Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Yeah.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Wow.
Heat.
[Music]
Wow.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Woo!
Heat!
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
for
the Lord.
[Music]
I
Oh,
hey.
[Applause]
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
[Music]
Oh.
Yeah.
[Music]
Heat.
My body is
my body.
[Music]
My body is
born.
My heart is
my heart is here.
Heat. Heat.
[Laughter]
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Welcome back, Riftbounders, to day two
of the Riftbound regional qualifier in
Houston, Texas.
Yesterday, we saw various legends strike
the stage for a chance at glory. Kai'Sa,
Master Yi, and Annie emerged as the top
strategies. But legends like Volibar,
Yasuo, and Leona are still in
contention.
After nine rounds of Swiss, 64 players
remain. Single elimination is the name
of the game now, and it's anyone's
showdown. Cash, promos, and the best of
legends are still on the line, but in
the end, there can only be one.
Hold on to your battlefields. The first
ever English regional qualifier champion
will be crowned today.
It is absolutely crazy that 64 players
are going to be competing today for the
first ever English regional qualifier
champion. I'm Bear Bryant joined this
morning with Frank Scaren. Frank,
what a surprise it is to see these 64
players and the diversity that we have
in this tournament still heating up.
>> Yeah, I think today is going to be a
really amazing day. You know, yesterday
we had over a thousand folks show up to
battle for these top 64 slots. And now
that we're here, we're going to see some
great single elimination play. And what
that means is every round players are
going to be fighting for their
tournament lives. And that's just kind
of the peak of competition to me.
All or nothing, single elimination is
the highest level of anxiety, at least
for me, when it comes to sitting down in
these like professional tournament
settings. And it's also not even just
that. There can only ever be one burst
ever. And this is it right now, at least
for, you know, the English regional
qualifiers. And with the Origins format
where we have all of these 16 legends
across, you know, Origins and the
Proving Grounds, it is just so exciting
to me to see the diversity that we have
in our current format and with all the
people and expectations that I think
people thought they had is not
necessarily the story that we're
telling. Yes, of course, we have our
very strong decks that we can talk
about, but Annie Annie really rising to
the occasion in this event. And when we
look at the games yesterday on stream,
you see why people and it is now the
third most represented legend at this
event as a whole. The tricks that this
deck can pull off to 20 charact legends
like Kai'Sa really showed off yesterday
on stream.
>> Yeah, you know, if we look at our our
metagame breakdown here, you do see the
kind of like boogeymen of the format,
Kai'Sa and Yei showing up, performing,
having really solid conversion rates. Uh
but then yeah, you also have some great
follow-ups coming from Annie,
Misfortune, really showing off. And then
even as you go down, there are, you
know, a couple players who are clearly
just masters of their legend and decided
like, hey, I'm really going to go off
the beaten path here. Maybe they're
making, you know, shots at the best of
metal legends. Or maybe they just feel
like I've really just like mastered what
Victor has to offer, what Yaso has to
offer, and I know that I could beat all
these folks who are going to show up
with Kais because I know exactly what
they're going to do and exactly how to
get around it. Yeah, I I just even look
at looking at 27 Kaises, 11 Ye, 11
Annies and you know, Teemo rising even
further to the top. You know, we have
iconic players that we got to showcase
yesterday. Prismaticism showcasing that
legend that did well not only in Vegas
really putting in a lot of extra
confidence into players to test out and
bring a deck like that. And spoiler
alert, our Swiss champ at the end of
yesterday was one of these not one of
these top three here. Frank Misfortune
Dazzling Aurora ended up cream of the
crop at the end of yesterday. Yeah, I
was really impressed with all the
matches I saw for Misfortune Dazzling
Aurora yesterday. You know, coming to
this event, I kind of had a picture of
the deck in my mind where I'm like, "Oh,
you know, if they don't find the
Dazzling Aurora, their deck doesn't
function." And then I just saw time and
time again these decks winning without
even drawing Dazzling Aurora. And that's
kind of when I got the vibe like, "Okay,
these players have figured it out. They
know how to build this deck to win even
when they don't have their major piece."
>> Absolutely. And some of my fan
favorites, of course, Victor, Yaso, and
Darius still showing up some
representation. And like I said before,
you know, a sneaky Volibar and a Leona
of two coming in here. But we do have
our rest of our legends going in here.
And you can also see some representation
of the legends that didn't necessarily
make the cut. But as you can see, Ari
set, Leona, Jinx, Lux, and Garen.
There's some metallics that are going to
be handed out even before we get into
this top 64.
>> Yeah, I know a decent amount of players
have locked up their best of Metal
Legend. I'm sure they're, you know,
maybe you didn't make day two, but hey,
that metal legend is a great consolation
prize. I will say a little surprised to
see set didn't uh put anyone into the
into the second day.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And here we have our
standing breakdown as well. Some of
these players we were very lucky to
showcase. You know, I see Allen's Q here
in fifth place with Kaiser going 70
and2. And like I said at the beginning,
Misfortune, Bounty Hunter, 8-1, but
great players we've seen all day. And I
can't ask for a better representation,
honestly. Yeah, I mean it's just been
amazing to see all these kind of masters
and legends from all these different
card games kind of show up to
conglomerate and fight it out in
Riftbound and like I don't know just
really magical people I've kind of grown
up with as acquaintances or friends or
idols and they're a lot of them are just
here battling it out to see who's the
who's the best Riftbound player of the
day.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Speaking of battling
it out, you know, there's that Volibar,
we have Malik X that we have the
pleasure of showcasing making it all the
way through here in 20th seed. There's
that Yaso at 32nd. We're going to
quickly go through the rest of these, of
course, but Teemo representation still
here. Victor and there is Jeff Jones. We
got to showcase as well on Lein, the
only one still in the tournament. And
it's it's so fun when I'm in the
position of someone like Jeff Jones
where you're the only Le in Top Cuts.
You're already locked in that metallic
prize, best of. So now you're just
playing for the best seating. And of
course, you want to go home with some of
these other wonderful prizes that we
have access to here at this event
because they're still playing for cash.
They're still playing for promos. And
man, the prestige Buccaneer Misfortune
Frank, it looks oh so beautiful.
>> Oh, it's gorgeous. And I think a really
important thing to note, Barrett, is
anyone can win this event from this
point.
>> Absolutely. Single elimination like we
pointed out earlier, but of course,
first player going home with $6,000 in
their pocket. And of course, they would
go home with the best up prizing as
well. Of course, in the mat with the
Misfortune Buccaneers. Second place,
3,000 going all the way down for top 32.
So, it almost makes you think, Frank,
let me put this in your mind a little.
This is a cut to top 64. That means you
still have to win one round if you want
to go home with any money.
>> Yeah, I think players are kind of going
to be feeling that pressure this round.
You know, it's kind of like a great
benchmark to be like, "Hey, I cashed
this event. I'm feeling good." And yeah,
so a lot of pressure is going to be on
this first round.
>> Absolutely. Speaking of pressure, I have
a lot of pressure when I think of coming
to a highle event like this. So, I'm a
little more of a comfy cozy kind of
person, Frank, myself. So, I like to
stay home at my local game store where I
can go and check out the Nexus Knights.
And we know that there's the incredible
Teemo promos, the GG Eezys that are
going around that you can try and get
your hands on if you can go to
locator.ribbound.uvsgames.com/events.
You can check out some stores where you
can go and participate in Nexus Knights.
But if you want to get a little bit more
of that competitive itch, there's the
next step further. We've got the
summoner skirmishes that you can also
participate to. If you go to
uvsgames.com/ribbound-organized-play,
you can find out where your summoner
skirmish is going to be held locally
near you. And there's some fun. You
know, I remember the Blitzcrank promos,
trinameirs that are being handed out at
least for the origins. And we have even
more unique stuff probably coming out
here in the future for Spirit Forge,
too.
>> Oh, definitely. Barrett. And you know, I
got to say those Nexus nights, me and a
bunch of people from the Riot office. We
go to our local one, play. It's a great
time. Just have fun, meet people in the
community, and just like, you know, it's
casual. It's comfy. It's just like you
said.
>> Yeah, absolutely. But Frank, the
tournament must go on. Top 64 is ready
to begin and get underway as we have our
first match coming up here shortly and
I'm excited to see who we have. We've
got that Malik X on Volibar who we
showcased earlier on day one versus
Dewali on Annie. Incredible match up
here and can you give me a little bit of
insight because when I think of Annie in
the aggressive nature, but Volibar needs
a little bit of time to get those mighty
units into play. Yeah, you know this is
if you told me that a Volibear player
was going to make this deep run, I
definitely would have been suspicious,
especially because I think the metag
game is driving pretty aggressive right
now. Especially because you see these
Annies kind of just crushing players
with their blitz starts and Volibear
does need that setup time. But clearly
Mal has figured it out because Oh.
Oh yeah, absolutely. We're actually
going to swap over to a different one.
We've got Master Yi versus Victor. This
is Gambit 01 versus Ghosty here going in
unless we swap back over.
So yeah, okay, we're going to do the
Volibar versus Annie instead. But I'm
interested here because this aggressive
nature, we have Zon Warren for game one
going for Dewali versus the Asperence
climb from Alec X. And that I think is
the scariest battlefield if I'm playing
Annie because I do not want the game to
go longer than basically eight points
because the deck is so good at getting
that double conquer when you get to six
and now we have to delay it a whole
extra point.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think you're right there
Barrett that aspirin's climb is kind of
the breadandbut battlefield for decks
like Volibear. just getting to push the
game back just that one extra point and
Annie really is optimized to get exactly
to eight as quickly as possible. It can
really change the texture of a game.
>> And for everybody at home, this top uh
this top 64 is still 50 minutes per
round and then still following the round
procedures after time is called. So
these players must still play at the
same level they were playing yesterday,
but the stakes are even higher because
one match loss means you are eliminated
from the tournament. playing some
catchup, of course. Turn one, we see
obviously early on we want a two drop
from the traveling merchant, but we see
the iron ballista come out on the other
side, which is not a unit per se, but
can get the job done when it comes to
removing things.
>> Yeah, I will say every time I've seen
Mox put this iron ballista on the table,
it's been incredible. And I think this
is a big part of his game plan to kind
of slow the game down and make sure he
could do the late game bear things. And
even as you can see right here, Dwali
has to make the decision of, you know, I
want to score my only early points, but
if I put this traveling merchant into
this battlefield, it might just get
mowed down by the ballista on the
following turn.
>> Absolutely
thinking very early on here, you know, I
think both of these players know that
the stakes could not be higher in this
first round for top cuts. As we go to
the turn two here for Dewali, we did go
ahead and conquer into that Zon Warren.
Get all the conquer effects of move and
move abilities from the traveling
merchant. going to discard and draw
cards to our heart's content. And then
with three of our runes, we're going to
play this sneaky deck hand to
immediately get to double conquer on
turn two. And that's exactly the pace
that you need for this deck. Yeah, Dwali
just making the decision, hey, I'm going
to put that pressure on. Maybe I'm going
to lose some units to to the ballista,
but they will have scored me points. And
especially with the game going to nine.
I think that's a great call.
>> Oh, here comes Falling Star.
>> Yeah, the Falling Stars here getting a
lot of mileage for at least removing
both of the units off of the table. But
it makes me wonder because you could
have also just gotten rid of one of them
with the iron ballista effect, right?
>> Yeah. You know, that's a that is that is
an interesting play from Malik. I'm
guessing maybe he just didn't have
another great option for the turn and he
was like, "Hey, you know, if I just
ballista down one of these units, I'm
not going to get to take care of the
other one and then more points are going
to be scored by Dewali." This also does
play around flash quite well.
>> Yeah, because just cuz you move them,
they will still end up taking that
damage. But it looks like we want to get
at least one more move trigger out of
our traveling merchant beforehand, which
makes a lot of sense. But those units
are going straight to the trash. But our
trash is quickly getting filled up very
high. And that's exactly what we're
looking for eventually when we play
something like a VI. Yeah, it is
interesting to see Dwall use a flash
there just for the movement trigger and
the discard and draw. kind of tells me
that his hand is not ideal and he feels
like he really has to put something
together to make sure to keep that
pressure on because again if he can put
Voly Bear under the gun, Volibear is
going to do some really powerful late
game things that he's just not going to
be able to keep up with. Do you think
Malak X feels a little under the gun? I
mean that Falling Stars was our only
play for that turn and it does recycle
two runes to pay for its power cost
which is the opposite thing that Malibar
does which is ramping and channeling
more runes for sure. I'm I'm guessing
Malik figures that if he can slow the
game down enough, even if he's recycling
some runes of his own, as long as Wall-E
isn't scoring points, he feels
comfortable with kind of keeping that
pace and going into the later game
together, but with the point score low,
and that'll favor him.
>> Absolutely.
As for the turn back on the Dewali, we
are going to end up playing a very early
VI destructive here, which you know
makes it a little vulnerable for
something like another instance of a
falling star. But with the pouty porro
also coming in, we have set oursel up
for the double conquer. But keeping all
five of our runes ready here for Malik.
We're going to maybe hopefully have some
sort of tricks to slow down these
conquer and get these scores off the
table. Um but we have to deal with a
three might vi
deflect porro.
>> Yeah, you know, this is a very
interesting game cuz I feel like both
players decks kind of aren't exactly
doing the things they want them to do.
And it's always interesting when you see
more of a scrap and both players kind of
like fighting on the lower side of their
of their power spectrum. And I don't
know that Voly Bear has a has a ton of
cards they're looking to play on the
opponent's turn. So I'm interested to
see when Dwalli, you know, decides to
move for these battlefields if Malak is
going to have anything to contest or his
draw is just a little clunky. Yeah, off
the top of my head, I can't think of
anything aside from like maybe a void
seeker, but again, still talking about
the power cost that does still have one.
And it's just something you have to be
constantly thinking about the pace of
which Malik is going to accumulate runes
and get further and further up because
at the end of the day, we can only start
channeling with our legend when we play
mighty units. And you need to play five
might units. Usually that costs a little
bit higher than five.
>> Definitely. And especially if you know
there is a void seeker or hex techch ray
or something like that. Those are cards
that flash can get around. Now I do
think we saw Dwi play that one flash and
then discarded a second flash to the
traveling merchant. So there could be
one left. So you know much easier to
start firing that removal off when you
know the counters are in the trash.
Resolving our stacked deck. Two cards
going to the bottom. Of course there was
a stack deck that was already played
earlier this game as well um as we were
playing some catchup. But you know just
getting a lot of setup finding the exact
pieces we need here for Dewali. moving
in with this pouty porro, which is I
think the smartest one to move in first
because this one has deflect if there
may be some sort of trick from Malik.
>> Definitely. And you know, even if next
turn Malik is going to decide, hey, I
need to kill this porro with the
ballista. That's going to cost a rune
too cuz that goes through deflect just
like anything else. And as you say,
controlling the board is great, but
eventually Mox is going to have to, you
know, make his move and start getting
some of his bigger units on the table or
he's just going to slowly bleed out.
>> Yeah, going getting the conquer here,
which means we're going to get the Zon
Warren effect. Pitching a Gust makes
sense. A lot of these units have Vol of
air plays are out of the range for Gus
to work at least when getting rid of
theirs. But it means you are giving that
up to maybe protect one of your own
units.
>> Yeah, I think one of the reasons this
Annie deck has started to really show up
and have so much success is they just
have so many tools and so many options
for different matchups and because they
have all these, you know, discard and
draw effects and things like stack deck,
they can put these cards in their deck,
discard them when they're bad in the
matchup and just dig to find the ones
they need and are good for the matchup.
So I think Annie has really become one
of the most versatile decks in the metag
game right now.
This VI, do you think it is safe to move
it into a battlefield? Now as we see of
Darius being potentially played here,
but um we haven't I mean we have played
one card already with that stack deck.
Um the question or we all we played two
we sorry we had to double stack deck so
we've already played our second card.
the Darius won't get readyed in any
capacity. So when I look at this VI as
we are mount posturing with our trash,
is there a safe number here that you
think he would recycle to make it feel
like this VI can survive any sort of
shenanigans? So a really important thing
to call out about these single
elimination rounds. The players are
actually using open deck lists. So both
of these players know the complete
contents of the other players deck list.
So Dwali knows, you know, exactly what
types of cards Mallex can have and knows
if there is going to be a void or is
going to be a hex tech ray on the table.
Now, if you know those cards exist and
are in the deck, you can decide, hey,
I'm just going to pump Vi around them
and make sure that the removal is not
going to get me. Whereas, if it was a
closed deck situation, you'd kind of
have to make the judgment call. Is it
worth the risk or am I just recycling my
cards for nothing?
>> And that seems to be exactly what we're
doing. We chose to recycle two cards,
getting Vi up to five might, which is
exactly one over Void Seeker. Yeah, that
definitely communicates to me that
Dwalli just, you know, knows something's
going on in Alex's deck that he's
looking to play around and he would
rather spend some recycles now. Maybe Vi
is going to be a little smaller in the
future, but he just wants to secure
these early points and make sure he can
get on the board as quick as possible.
>> Yeah, we do see the incinerate. I did
see the flash of it in Malik's hand
here. So that one only does two to a
battlefield or unit at a battlefield of
course which is enough for the pouty
pora. But again that that pesky deflect
cost that we're going to have to deal
with anyway as this VI moves in.
>> Yeah. And it looks like in fact Malix
does not have great tools to interact
right now and is mostly just working
through a clunky hand. And you know
that's kind of the risk you take when
you sign up with Volibear. Sometimes you
know you're just a little slow out of
the gate but certainly wouldn't count
him out yet. He's been beating these
Annie and Kaisa decks all day and let's
see what he can do to get back on this
board.
>> Seven runes here. What do you think is
the ideal play that we can imagine
coming from Malik to come back into this
game?
>> So, seven runes is kind of the sad
number for Volibear, unfortunately. You
know, at nine you have Dazzling Aurora.
At eight, you have Dead Bloom Predator
to kind of jump in and fight you back
into the game. Seven, I honestly no
amazing plays jump to mind. And I think
Mal is going to have to look to piece
something together to slow the game
down. Oh, we do have a Nivea. That is
true. That's pretty cool. That is a very
unique card that Volbear plays that, you
know, you don't see in the other
variants like Misfortune. And it's a
really tough call. Like, do you want to
get Anivia on the table right now? Cuz I
believe I saw a dazzling Aurora in
Malax's hand.
Yeah, I mean the fact that we're if we
pay this recycle cost, but with the
conjunction of the ability from the
legend getting one back to us is going
to put us here to six, which doesn't put
us obviously into dazzling range like
you said, but instead could find us in a
dead bloom range like you just
mentioned. Um the Anivvia here, I I
don't see this card seeing play
basically at all except for Balibars
like you said, getting to get that eight
might unit onto the board without paying
the power cost from Dazzling. But the
the attack the triggered ability that
works when you attack with it dealing
three to all units on a battlefield.
Don't you think that's like a perfect
ability against something like this Ann
deck? All these units are small.
>> Yeah, it's a really great option. You
know, it gets around things like deflect
because it's more of an AoE effect. And
I think it's the kind of thing where,
you know, when Ania moves into the
battlefield, any units there are going
to die or have to retreat back to base
through something like a flash. Um, and
I think Malak really made a a super
smart call here to be like, "Hey, I can
wait until next turn to get this
Dazzling Aurora down. But if I do that,
I'm going to be so far behind in points
that it's just not going to matter." And
he's like, "I need to get this Anibia on
the table to give me a fighting chance."
Speaking of behind in points, as the
double hold comes in here for Dewali,
we're going to go up to six, which in a
normal game would be the exact number
Dwali wants to do to bring these units
back into our base, as we're already
going to be doing right here. But then
we could set up for the double conquer
play with Vi and get it as big as we
need it to based off of cards in our
trash. But we do now have an extra point
we have to play for. So instead just
keeping those units safe now. Yeah,
again aspirin's climb is going to give
Malix an extra turn of cushion to work
with which is going to be huge if he
does manage to mount a comeback into
this game. It's pretty much going to be
solely thanks to the aspirin's climb
just showing off how it's such a
powerful battlefield for these slower
decks. But even though Dwalli isn't
threatening the double conquer to eight
next turn, I imagine he's still got to
love his position. He's got a ton of
great units in play. He has Vi with a
pretty sizable trash and he kind of just
has to pace his threats in a way to make
sure he has enough to just keep
overcoming a big unit or two and he
might be able to close this game out at
nine just as easily.
>> It was as simple as move my units back
past. We didn't spend any of the runes
we have access to to even play something
like Annie Stubborn to maybe recycle a
spell back from our trash. We didn't do
any something like that. We're keeping
so many of our runes up. But at the same
time, if you're not really going to get
any interaction from Malik here, those
like if you you don't create a chain in
any capacity, obviously a showdown might
occur if this Anivvia moves up, there's
no instance for us to be using any of
the cards in our hand.
>> That is definitely true. But on the same
end, if Malix doesn't do anything that
creates, you know, a chain or a showdown
and gives Dwall an opportunity to play
cards, that also means Mix hasn't really
done much himself. And I think given the
score disparity right now, that that
trade would favor Dwali. I did also
happen to see, I believe it's a Rebuke
peeking out in his hand.
>> Wow.
>> Which would line up super well against
this Enivia right now. Huge tempo swing,
but I also think Malix has a sabotage.
>> Yeah, it's going to be about the reads
here. here. I can only imagine before
you make any sort of decisions, we saw
this a lot with set decks yesterday, um
being able to mainboard cards like
sabotage to get around very pesky
answers in your opponent's hand like the
rebuke because rebuke is something you
don't want to see because once I play
the units for free off of something like
Dazzling, I don't want to have to pay
for their cost.
>> Definitely. And you know it's it's it's
it's a really tough decision here for
Malix because sabotage getting you know
if it hits nothing important you kind of
just spent a power to really not do much
and you know his development is already
struggling but at the same time if he
hits something like that rebuke it could
really break up Dwali's plan and get him
back into the game.
>> Catalyst of Aons to give us two more
runes here getting us very close but
we're just going to end up using one of
the runes that we have for playing a
sabotage just like you said. And now we
have full information. That third flash
we do see here and of course the rebuke.
But I mean as we're kind of noting here,
not a lot of play, not a lot of cards to
play with here for Dwalli. Definitely.
And I I love seeing this rebuke in the
main deck from Dwali. I feel like a lot
of players kind of shy away from cards
like that in the main deck and play
mostly the lean and efficient cards, but
Dwali really leaning into that sort of
toolbox strategy we spoke about for
Annie and being like, "Hey, I'm going to
have that in the main deck because I
could find it when I need it and just
discard it when I don't." And a really
important thing to note here is sabotage
does recycle the card. but it doesn't
put it in the trash. So now not even
Annie Stubborn can get it back.
>> Absolutely. Um but important to know
also I I brought this up a little bit
yesterday, but I want to I want to kind
of pick your brain from it. Once you
know all the cards that your opponent
has access to in their hand, obviously
we know that there was a sneaky deck
hand and the flash there. That was a
prime opportunity at least when if I'm
Malik. Oh, there's not a lot that you're
going to be doing next turn. At least
with not with units you already had to
your disposal on the field.
Yeah, it's interesting because we see
Malik hold this Anivvia back here and he
could have gotten in there. He could
have scored a point, gotten on the
board, but I imagine he's thinking,
well, if I put Anivvia in, she's
probably going to trade back, maybe even
take down a Darius or a VI with her, but
then she'll be off the board. Dwali will
still be able to score the points he
needs to score this round. And I think
Mox is going to look for more. Next turn
is when he's going to make his power
play and look to establish some really
strong holds and attempt to just fully
lock out of either holding or double
conquering for that ninth point. The
catalyst of aons from last turn actually
makes a lot of sense now when we now
play this incinerate to get rid of the
pouty porro that we brought up earlier
this game. Now with the runes to afford
that deflect cost, but we can still set
oursel up to potentially slam down a
dazzling Aurora next turn because we did
that channel.
>> Definitely. We saw a really great sweat,
Kasano and I, yesterday where you know
you needed to flip a dead bloom predator
off of the dazzling Aurora to stay in
the game. I believe it was Malax who did
it. I'm not I can't remember for sure,
but the dead bloom was hit and we might
see that same situation here again when
these players are playing for their
tournament lives.
>> Absolutely. If Dewali at least with no
other investment from the cards in hand,
of course, we know that that sneaky or
uh that deck hand is in our hand. So we
don't have to put this Vi in danger for
a double conquer, but that Deckand is
going to be very easily killed off by
this Anivia just on attack, not even
through, you know, actually combating
against each other. But this Darius is
going to be a little more pesky. But if
Dwali wants to get up to eight points
this turn, I think that Decan's probably
coming into play.
>> Yeah. And you know, the thing that I
love about Vi is she is sort of the
ultimate contingency plan. It's like the
threat of the Vi is more valuable than
the Vi itself. You don't use Vi until
you absolutely have to. She sits there
and she's just like, "Hey, when you need
me, I'm gonna be like a 12 might unit
with ganking to go in there and mess
things up." And Dwalli just doing that
perfectly, leaving Vi in the base,
making sure she doesn't get threatened
by removal and keeping her to score that
last point when the time comes.
>> This is actually going to be a lot
bigger. The the draw for turn was Kaiser
Survivor. What an incredible draw
because it's an accelerated unit we can
play right now. Has an unconquer draw
that we're doing. And then the conquer
ability from the ZH Warren means that
all of a sudden that level of mystique
that Malik X Malik X knew almost
everything that was in Wally hand. And
now all of a sudden we know nothing.
>> Yeah, the speed at which the Annie deck
churns through cards is very impressive.
And you you may think you know their
hand, but their hand is going to change
real quick.
And Dwali really doing exactly what he
needs to do knowing I'm just going to
score my points. I'm going to make sure
I have enough oomph to get through on
the following turn for the last points.
And we're gonna have to see if Malak can
put together a powerful enough force on
these battlefields to box him out
>> because you know Dewali currently
doesn't have something like a fight or
flight in hand. Is it maybe the decision
here where we have to not just swing
with our Anibia to get onto the board,
but whatever unit we may find. If it's
not the Dead Bloom Predator, do we just
have to overload one battlefield to deny
or No, cuz we have to contest both
battle. The Darius hold point is enough
to get us there. I'm Yeah, point is at
eight, not not seven. So, you have to
clear both battlefields, which means we
are, like you said, just looking for a
dead bloom either from hand or from the
top from a dazzling. Yeah, I believe Mal
has reached a point where he kind of
can't play around anything anymore. He's
like, "Maybe I have a fight or flight.
Maybe it would suck for me, but if I
don't try, I'm going to lose." So, my
expectation is at this point, he's just
going to shove everything he has at
these battlefields and hope it's good
enough.
10 runes to play with, which means
dazzling is all but basically everything
that you have access to, which makes me
think, what are we going to still do
about this VI with us L if even if Dwali
loses the two units he has at these two
battlefields? It's more cards in our
trash to feed for this VI. So that
something like a dead bloom predator
with only one ready rune up that would
be for Malik if the Dazzling comes down.
There's no tricks to help your Predator
stay alive.
>> That is true. And I mean, I think at
this point, Malik would have to just
pray there's no rider ride the wind to
back up this VI and that she'd only be
able to take one of the giant
battlefields. And really heads up play
by Malix here, using the iron ballista
on the Darius before moving in with the
Anivvia. So now the Anivia's attack
trigger will be enough to finish Darius
off. And this closes out windows for a
fighter flight. But what it doesn't
close out a window for is the third
flash because flash is a reaction. And
Dwall's been holding on to that for a
while. and it's going to pay him off
perfectly to get Darius back into the
base.
>> Now the question here is that you do you
also target your Kai'Sa bring it back
because if there's one thing that you
can do is if you get off of the
battlefield means you're not contesting
it. Dead bloom can only be played at
contested battlefields or of course
places you already control. So it would
force the dead bloom to then reinforce
the Anivvia. And yeah, as you can see
here, hands on the head from Dwali. That
is exactly what he's thinking about.
He's like, I know if I hold this
battlefield, I win, but I know the one
thing that really punishes me is Dead
Bloom Predator. And he's got to think
based on the context of the game, the
texture, the decisions that Malix has
made is the Dead Bloom Predator in the
hand. If he suses out that it's a
dazzling Aurora flip, is that a chance
he wants to take? And you know, this is
making me think he actually doesn't have
the Ride the Wind in his hand because if
he did, I think this would be a pretty
easy decision because Vi would just
clean it up either way. But he is going
to retreat that Kai'Sa as well.
>> Well, we know he's been fishing for it.
I mean, right when the sabotage was
played, we had very full access. We did
draw a bunch of cards and then discard,
you know, draw discard.
We're looking for it, but if you're
right, if we don't grab it off the top,
then a double conquer play is not
something that we're going to do. Looks
like the decision is to pull back that
Kai'Sa and not have any of the contested
battlefields now. Yeah, and I think this
was just a a great play by Dwalli at the
end of the day because I think he's
saying the only thing I could lose to
from this position is a dead bloom
predator that kind of snowballs the
tempo against me and he just doesn't
want to put himself in that spot. So,
he's going to play it a little more
conservatively, pull that Kai'Sa back,
fire off a void seeker on Anvia, I
imagine just to see another card and
keep digging for that ride the wind. It
doesn't look like the Anivia is actually
going to be taken off the table.
>> It's an interesting interaction, too.
One of the things I do love about this
game is that even though we used that
flash at reaction speed, the showdown
still occurs for an actiontime spell
like Voidseeker 2 exists once the focus
still gets passed to you, the showdown
happens even if you don't have a unit
there. And I love being able to still
use cards like Void Seeker for that
cycle draw even if you don't get the
full effect of it.
>> For sure. And that's one of the core
strengths of Annie with that dark child
legend. You get to ready two runes.
other decks kind of have to decide, do I
want to play for tempo on my turn or
hold up tricks on my opponent's turn?
Annie just gets to do it both. And I
think that's a lot of why she's been
seeing success.
>> I sure would like to play a deck that
has um plays on multiple facets of the
game, right? It's not just about playing
on my turn. It's about playing a lot of
the time on your opponent's turn as
well. And now Mal is going to have to
decide what can I do to stop the win
next turn. It looks like he's decided
his best option is slap a Kadricken down
into this battlefield to go alongside
Anivvia and hope the two of them can
hold on against these big numbers that
are going to be coming in from Annie
next turn. Channel our bonus room
because it is a mighty unit. It's going
to draw us two cards because it does
include itself when it comes into the
battlefield or in play I should say. So
drawing two here. Are we fishing for
anything in particular you think to stay
in this game? Yeah. So, the one card
that I think that could potentially help
Malik fortify this hole is I believe
it's called Stormbringer. Uh, it's the
spell that gets reduced by the greatest
might among units you have. You still
have to pay a power for it, but
effectively from an energy point. It
would be free. Deals five damage. It
might be able to help to catch Dwali off
guard, but oo, there's a fighter flight.
>> And I think that's it. That fighter
flight alone that we dug for, try to get
through so many cards is going to be
game one going to the Dwali on Annie.
Yeah, great game. I think you really
kind of just saw Annie put on a clinic
there. Mix had some clunky early turns.
Dwali did exactly what he needed to do
to punish. But now the second game, Mox
is going to be going first with an
obelisk of power for an extra rune. And
we'll see if he can get a more explosive
start. Speaking of explosive starts
though, the Dreaming Tree coming in for
Annie. And Frank, I have seen Dreaming
Tree for Annie pop off yesterday. They
have so many of their cards that target
their own units that you're just going
to get so much mileage. I saw more
mileage for Annie on Dreaming Tree than
Kai'Sa on Dreaming Tree by far
yesterday.
>> Yeah, Dreaming Tree definitely one of
the more powerful battlefields in the
game, especially for decks that can
fully take advantage of it. And Annie is
one of those decks. You know, you've got
your ride the winds, maybe your cleaves,
all the stuff like that. And we've
thought we saw Annie move through a lot
of cards last game. I think this game is
going to take it to a next level. But on
the other side, kicking things off early
with the catalyst of aons and the
obelisk of power. Really getting that
amplification of channeling runes. We're
already at seven runes here for Malix,
which means we'll be at nine. That's
dazzling range immediately off the get-
go. Yeah, catalyst of Aon's pretty much
the exact card that Mallex wants to see.
I think if he could start it I think if
he could start with Dazzling Aurora or
Catalyst in his opening hand every
single game, he might just choose
Catalyst. It's the thing that makes his
deck hum. and he is going to go behind
on points, but this game I think he's
going to have some quicker follow-ups to
get back.
>> The fact that we're going to start
playing cards when uh Dewali is only at
two points versus when we were at six
already at the other game and experience
climb being the only reason why that
game was delayed even a little bit
further. But a Draven coming down here,
Draven uh Showboat of course, which
scales in might as the uh score goes up
for us. Already now at five might. And
there it is, the fast dazzling Aurora.
And you know, this is just going to
start putting a lot of numbers on the
board for Malix very quickly.
>> This is my favorite game is when we go
through. And we got a Magma Wororm here.
It's going to come into play. And now it
also says that all other friendly units
enter ready. And it's still got eight
might to go with. It's going to come
straight to our base.
>> Yeah, Magma Worm kind of the investment
hit for the deck. It's like, okay, it's
not going to impact the board right now,
but let me tell you, when the next giant
monster hits and goes straight into the
battlefield, Dwali is going to feel it.
It even fixes the weakness of what I
would say of dazzling Aurora decks is
when you draw the units into your hand.
It allows you to still play them and
it's as if all of them have a free
accelerate to go with them as long as
Magma worm is still on the board.
>> Yeah. And it'll be interesting to see
what Dwalli does this game when, you
know, just kind of a little more
contention. Last game, we kind of got to
saw see him score points for free, move
out in his own time, and now he's going
to have to play that back and forth of
when do I want to pick my spots? When do
I want to sacrifice these units to
score?
Hold double hold here for up to four
score on Dewali. We still have this
Draven of course back at home. Can only
imagine just the double retreat here uh
or double go back to base and including
with this traveling merchant. Want to
start cycling through more cards. That
was the success that we had in game one.
We want to still do it here obviously in
game two.
>> Definitely. And I love the Draven
Vanquisher here from Dwali. It can get
big enough towards the end of the game
that it can actually go toe-to-toe with
some of Volibear's strongest units just
by itself. Yeah, already up to seven now
as we have four points, but the poor is
going to come back. We did end up
pitching a ride the win saying, "Well, I
won the game last time without it. I
don't really think I need this." And
then of course Annie Stubborn can come
in at any point and help pick that up.
>> Yeah, that's the great part about Annie
Stubborn. I feel like there are a lot of
games where you don't play it. Maybe
Dwali keeps it in the champ zone, but
it's kind of is just there as the
insurance where it's like maybe I did
discard one of my key pieces early, but
I can just get it back whenever I need
it.
Darius Trifarian coming down here and
we're just going to pass the turn. No
need to play a second card obviously
because we're already doing very well on
our own in the board state as we move
all of our units back to our base. We're
going to pass back to Malik. But now
this is the time for Malik to stabilize.
What kind of units do you think we're
looking for here? Open battlefields.
This is your time to really get on to
them. But how do you keep them? So, I
think this is really the point where
kind of almost any of them will do. As
long as Malik is playing a unit that,
you know, cost 8 to 10 energy and then
putting a unit that costs 8 to 10 energy
in off of the Aurora, he's going to be
happy. He does have that Volibear in the
zone. And I believe he's at 10 runes.
Yep. And there it is.
>> Yeah, the Bali Bear Furious coming into
play here, which is going to be very
nice because this helps even with more
removal as it attacks. And that deflect
to being very pesky to be overcosting
things like uh fighter flight on the
other side of the board.
>> Definitely
>> getting our channel of course from our
legend ability. And we still have a
dazzling proc that we're going to have.
And of course it comes in ready. And
that's so nice cuz we're going to be
able to contest both battlefields here,
but just keeping them at home instead.
And here comes Anivvia again being able
to have some removal if Dewali wants to
go to that six points, which we know
that's what his deck wants to do.
>> Yeah. And Malik's really really got to
respect his patience here. I feel like a
lot of players might think, "Oh my god,
I'm behind on points. If they score
again, it's going to be six to zero. I
need to get this Magma worm in there or
this Volibear in there just to get on
the board and try to contest." But I
think he knows that the Annie deck has
so many tools to just come over the top
of a one big unit or two that he's just
going to going to buckle down and try to
turtle up on a following turn where he
has more agency over how the combats
will go.
I think it's really important here that
Dwali still has access to this pouty
porro and this traveling merchant
because these are the only two units you
feel like you have to put at risk at
this moment keeping things like the
Darius and the Draven the brotherly duo
for when you need to actually go through
and break through all these units that
we know Malik has to put on the
battlefields next turn. Yeah, Barrett. I
think I think on Dwall's next turn, we
are going to see a clash of the Titans
where, you know, the Noxis brothers are
going to go fight the monsters of the
Fiord and see who comes out on top.
>> That's my favorite. Um, as we as our
players are going through motions and
getting effects through as they are
basically setting up for this giant
battle as you said. Uh, it's very uh
Knox versus Failure is what it feels
like specifically. I I'm super excited
going forward in in Spirit Forge that
someone can play Darius the legend and
in 2v2 they can play it right next to
their brother Draven coming out in
Spirit for Forge. So I'm excited to see
stuff like that. But of course what we
have right now is how much might can
Dwali posture and put up going into next
turn because there's a lot of units on
the other side. Yeah, I think a really
important piece for him is going to be
if he could find a VI to put on the
table because Vi kind of, you know,
represents the biggest number that you
could have. It doesn't look like there's
one here now, but it's possible he could
also be keeping it safe in his hand to
play around something like a falling
star and combine it with a ride the wind
on the final on the following turn to
get the job done.
>> Passing with all of our runes still
ready here for Dewali. Going back to
Malik,
what do you think is going to be here?
So, I think Mallex is right back in the
position he was in the first game where
he just he's out of options to play
around things. The patience has to end
and this is the point where he has to
make his move into the battlefield and
try to establish that hold. And it's
going to be tough, but I've learned not
to count this Volibear deck out. They
can turn games around from 6, 70, and
win in the end.
>> Ania being moved up to contest the
obelisk of power against the Pouty
Porro. And yes, the Inivia ability that
says when I attack, it'll deal three to
all of the enemy units here. Does get
around the deflect. So now it is up to
the Dwali if he wants to play a reaction
speed spell or action or has to be
reaction because of the attack trigger.
But we do have the flash which is going
to bring back the Porro and the
traveling merchant. Will get the move
trigger as well. Immediately conceding
the other battlefield though with it.
>> Yeah, I think you could see from the
board that either that Volibear or Magma
Worm would just come in and chomp the
merchant anyway. So getting it out of
there, getting some hand smoothing. And
I will say, I think I just got a pretty
good peek at Dwall's hand, and it looks
diabolical. I think there's a fight
orflight. I think there's a rebuke. Just
a ton of these really strong chaos cards
that just line up perfectly against the
giant monsters.
It almost looks like kind of like the
writing on the wall then if this ends up
being the case. But you're right, I'm
don't want to sell Malik out because I
think we can see some massive units. I
think of like, you know, the giant 12
cost Volibar that could potentially be
in this deck just for us to have extra
might on the board. It has shield. But
of course, without deflect on that unit,
it is susceptible to things like rebuke.
So, you have to constantly be putting up
enough threats to get through it.
>> Yeah, it'll it'll be interesting to see.
I'm sure Dwali if he thinks he can go
for it and he has to sack all his runes
to do it,
>> he will.
>> I would see. I think he would. But Malak
really just thinking, how can I get as
much might on this board as possible?
Play around as many tricks as I can.
He's got a pretty handful of cards and
still has that Aurora flip on the table.
Hopefully some removal to come with it
as well. I think that's going to be one
of the key pieces here is just totally
reducing the amount of might that you
have to worry about on defense. We saw
Falling Stars in game one. It would get
some of the work done here. Dead bloom
predator from hand going to support the
Anivvia. Extra deflect on here makes it
a little bit harder to choose. Of
course, of course, we have a lot of
runes under wall side, but with the
channel going to come through here.
Three extra readied runes for Malik.
That is enough to still play something
like that falling star.
>> Yep. Double the might on the battlefield
real quick. Get your number as high as
you can and see what else you can do to
trim down Dwall's board.
two. There is the falling start from
hand as we recycle and we're going ahead
to pick up the third one because we just
want to get rid of as much as we can
here. The Draven incredibly out of range
as we are now at nine might for it and
the Darius would require both of those
triggers. Yeah, one of one of my
favorite parts about the eb and flow of
a riftbound game like this is both
players spent the early turn building up
their runes, getting to the high energy
count to play their powerful cards, and
now they're burning it all down for the
powerful power cards to get the to close
it out.
>> Yeah, here we have a sabotage for the
last rune that Malik is going to play.
And he basically looks and sees every
spell and trick that is going to be
coming from Dwali. I think the biggest
thing to note here is that there's not a
VI. It is only these tricks like rebuke
and fight or flight. Those two would be
currently enough to move the current two
units off of the battlefield to go for a
double conquer play with his two units
on board. But we still have a couple of
units that Malik has to make the
decision on where to assign based off of
what we recycle here. That's a great
call, Barrett. And I think, you know,
Malik does see that hand, sees there is
a ride the wind and is like, okay, if a
VI comes, I'm just going to lose. But
there is no VI right now. So instead,
he's going to fight against what he
knows, get rid of the rebuke, and
hopefully give him a fighting chance to
hold on to one of these battlefields.
>> Not moving up our other two units.
instead. Here comes the trigger on the
dazzling aurora. A second dead bloom
predator coming into play to reinforce
with those other ones. And it's nice
because it's double deflect unit and an
eight my body across for all three of
them with the Anivvia.
>> Yeah, Mik's really staking his claim
saying I don't think you could break
this battlefield and I'm going to keep
these other two big units in the back
because I think I'm going to get another
turn and use them to fight for the other
one.
>> Absolutely. I hope that is the case. Of
course, there's a draw and now a stacked
deck that Dewali does have access to to
hopefully find what he's looking for to
maybe break through. I also just wonder,
obviously, I can't see how many cards
are in the trash right now, but even if
something like Avi were to come through,
you finding it off the top with the
stack deck, do we even have enough cards
in our trash to contest the amount of
might that's going on at this
battlefield?
>> Uh, it is hard to tell exactly how many
are in there right now. Um, but we do
have Draven currently at a nine. Darius
easily representing seven. The dead
blooms in Anivvia are quite large, but
that's only 24. It doesn't take too much
more to get over that hump, especially
because we know there's at least a fight
or flight coming in here from Dwalli.
>> Yeah, gonna go ahead and use it right
away
to send back, I would assume, the
Anivia. They're all the same might, but
that one doesn't have deflect, so you
don't have to pay the extra cost on it.
>> Yeah, Anivvia goes back. And this is
this might be a spot where we really see
Annie Stubborn shine to come in and reby
that effect.
>> Yeah, that seems to be the play here.
Annie Stubborn going to pick up
hopefully that one as we will be able to
afford it.
>> Uh-oh. And I think I think the math is
lining up quite well here for Dwalli
because with Draven at a nine, Draven
can just take down a dead bloom predator
1 v one and then Darius could
potentially go to the Dreaming Tree to
score the other point and end the game.
>> Yeah, got to pay that deflect cost.
We're going to recycle with the bonus.
And so with that being played as well,
Darius even gets an extra two might
going to the seven and it would ready if
it was exhausted. But yeah, the Draven
being over the top. There has to be some
sort of free trick, something you
mentioned storm surge in game one.
That'd be the only thing I can imagine
right here to help solidify staying into
this game.
>> Yeah, and I think Dwali is realizing
that right now. He's deciding, hey, is
there any opportunity for me to play
around this? But it looks like he's kind
of committed to this line and we'll see
if he goes for it. he could decide, hey,
I need to cut my losses and be patient
here. And this is, you know, this is the
spot where you really got to big think
because these games matter a ton.
Whichever player loses this match will
be out of the tournament. So, this is
not where you want to be hasty and just
try to clinch what feels like a win.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You have to be
incredibly smart here. And with our two
extra readied runes as well, if we did
still have the ride the win, we could
find a world where if some if Oh my
goodness, with the extra cost, it it
does end up being free as well.
>> And there it is.
>> This is exactly what Malak needed to
have a fighting chance still in this
game. I believe it's Skysplitter.
>> Yep, Skysplitter is reduced based off of
the highest might total you have. And we
have all the might in the world. And
this is now threatening to contest that.
And you would need an extra unit
basically now if they still trade with
each other.
>> Yeah. So this is this the skysplitter
won't be enough to just take the Draven
out. Yeah.
>> The Draven and the Dead Bloom Predator
would both die and go to the trash here.
>> Dwalli still has Darius ready to go and
I believe is maybe holding on to a ride
the wind. So we'll have to see how this
combat goes. And Dwall might still be
able to sneak both battlefields in the
end.
>> Yeah, we could ride the wind that Annie
or even just the Darius over afterwards
on the Conqueror. But that means there
could potentially be another answer to
the Darius. But this is a seven might
Darius. And there's the conquer point
going to seven. Ride the wind here on
the Darius. There's the handshake. Game
two and the match going to Dewali on
Annie.
>> Yeah, really, really amazing showing
from Twalli. He played that Annie deck
to perfection. And you got to give big
props to Mix 2. Super deep run with
Volibear. I believe he locked up that
Metal Legend, which you know, that's a
great consolation prize. So, I'm sure
he's really happy with his performance.
And anytime I saw him on camera, he was
playing great.
>> Yeah. I mean, the fact that there's
representation for all the volleyball
players across the world here at our
Houston, Texas regional qualifier and
he's going to go home with that metal
one. So, I hope to see him sporting that
medal volar in the future even because
obviously that legend is not going
anywhere. It's going to be incredibly
powerful in the future as well. But we
have another match of course that we're
able to dive into. We even gave a sneak
preview for our viewers earlier. Um, but
yes, we do have our next match that
we're going to be diving into for top
64. Congratulations to Dewali making it
to top 32. He's going home with a little
bit of extra cash in his pocket.
>> Definitely.
>> So, here we go. Game two or match two I
should say for top 64 is that we're
going to end up having Master Yi versus
Victor as we already have this idea. And
Frank, you went didn't have the pleasure
of being here with me, but I had the
pleasure of watching a similar matchup
to this yesterday and the Victor at the
end of the day was victorious and took
down the match. What do you think about
when you think of mind vers or mind plus
order plus versus calm plus body?
>> Yeah, I think that is a really
interesting match up Barrett because I
feel like when you look at all these
Master Yi decks, and there are a pretty
good number of them, they're really
tooling their decks to kind of fight on
the board, fight stats in the board. You
see a lot of disciplines, you see a lot
of ong guards, just the Master Yi legend
that gives the extra plus two. And it's
a lot of my number is going to be bigger
than yours because what you don't see a
lot of in the metag game is the order
removal. And those are removal spells
like maybe call the weak, vengeance,
blast of power, whatever this Victor is
bringing to the table and they say,
"Hey, I don't care how big your might
is. I'm just going to kill your unit
straight up." So, it doesn't surprise me
that a Victor player who clearly knows
what they're doing is making a deep run
and sort of picking apart these Ye
decks. Now, that's not to say Y has no
gameplay cuz Defy often a powerful
option that can fight back against a lot
of that hard removal.
>> Yeah. Still deals with the hidden blades
that can get played normally or hidden,
of course. And then you even have access
to defy the cold of weeks like you said.
I think even like we we saw aggressive
like grand strategim plays that allow
your units to in the normal sense just
win through combat of course and allows
your little recruits to get a little bit
closer to going through. So uh so going
we're going to have a quick piece of
content for you all before we set up
this next game, but we are still going
to be anticipating to do that match for
you all. So we're going to take it away
here real quick.
Hey, Riftbounders. I'm Barrett Bryant
and today I have the privilege to be
joined with George G, one of the most
decorated players I currently know.
George, tell me a little bit about
yourself.
>> Uh, hi Barrett. I went to China to play
this game cuz I was so excited when it
was about to release and I wanted to
play the first tournament. So, I decided
I I learned to sign up for the Chinese
tournaments and I flew all the way to
China to compete where I played in three
regionals scoring a top eight, a top 64,
and a first place in my third one.
>> Wow. Getting a win automatically in one
of the first regional qualifiers for
this game is quite the achievement. So
again, you if I'm going to take advice
from anybody, I want to take it from
you, George. So George, what are you
playing this weekend then? I decided to
stick with Kai'Sa. Kai'Sa is the event
that I won my first regional on, and I
feel like none of the decks have a big
edge over the others this weekend, and
so I decided to go with my comfort pick,
and I'm going to play Kai'Sa this
weekend.
>> That makes a lot of sense to me. She's
one of the best resource tempo based
kind of decks that we can see in this
room. And so do you have any like
specific, you know, tactics or tips that
you could give to anybody if this is
their first event, if they're playing
Kai'Sa or not? What do you think is a
good advice for a new player in a card
game like here in Ripbound?
>> A new for a new player coming to this
tournament like something of this scale,
I would say to come have a good time,
have fun with your friends, get good
food afterwards, and just make sure to
prioritize having a good time. Have fun.
>> I think that's the best advice I could
ever take as well. But George, we're
going to go ahead and do a quick deck
tech if you don't mind over your Kaisal
list. So, we're gonna go over and take a
look at that.
Welcome back. We're now joined here with
George G's Kai'Sa list that you're gonna
hopefully be running with tomorrow, give
or take a few changes that you might
make the night before, but I mean, this
is exactly what we're talking about here
in Houston. Kai'Sa is the deck to beat.
It's the deck that you believe is going
to be the strongest here. And I want you
to kind of give me a rundown on why you
ne not necessarily chose specific cards,
but why did you pick Kaisa? And how did
these cards answer what you're looking
for? when I was learning Riftbound, uh,
Kais' style of cheap creatures and cheap
removal, uh, that suits my style from
other games. And so it was natural
before anyone was playing it, I was
testing a deck before even all the cards
were revealed. So I had some kind of
emotional attachment to the deck before
taking it to China and before it saw it
success. Um, yeah, I just like the type
of deck that plays low, non-committal
characters to the board and is able to
kind of trade them off and make value.
Yeah, I think watchful sentry is like a
prime example of that, right? And then
Raven Bloom student, you being able to
exchange, you know, a full swing and
might tempo from playing the spells that
you're already going to be using because
of your legend ability. It makes a lot
of sense and I can't agree, can't
disagree with that.
>> Yeah, many of the characters in the deck
replace themselves such as watchful
sentry, electing yortal, and the leader
if it's able to conquer also replaces
itself. Uh the deck has some spells
cycle as well and stupify. Uh, retreat
again recycles your powerful creatures
or your your creatures withdraw a card
creating economy. But, um, the deck also
has some sneaky late game tricks.
>> Speaking of those late game tricks, cuz
I think this is a different kind of
conversation will maybe go down
afterwards, but the late game trips when
you look at like Athenian rain plus time
warp, obviously thousand tail watcher is
the big one that a lot of people are
looking at.
>> When it comes to the mulligan in the
beginning of the game, how do you take
advantage of such a great curve that
we'll call it that Kai'Sa has? What are
you looking for in that very important
moment at the beginning of the game?
>> I'm always looking to match my starting
hand to whether I'm playing first or
second, first and foremost. And then
primarily I'm looking for stuff that
synergizes with the battlefields that
I'm playing on the on that particular
game. So in this deck here, we have
Targon speak. This means you probably
want a spell to take advantage of the
free mana or if your opponent has the
grove where he draws a card if he holds
it, you may need cards to break in there
on your second turn.
>> That makes a lot of sense. Of course,
one of those best cards, Falling Star
here. I see a pretty even 66 split on
the runes here. I know a lot of people
don't really vary from that, but the
power costing I think is important to
pay attention to because Kaisen can only
compensate for the spells. I see three
Darius, three watcher. It makes sense.
Can you talk to me? You talk about the
lowc costing units. Can you talk to me a
little bit about Legion Rear Guard here?
I think this unit is fantastic, but not
everyone's playing it.
>> So, there's a debate between the Legion
Rear Guard and the Pow Porro. The Powyp
Porro is kind of more of a grindy
economy, make your opponent uh pay their
mana type of card with his deflect cost.
And the Legion reard is great in the
late game for making uh double
accelerate turns to score directly from
six to eight with no board state, which
is um that's a that's a cool trick as
well in the late game. I did I did want
to point something out about Kaisa's
mana curve. Um most of our you can see
the costs are pretty even. And it's
important in Riftbound when you look at
your costs in your deck to think about
which ones are the late game costs and
which ones are the early game costs
because if you're paying blue when
you're at 10, say for example, if you
play this expensive four blue card and
you're already at 10 mana, which it
costs, the all the cards remaining in
your rune deck are going to be blue
essentially. Yeah.
>> And so the late game ones are less
important than the early game ones when
building your rune structure.
>> Yeah. It makes the decision on why I've
seen a lot of Kaisalis drop down in the
smoke screens because of exactly what
you're saying. If I use them too early
for smokeokesc screen when I really need
them necessarily to play a time warp
that I drew, you don't buy you might not
have them and they're not going to come
until later.
>> Sure. Kais are loaded in the blue in the
late game with a watcher and the time
warp.
>> Absolutely. Uh separate side question as
we kind of look at a few of these
sideboard pieces. Um most Kaiso lists
that I've been paying attention through
and you can even vouch in China when you
were playing everyone started playing
three copies of Void Seeker main board
and now as I'm seeing here not playing
any main and instead just opting in the
sideboard. Is there something
specifically about Void Seeker that it's
just harder to execute in the earlier
turns or is it just that falling stars
is much better to see?
>> I think this developed um this is a more
of a high level high level analysis
situation, but this is be became Kaisa's
first battleground. Uh the dreaming tree
uh this card draws a lot of cards
throughout the game. And so the draw
card text is not as powerful on Void
Seeker. And there's another situation
that occurs when your opponent has a lot
of creatures. the strategy of just going
very wide with many small guys um is a
lot more viable for them because they
have so much access to extra cards. So
they'll be playing unit unit and
sometimes if you hold up three mana for
void seeker they won't they won't uh
initiate a showdown.
>> Yeah.
>> And so their unit lead will become very
wide on you and you'll be stuck with
your three mana and you're left holding
it and you're wondering do I hold up
three again or not? because then they
may only offer you the ones that replace
themselves to shoot as well that are
cheaper than void seeker. And so now
you've wasted three mana one time and
then perhaps three mana again the next
turn just shooting a watchful sentry and
you begin to realize maybe this card is
not so good in game one. But in the
games where you have less cards, I like
void secret. I think that's why it's so
common in the side deck right now.
>> I love that. I think that's a perfect
answer and I've learned a lot just in
that exchange because as I see you're
right. Dreaming Tree Plus uh retreat I
think is one of the greatest plays you
can think when it comes to hand
advantage and generating those cards.
When it comes to the tournament itself,
George, big picture.
>> Okay.
>> What what do you think the scariest
thing that you're going to see tomorrow
even though you're playing
>> the best deck in the room, right? You
know what are you afraid to go against?
What's going to be your hardest matchup?
>> I don't want to hit Aurora or Annie.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I personally, maybe it might seem
good to say, but I love the matchups
where you can you have a lot of skill
expression and you have a lot of
influence on the outcome and so I'm
afraid of Annie and Aurora.
>> My favorite games to watch actually are
Kai'Sa versus non Aurora Y decks. I
think those decisions are great and the
back and forth of Defies and Unyielding
Spirits versus what you're doing here. I
love it. Absolutely. But I see the
respect, right? You know, dazzling
Aurora decks. You can kill basically any
large unit here with the unchecked power
in the sideboard. Thermmo beam of course
can kill off every gear on the board. It
makes a lot of sense. So you talked
about how you picked Dreaming Tree as
your first battlefield for game one,
that advantage that we just talked
about, but I do kind of want you to talk
about these other ones, right? So we
have Vioma's Layer here and Targon's
Peak. So why specifically are you using
these ones today?
>> So typically in Riftbound, my strategy
so far has been to pick a battleground
for the random game where I don't know
if I'm going first or second, then to
pick a battleground for going first.
That's my Targon speak cuz it provides
an advantage to the first player to get
into the battlefield or conquer it,
right? So, uh that allows me to use my
spells on my opponent's turn. Of course,
I'll have side side deck in my void
seekers and I'll have extra energy
available to cast them with uh Targon's
Peak. Uh the Viles Lair specifically,
I'm swapping this one to my game one
battleground against Annie. This is to
stop the purple movement spells from
saving Annie's creatures such as flash,
fight or flight, uh and maybe some
others. I can't think about it right
now. No, you're right. I I also wonder
too, right? Um it doesn't stop ganking,
of course. So, you know, Misfortune
doesn't really do much there, but I also
wonder then if you maybe run into a
Yasawo that someone's going for the
metallic cards, even though you probably
have a pretty good match up already, do
you even consider biomair for that game
one?
>> Um I think if it's a match up I haven't
seen before, I'll stick to my game plan.
>> Yeah.
>> But against Annie, I'm going to go with
this one. Game one.
>> Love it. That sounds great to me. Uh
George, final thoughts on why you feel
so confident playing Kaiso specifically
as a deck in the room? uh kite. Why I'm
confident in Kaisa? It's because I have
a lot of practice on it. I I don't have
a big preference for any deck this
weekend. I think whatever you guys chose
is a good choice. Uh but for me, one
more ride with Kai'Sa.
>> Absolutely. And I hope it's a great
ride. George, good luck tomorrow. Thank
you so much for doing this deck tech
with me. We're going to go ahead and
shoot it back to the desk.
>> Welcome back, Rift Founders. I'm once
again Barrett Bryant joined with Frank
Scaren and I sadly have to apologize to
our viewers. We were going to do the
second coverage match that we had for
top 64, but our tournament is pile
driving through. We are going to go
ahead and be going into our top 32
matchup as the tournament has
progressed. And we had the pleasure here
of just watching that. I I got to talk
with George, not just even so much
oncreen there, but outscreen and, you
know, talk about his traveling to China
and participating in the regional
qualifier and winning that one now
coming back here to America, you know,
coming and playing in this one. And it's
so insightful when you talk to literally
one of the only few decorated players
now in our game. He had so many
insights. I learned so much and we're
even going to be able to watch his
gameplay now in this top 32 round. Yeah,
I'm super excited to see George in
action here. You know, for those at home
who don't know him yet, he is one of the
kind of leading players in Riftbound
right now. Super awesome to see him go
all the way to China to play in those
events and take one down. And the really
important thing to note about George is
he is a Kaisa die hard. He has just been
ride or die Kai'Sa all the way. Has
tuned his list, tweaked it, and has just
keep finding edges in the mirror and
it's really showed off. And I believe he
actually snuck into today in 64th place
just squeaking his way right in. Yeah,
as you can see there at the bottom, he
was eight and two. One of the one of the
lucky eight and twos that did end up or
nine or sorry, seven and twos that ended
up making it into the tournament here.
And once you're in single elimination,
that record no longer really matters
because I guess 8 and2 with the win last
round. So, he wins the die roll going
first here. George G barely sneaking
into this top cut and now making a
deeper run in as we go into top 32.
>> Yeah, and we're really going to put
George to the test here. It's a Kaiser
mirror match. He's going to get to show
off the expertise he has, but you know,
two players at the table and Kais takes
some really unique approaches to the
mirror match and each player tends to
have their tech.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And of course, his
opponent Talion here playing voidgate as
our choice of battlefield versus of
course George. We talked about game one,
the Dreaming Tree. Now, of course, I I
am interested to see what changes George
might have made when I did do that kind
of deck tech with him. And we're excited
to see that inside of the match itself,
but I assume Talion, every Kaisalist
looks a little bit different, Frank.
There's a few extra cards you can play,
certain choices in the sideboard, of
course. You know, I talked about with
Georgeing Void Seeker in the beginning
of the the legacy of the Kai'Sa decks.
Now, maybe not so much. So, both of
these decks could still be very
different.
>> Yeah, some builds lean more tempo, more
aggression. Some builds kind of look to
ramp up to those Atheian reigns and time
warps and it's really can just the
amount of things you can do to look to
get edges in these mirror matches are
pretty vast. But right now we're just
going to see both players start by
trying to get a bunch of units onto the
board. Tempo is the name of the game as
we play the cleave into the battlefield
with our watchful sentry just to draw a
card off the dreaming tree. One of the
benefits of playing that battlefield and
then because we played a card our Nox is
hopeful only costs two. Keeping one up
as we pass back. Yeah, Italian thinking.
He's got the pouty porro here. He can
use it to contest this watchful sentry.
The name of the game is tempo. Scoring
points is huge. Trying to get ahead or
at least stay caught up. And the pouty
porro moving in. George looks like he's
going to say okay. But wait, going to
stupify here, which means we do have to
play or no to buy our own unit of course
is probably the better here because it
doesn't actually reduce the might, but
you're going to get the draw from
targeting your own watchful sentry here.
Not actually picking the powdy porro. Oh
no, we did. I believe what George did
here and this is this is the advanced
kaisite techch. This is the thing that
George used, he actually used the
daughter of the void legend to pay for
deflect because the way deflect works is
it imposes an additional cost on the
spell and since it's a spell cost,
daughter of the void is like yeah I'll
pay that deflect.
>> That is some next level play of course
is we didn't end up using any power on
our own turn. Absolutely. Now that means
we just got the draw from the stupify,
not from the dreaming tree and then
trading. But we still get the draw for
watch trading with the Patty Porro.
>> Definitely. And George is being like,
"Hey, you know, we're both losing our
units here. Battalion, you're not
getting a point." And that's what he
cares about.
>> Yeah. Also keeping up still on the
points here himself going for the second
one with this Knox hopeful, but there's
a Darius now on the other side of the
board that although it wasn't going to
come in ready, it is a powerful unit to
have that's going to contest this Knox
hopeful.
>> Yeah. And again, just want to reinforce
the players are playing with open deck
list at this point. So, both of these
players know what the other Kai'Sa
player has brought to the table to try
to fight this mirror match. And it's
going to be really awesome to see both
of these just like experts of Kai'Sa
figure out how to navigate this.
>> I kind of want to dive into that a
little bit as our players are going to
go through some pretty um powerful
choices that they're going to have to
think about. Uh Frank, when you think
about mirror matches in general, not
just in Ripbound, but in card games,
obviously the more and more legends we
have accessible in the future releases,
mirror matches will be less likely. But
in this current example, how how
wellversed do you think you have to be
if you're both going to be taking
probably the most represented deck in
the room or legend? How much practice do
you think you need against the mirror
match?
>> Oh, I I'm sure both of these players
have put a ton of effort and time into
learning the mirror and the things that
are important. You know, maybe if you're
like a Victor player or a Leon player,
you could be like, I don't need to worry
about the mirror as much. I'm probably
not going to run into that. But these
Kaisa players are definitely prepared.
And here we see Talion going in with a
Darius, which George is going to try to
meet with a Hexte Ray.
>> Yeah, Hexte Ray is going to deal that
three to the Darius, which is going to
help those Noxis Hopeful once again
trade with another unit of Talion and
deny that Conquer. But a spell of our
own potentially coming in here. It's the
void seeker going to deal four and then
draw a card which then means I add
another reaction timing. We're going to
play a retreat on the Nox's hopeful
which will be targeting our own unit to
draw off of the Dreaming Tree and save
that unit back into our hand. Great
exchange there. Yeah, that's what I love
about these Kaisamir. They're just real
spell slers. You see a lot of actions in
these showdowns. Dreaming Tree also
coming in there to kick in an extra card
for the retreat and George saying like,
"Okay, I'll I'll give you the board for
now, but I'm gonna build up a really
really large army of resources in my
hand." I think that's the best part,
too, right? It feels like George still
is on the upoot. Although losing that
exchange, at least when it comes to the
battlefield as itself and giving the
point over, it resulted in Talion only
going to be able to have one ready to
run, whereas George worked with a lot
with a little, I should say, with only
having the two.
>> Yeah. and Talion really using Darius to
great effect there. You know, a lot of
times when you think of Darius, you
think, hey, I'm going to play him from
hand. I'm going to cleave him to get in
there and fight. But kind of the other
thing that Darius can do is go into a
battlefield, use his ability to ready,
and then back out to be good to go next
turn.
>> Kaiser Survivor coming in back. We're
going to fight over this dreaming tree
all day for both of these decks, I
think. And makes sense. But getting that
conquer up, going up to three for
George, and getting the on draw effect
or on conquer draw. And we have a ton of
runes to play through because we've used
our legend ability in conjunction of
saving ourselves the most we can without
paying these power costs. So, we have a
lot to play with here.
>> Yeah, both players probably going to
avoid the void gate as much as they can.
No one wants to be in there. Maybe a
watchful sentry, but a really valuable
unit like Kaisa survivor. So, like, hey,
I'll go over to the dreaming tree. You
can stupify me, get some extra cards.
That's cool.
>> Yeah, it looks like a falling stars that
we ended up drawing is going to be
played here. And wherever these
reflexive triggers go, it will be
interesting to ch double on the the
Darius makes sense when you get the big
one off of the board. Whereas the Raven
Bloom can be kind of dealt with later.
>> Yeah, and the pace of play from both
Talion and George here. Super
impressive. These are clearly two
players who are just super comfortable
in their seats, know exactly what
they're doing and are ready to make some
good decisions.
>> Oxbow coming back onto the field with a
powdery boro to come with it. Keeping
two up once again for George as we pass
back to Talion.
George has managed to, you know, secure
a pretty nice early point lead here,
which is super important in the matchup.
But now it's Talion's turn to swing
back. It really is just these two decks
kind of just throwing haymakers at each
other back and forth, scoring the
battlefields as much as possible. And
just when you think someone's
established a lead just like that, it
could swing in the other direction.
>> Yeah. And and we're reaching these like
key rune break points for these decks
for these powerful cards. We know
Thousand Tail Watcher exists in these
lists. You know, we can talk about
things like Athenian rain, the signature
spell for Kai'Sa, and then some of these
lists do play things like time warp. So,
the closer and closer we get to that
area, it the game can all of a sudden be
flipped on its head where it's like, oh,
I'm going to take another turn right
here, or I'm going to completely try and
remove your entire units. What do you
think is going to be the key to success
for Talion to maybe come back in this
game? Because I don't think Watcher here
is that great of a play with the two
extra units in the back foot. Yeah. So,
I think Talion, he's just got to do what
he can to make sure he's keeping pace
with those points if he lets George get
too far ahead. The Kai'Sa deck is way
better at offense than defense. And
there eventually will come a point where
he just can't keep George off the
Conquers. And we are going to see the
Thousand Tail come down here to give
Kai'Sa a shrink and to try to use uh the
students to take her down. Yeah, but
with the hex tech ray here means that
again George is going to be able to
trade with this Raven Bloom student or
now it's actually going to deal the
three over the top unless there is some
more spell tricks to help buff up this
Raven Bloom. It's going to die before it
even touches his Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah, Italian taking a look at George's
trash. I think he's saying, "Man, that's
a lot of hex tech rays. Couldn't have
played around it." And the Raven Bloom
is going to go to the trash itself.
>> Having a hex hex tech ray of our own
though to test that to just stop and get
it out of the way. And it makes sense,
right? The timing on that card is a
little bit harder to pull off when it
goes through. One has to completely
resolve before we get to the next
action, right?
>> Yeah. Getting getting Kaiso off the
board. I'm sure Talion's super happy
about that. But the really important
thing to note is that he is struggling
to score points right now. And this is
exactly what we were talking about and
gives George a really good opportunity
to get ahead on points.
passing back to George all those runes
to his availability and now instead a
thousand tailed watcher of his own which
I can imagine again just to hopefully
contest that seven might body that's on
the other side of the table. Yeah, you
don't see this as much the thousand tail
without accelerate but George just being
like hey I just want stats on the board
but what you do see very often is
combining it with a falling star to take
down something you normally couldn't and
George quick to do that and clean up the
last unit the Talion had available at
the time. Excellent play here getting
around that seven might body with the
double use of the uh thousand tail
watcher as well as the falling star and
for a double conquer going to five with
nothing left on the board for Talion and
only the three cards in hand plus the
one we're going to draw.
>> Yeah, George really just showing off why
he's established that reputation as a
master of Kai'Sa and just putting on a
real great show for us.
>> It I love high level gameplay, Frank. I
I think the fact the further and further
we go into it, I'm actually going to be
a little disappointed because I won't be
here at the later points of this desk.
And once we get to, you know, that top
eight, that top four, that finals match,
it's not only the highest stakes that
you can think of, but it is going to be
the best players in the room this
weekend.
>> Yeah, this is this is really a dream for
players like this where Kai'Sa is just
such a such a gamer's deck. There's so
many decisions, so many interaction
points, and you know, sometimes people
will shy away from a mirror, but a
mirror like this where you just get to
get to really make all these choices and
impact the outcome so strongly. I know a
lot of players have been loving it, and
you know, it's going to be just
interesting to see how Talion and George
can do.
>> Kai'Sa survivor coming in for Talion
from the champion unit zone. We did
accelerate it and then easily fought off
against that pouty porro. finally
getting a point onto the board again for
Talion and now a Falling Stars coming in
as well to remove that Nox is hopeful
because it has that awkward four might.
You know, that's one of those break
points, the four and seven might really
being difficult for yourself as a Kaised
to deal with.
>> Yeah, I'm sure not Talion's favorite way
to use a Falling Star, but heads up play
to just be like, hey, I need to stem
this point flow that's coming from
George. If I don't fight back here, I'm
just going to fall too far behind.
George being very good. Also, if you
watch him play on point mapping, of
course, as you can very much see the
kind of lead that he's built himself
here, I don't think he's worried at all
about how to get to seven. It's that
what resources do we use right now to
get to seven to then solidify and lock
in that eighth one. Yeah, he is he is
reaching that critical point where he
can threaten to double conquer at any
time. Looking at his hand and trying to
figure out the best way to do it.
seen cards like cleave in his hand that
as we saw earlier on even in this game
of just using them for value when you go
to the dreaming tree just for the extra
draw and finding more important key
cards but it looks like the first Darius
Trifarian going to be coming in here for
George and all he has to do is play
another card I don't know like a cleave
on our watchful sentry onto the other
battlefield draws us a new one goes to
six and then that Darius would ready up
or just target itself right now the
great play to make Darius basically a 10
might attacker just from this two Hard
play for six energy.
>> Yeah, interesting decision point here
from George. He has to decide, do I just
want to go in with one, go up to six,
set up the double conquer next turn, or
do I want to go in with both, go to
seven, and threaten a hold, which will
just win me the game on the spot. And
the way he's playing it out, it looks
like he might be trying to establish
that hold.
>> Yeah, we're going to get a retreat
though through from Talion. Going to
save the Kai'Sa. Little unfortunate
because we're not on that dreaming tree.
So, it's really just going to save the
unit and not get a bonus draw. But a
watchful sentry followup here. Takes the
point, goes to six, and like you said,
posturing for that double conquer later.
>> Yep. George decides, hey, you know, one
battlefield is enough for me right now.
I don't need to try to hold. He probably
feels that exposes him to too many
things that could kind of take him out
of the driver's seat and he's just going
to be like, I'm going to go for the
double conquer because that's what
Kai'Sa does best.
>> 10 runes for Talion.
>> Yeah. Normally, you know, some decks
play time warp and you're like, "Ooh,
this is my time warp turn, but not
looking great on this board if Talion
has access to it."
>> Yeah, you really need units. Uh it's
about, you know, like getting the two
turns of holds or something like that
when you have that incremental
advantage. Of course, then it just feels
like you were going to win anyway
because of how much of an advantage you
have. But even the units in your
battlefield means you can play them or
have them ready to go, play things like
the time war to guarantee yourself
another turn, use those resources, and
then have another turn to back them up.
But not going to be the play here as the
Kai'Sa that we just saved, the survivor
going to be coming back and accelerated
once again hopefully to draw us another
card at one of these battlefields that
we conquer with it. So now Talion has to
go in the tank, see if he could come up
with anything to hold off this double
double conquer next turn. There's
already a thousand tail watcher and a
watchful sentry down. And the cool thing
about Darius is he can kind of do a
pseudo ganking impression, hold the one
battlefield, move back to the base,
ready up, and just launch an allout
assault with all of George's units on
the Dreaming Tree. Love it. Love it.
Love it. Um, even had the uh privilege
of casting a Darius match yesterday. And
you know, the fact is that a legend like
Darius has to gets to keep that
trifarian in their pocket. But when you
don't get to do that, a lot of these
lists, you see them playing three full
copies of the Darius. That's how
impactful it can do for doing plays.
Just like you said,
>> definitely Barrett. So, Talion will pick
up another card from the conquer trigger
to try to help him hold off George's
offense. He's thinking, he's doing some
math. Definitely a spot where even if
you feel like you're behind, you're not
going to give up without a fight.
>> Do you think there's a five rune play
here we can do to even come close to
saving yourself? Because even when you
pass, right, you know, George has all of
his runes that he's going to have access
to to help the offensive, not just
what's already on the board.
>> So, Darius is at the void gate. It makes
him a little easier to take down.
Something like a void seeker would be
able to do the job. And we might be
seeing that right here.
>> Yeah, there it is. Targeting that Darius
going to draw another card as well for
Talion. Helps out those resources with
only one energy. Looks like we're going
to have to let it go. Yeah, the void
gate coming in clutch here at least for
that specific situation. So that helps
out.
>> Giving Talion another card and another
option, but his runes are running low.
>> Two left. Still a watcher. Still a
another watchful. There's two watchers
on the other side. Watch for what?
thousand watching and a watchful sentry
as we just passed. Keeping the two up.
Do going to have to do our best to stave
off the double conquer here.
>> Yeah, and this is a spot where as
Talion, even if you don't have it, even
if you don't have a way to stop it, you
got to make the opponent do it. You got
to put George to the test because maybe
he'll shy off and maybe he won't go for
the double conquer and that would buy
Talion another turn.
>> Kathy and Rain seems to be the show here
as we are going to pay fully for this
which is going to completely remove this
Kai'Sa plus more. Yeah, George just
saying, "Hey, you know, I'm not taking
any chances. This is for the win. I'm
just going to blast Kai'Sa survivor with
her own ability into oblivion.
>> Send them all the way." Moves in with
the Thousand Tailed. And it looks like
that's going to be game one going to
George representing the Kai'Sa here.
>> George doing what he does best with that
Kai'Sa deck. Talion putting up a pretty
good fight. And I believe George was
going first that game, which I from what
I understand is a strong advantage in
the Kai'Sa matchup. So now Talion is
going to get his chance to crack back.
>> Yeah. Uh battlefield choices here. Bomos
layer which we saw George talk about and
showcase yesterday. So great to see it
here in when he's going second. Not
necessarily a ton of movement tricks
going on here for the Kaisil deck. But
that thing we talked about with Darius
isn't really possible when you're not
allowed to come back to base from the
Biles M. But whereas Reaver's row over
on Talion side,
>> yeah, we really just have both sides of
the spectrum here. We have biomawer
which is says when you come here you can
never leave and reavers row says when
you can come here you can leave whenever
the hell you want
early turns pretty simple usually for
these decks uh love even you know
lecturing your order one of my favorite
cards actually just because of I love
the tank trade I think it's really good
at making the math difficult for your
opponent and of course it just draws you
a card on entry of course
>> definitely and you know Talion getting
Kaisa survivor on the table always a
strong turn two play
So game one, we saw a pretty big
discrepancy on George taking full
control of the game and being able to
always have a point lead and always feel
like Talion is always playing catch-up.
How does Talion then now put on his own
helmet and be the person in the driver's
seat? Yeah. So, I think Talion just, you
know, going first. He's going to look to
do everything he can to get stats on the
board. Maybe pick up big tempo plays
with Nox's hopeful and just kind of do
exactly what George did and score as
many points as he can as fast as he can
while then using the cheap spells to
fight back and pick off George's units.
Um, and right now we're going to start
at an even 1-1 and but see what George
has to follow up with.
>> Yeah, Falling Stars coming in again for
the early removal of the Kai'Sa survivor
that we spent our entire turn as Talion
playing that time. And that's even, I
think, why Talion chose to go into the
Reaver's Row because we were like, well,
if I'm completely tapped out, I don't
have a trick to make this watchful
sentry work against a trade. Why not
just save it for later? But now being
answered by a Falling Star. I mean,
that's what you spent your whole turn
on.
>> Yeah, definitely. And that will cost
George a rune, but I think he's willing,
you know, going second, you do get that
extra rune, and he's willing to
sacrifice that to get Kai'Sa survivor
off the board before she can start
drawing some extra cards. Uh now an
interesting dynamic we might see here is
if this watchful sentry so it's going to
go to Viol's layer but if it came to
fight at Reaver's Row there will be that
moment of you can retreat you're
currently winning but if you stay then
you can no longer retreat and I get to
play my tricks and I love that point of
tension and I hope we get to see it this
game.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And we saw George be
kind of like the master of those tricks.
Even though, you know, we and we saw
them both slinging spells, of course,
but I felt like every time George was
either defending a battlefield or
attacking into a battlefield, he was
being up on the trade, except for maybe
one scenario. And we're already kind of
seeing that as well of just like it
feels like Talion is like almost
avoiding him a little bit based off of
the cards that are just in his hand. It
kind of shows a lot on the posturing.
>> Definitely. And this would be a great
spot for something like a Noxis Hopeful
from Talion, but it looks like he's just
going to get a lecturing yortle of his
own down and then send it George's way.
>> These boards look very similar.
>> They do look very similar. Couple units,
they all draw cards one way or another.
George looking at a nice hand of spells
and he's going to have to decide what he
wants to do here.
>> What do you think?
I guess this isn't necessarily like a
big competitive picture, but when I'm
looking at to build a deck in a game
like Riftbound, unit based, but having a
legend like Kai'Sa that really benefits
from having these spells, especially
with power costs,
ratios, I think, is something I I really
value a lot. I'm a big I'm a math major,
by the way. So, when I think about it,
it's like when you see a hand that's
filled with so many spells, is that bad?
Is that not necessarily something you're
looking for? Let's let's say there even
spells that don't necessarily replace
themselves like the stupifiers that
exist in the world, right? Or the void
seekers when you don't have as many
units per se as like a set deck or a
Darius deck that is, you know, very
unittheavy.
When it when is it sometimes that it can
be a detriment that you have a bunch of
spells instead of creating a board
presence.
>> Yeah. So, I think the sweet spot that
the Kaisedex try to hit is just having a
healthy amount of spells that do have
that single power cost. That way you can
maximize and try to use your legend, you
know, every turn, every other turn, and
make sure you're getting good value out
of it while still building up your rune
total to hit the bigger spells like time
worth and a rain
draws oursel a new unit as we just
traded our watchful sentries away with
each other. Um, no point to be gained
obviously for George now just playing a
watchful sentry and now passing holding
up those four runes which I can only
imagine are for all of these spells that
we have. Yeah, it does look like both
players might have one of those kind of
more spellheavy draws as the units
aren't hitting the table nearly as quick
as last game, but Talion has used his
Kai'Sa survivor while George choosing to
keep his a little safer in the champion
zone to deploy down the line. Very great
point. I mean, George, I think played
his on a very opportune time. Didn't
even pay the accelerate Pagas that we
saw in game one. Neither did Talion, but
spent up the whole turn, whereas George
can basically wait now and delay it when
you can play Kaisa plus more things to
be progressive on the board. Yeah, there
is always that risk. And here we see a
pretty interesting exchange because, you
know, Talion's going to get to draw a
card. The lecturing Yortle is going to
go back to the hand. That's going to be
a rune for George. So, kind of just a
lot of cards moving around. But, I think
George is going to be pretty happy to
build up that rune total. And he can
even replay the lecturing Yortle down
the line.
>> And then with his own void seeker, void
seeker to rebuttal against the lecturing
yortle to potentially stop and deny the
point. Wouldn't it be a play if there
was a retreat of our own that we could
play here just to keep it alive? Hey, I
mean that's why they call it a mirror
match, but Talion instead going to let
his lecturing Yortle die. And I do think
he had the retreat in hand, but he's
going to higher value getting this
Darius down and ready to score some
points.
>> Makes sense. Darius feels a little bit
safer now that George has completely
tapped out now playing enough tricks of
his own. Darius coming in with seven
might and going to get that point that
Talion was really trying to get off the
bat.
>> Yeah, and Darius in Reaver's Row is a
menace because you're not going to be
able to even if George had a Darius of
his own, Talion's Darius could run away
and try to conquer again the following
turn. and still in that weird break
point, right? It's got five might. So,
following stars were going to require
both of the investment with the only
unit on the board. I guess you feel
pretty good if that's an answer to it,
but just out of range of things like
avoid seeker.
George looking at his hand. He's got a
lot of options, doing some math. Both
players taking a pretty good opportunity
to kind of slow down this game. A lot
more spells flying, a lot of decisions
to be made and making sure they want to
make the right ones. And here it comes,
the Reaver's Row check. Do you want to
retreat? Do you fear my watchful sentry?
Or Darius, do you want to try to hold
the line?
>> How many watchful senties are you ever
afraid of, Frank?
>> I mean, Talion does have no runes
available.
>> So, if he stays, he is just saying,
"Hey, George, I think you're bluffing. I
think you don't have it." And that's a
pretty bold claim to make. So, Talion is
going to respect George's play and back
out the Darius.
>> If if I'm in Talion's position, it's
really hard not to have that respect
because you're already down a game. But
you feel like you have to keep your
resources available. But that's exactly
what George wanted, right? I mean,
that's exactly what he's looking to do
to progress in the points to catch up at
one of the biggest downsides of going
second is just not being ahead on points
necessarily. And all of a sudden, we
have caught up just because you can
posture and make your opponent scared.
Definitely. And you know, Darius is
Talion's only unit right now. He has
lost his Kai'Sa survivor. So, it could
be catastrophic for him if he, you know,
tried to stick to his guns and it wasn't
a bluff. going to go ahead and
accelerate this Kaisa and immediately
move it into that biom layer. Going to
get the conquer draw of course and
another point for George and all of a
sudden now he's in the lead towards
victory.
>> George is in the lead. He's doing a
great job of playing on the even
numbers. But Talion is going to kind of
have that first opportunity to attempt
to go to five. And if he could do that
and kind of just keep that small point
edge, I think he's still very well in
this game.
>> Yeah, we're hitting again those critical
break points for the Kaisa decks. Things
like a thousand tail watcher are
available now and on the board and there
would be easy trades and get very large
might bodies onto these battlefields
that George will now have to spend more
resources to get through.
>> And very very important to note for
Talion, I did see a sneak peek of a time
warp in George's hand. And Talion, it is
open deck list, so he does know that's
on the table. And that's a card that can
just throw all the math out the window.
You think you're safe, you think your
opponent's on four, but uh-oh, look at
that. George could double hold the six,
play the time warp, and win the game on
the spot. So Talion's going to that's
just going to be an extra layer of
pressure that Talion's going to have to
think about.
>> Yeah, it cannot be a setup turn. It must
be a proactive going and contesting
these battlefields. But with the
Reaver's Row going to help keep more of
those units alive. And again, I think
just when you go to play a time warp in
general, it's just about already having
units on board.
>> Definitely. And time warp really one of
the funniest cards to me when listening
to Kai'Sa players cuz some will swear
it's broken and some will swear it's
unplayable. And I think I know which
side of the fence George is on.
>> Yeah, absolutely. The thousand tail
watcher though coming down here. Looks
like we are not going to pay its
accelerate cost, but it makes sense. And
then we also going to go ahead and play
a spell. Looks like be a falling stars
as we're going to pay the two and still
have to recycle one. So falling star
here with the minus three means we're
going to get a huge value here on
removing two units of our choice no
matter what and only having to put one
of those triggers on the Kaiso.
>> Yep. Talion choosing to go for that
watchful sentry over the Porro. doesn't
want to pay any deflect and George with
another retreat to pick Kais' back up.
>> Retreat. So high impact here. And with
the watchful sentry still dying, we're
going to draw a card as well. And now we
still have access. With the second card
being played though, uh that means this
Darius is ready. And they're going to
decide to keep it there or move it back.
What do you think is the best play?
>> Uh given that Darius is at Reaver's Row,
I think normally you would back out. But
since the row kind of lets you do that
for free sort of in combat later on, it
seems like Talion's going to stick to
his guns and say, "Hey, I'm at least
going to make you to contest this before
I move out."
>> Counting runes, making sure we're up and
a bunch spent completely tapped here out
for here for Talion. I mean, it's crazy
when we think about cards like time warp
in this situation. When your opponent
has that zero runes, it's not just for
one turn. It's actually for two of them
if you play a time warp.
>> Definitely. And with that count there, I
think George was kind of doing a time
warp check of his own, being like, "Hey,
can you play a time warp the following
turn?" And when he counted, he saw
seven. So, no. So, that's not something
he has to worry about just yet. And he
can see if he can take the time to set
up his own.
>> Yeah, it wouldn't be that double hole
that we talked about or you talked about
earlier on, but instead playing the
Pyro. And here we are. This is the first
time warp that I'm going to be able to
announce. Time warp coming in for 10 and
four recycles. Of course, Kaiso can pay
for one of those. And it means we're
gonna still have one rune to play with.
But no matter what, George is gonna get
another turn after this one.
>> Yeah, fool me once and I'll just rewind.
Time warp going to the banish and we're
going to see if George can use this
extra turn that he's going to get to
close out this game in a window that
Talion might not have expected.
>> Yeah, now going to six here on the hold,
which means George has a whole another
turn where he just gets to play setup.
Maybe even contest things like this
Darius and this thousand tail watcher as
long as we have some removal. But all of
those runes that we spent. Oh, this
second time warp actually coming into
play here with Kai'Sa. The last three
>> mine root. And this is exactly something
that George was talking to me about in
this interview where you play seven and
five of the split here of the runes here
because all of your late game choices
like this time warp are the ones that
cost you this mind. This means the hold
will actually take us to seven points
here with the pouty porro. And now what?
It's just as simple as a Falling Stars
Darius or the accelerated Kai'Sa that we
picked up earlier with the retreat to be
the game.
>> Yeah, you as So, you know, I think one
time warp, I guarantee you is on
Talion's radar, but playing around two
time warps almost impossible. And George
is going to just do exactly what he has
to do. There's the fist bump. There's
the match. George just showing why like
he loves this Kaisa deck cuz he he just
knows how to pilot it so well.
I I've played a little bit of League of
Legends and using Ekko's ultimate as a
little heart twice in uh that quick
succession like we saw in that game.
Masterful gameplay there from George. A
actual master class when playing a
legend like Kai'Sa even against herself
of course. Um but I promise to the
viewers that I won't lie to them this
time. Frank, we do at least have one
more match that we're going to showcase
here for top 32. But congratulations to
George moving on. So, but we are going
to be jumping in a little bit later.
Frank, again, this tournament is moving
at a breakneck pace, which means we're
going to be jumping into game three of
Clyde on Master Yi versus Samson on
Misfortune. Ooh, this is a very
interesting matchup. Uh, both decks kind
of have a a similar swath of cards
coming from Bodies. Some of the same big
units, both trying to get them into play
in different ways. Unless, you know,
Misfortune, I would bet, is on the
Dazzling Aurora build. Some Yeis are,
some Ye aren't. It'll be interesting to
see what these players are bringing to
the table.
>> Yeah. So everybody at home once again
jumping into game three here of this
other feature match. Again, we we want
to showcase as much riftbound gameplay
as we can going into it. So I don't know
the story obviously from games 1 to two,
but we have for the battlefield choices
here sigil of the storm here from Samson
and then the asparent climb from Clyde,
which means we are going to have
ourselves a bit of a long one again.
>> Definitely. And that mobilize coming
down from Clyde communicates to me that
hey, I think this is an Aurora Yi. So
this is just going to be a battle of the
Auroras. Let's see who can do it best.
>> And the zony's hourglass coming down
here as the quick uh second turn play
here from Clyde after using that
mobilize like you said just ramping and
then on the other side Sam says I'll
pass. Nothing really coming into play
here but Clyde is currently on pace to
be the first person to play the dazzling
Aurora which could go a long way here in
this matchup obviously.
>> Definitely Barrett and we'll have to
Yep. There it is.
>> Yeah, we're obviously going to be moving
this here a little bit quicker at pace
because again we're moving into this
tournament very quickly. The first
dazzling proc coming in here. I guess
we're not.
>> The other day I saw three catalysts in a
row. It's crazy.
>> Oh, triple find your center means those
are going to go on the bottom of the
deck. But we have a tasty faith folk
that's going to come in and go straight
to base for Clyde.
>> Yep. Deep down find the tasty faith folk
right into play and it'll be back to
Samson's.
>> Yeah. Now the dazzling answer of course
is going to come in here. But, you know,
now I have to think about and I have to
ask you, when you look at cards like
Zonas on the other side of the table,
when you look at the Master Yi Legend
versus you playing Misfortune, who do
you actually think has the edge here
when they're playing very similar decks,
but you have access to different
domains?
>> Yeah, that's a great question, Barrett.
I think it kind of just comes down to
interestingly now that both Auroras are
in play, you know, last match we saw
Kaiso where there was kind of a lot of
play on the table, a lot of decisions.
It's almost in Aurora's hands now in
some way because you know you can hit
things like tasty fay folk or you could
hit things like dead bloom predator and
there's really quite a big range there
and Samans's first hit is a
mindspplitter which is a really really
powerful chaos option that Clyde doesn't
have access to.
>> Yeah. And now we know full hand options
as well. And we saw two units there in
the side of uh Clyde's hand, which
luckily again the dazzling deck is once
you get the dazzling out, you're allowed
to play units still from your hand of
course, but that's not exactly where you
want them to be when it comes to the
mileage of the dazzling Aurora. But
again, hand knowledge means so much in
Riftbound because we only draw one card
a turn typically.
>> Definitely. And I'm really excited for
this. I actually have not seen a match
like this where both players have an
Aurora. It's just going to be a slugfest
>> and it's going to be a quick one too as
we are moving very quickly. But Master E
honed coming in from the champion unit
zone. And it does come in ready for a
double conquer play here from Clyde
getting him on the board very quickly.
And remember that Zonia's hourglass is
going to save which of these units died
first.
>> Yeah, Zonia's hourglass definitely one
of the powerful options coming from K
saying like, "Hey, maybe my tasty fay
folk isn't as big as your mind
spplitter, but it's pretty nice when I
got to have it twice."
>> White flame protector coming in here for
the actual dazzling aurora. And so even
on enter is still going to give the
might, but then the turn ends of course,
so it doesn't really matter there. But
it is still an eight might body for
later.
>> Back is Oh, you know what breaks the the
dazzling Aurora parody? How about two?
>> Wow, this is really going to be a real
match because we're going to have access
to so many different things. We even now
have our mountain drake coming in here
and 10 might is a lot that can answer
against this E deck definitely. But one
thing you do have to keep in mind, an
edge that he has is that Wuju Bladesman
Legend. So those units, they might look
like the Dead Bloom Predator can fight
them, but they would have an extra plus
two while defending and it would
actually be a trade. So Sam Sans is
going to play it to the base instead.
>> Yeah, holding things back right now. And
again, you know, powerful ability from
the Legend of Misfortune being able to
give ganking to any of their units. So
once you're on a battlefield, the holds
are very powerful because you don't have
to bring them back to base. You can
immediately go over to the other
battlefield.
>> Yeah. And right now, Clyde definitely
ahead ahead on points at the very least.
But with that second Aurora in play, if
Clyde can't leverage this tempo and look
to close it out, Samans is going to not
only catch up, but start to vault ahead
very quickly. And very important to keep
in mind, we are playing to nine this
game. So even though Clyde's on four,
he's not just two turns away from
winning.
>> Yeah. Going to be a lot of decisions to
be made here. And it's not just like,
you know, the inevitability if we don't
find a second Dazzlinger of our own or
can't close out the game at a quicker
rate, but you can only get two points a
turn in this game. This that's how
Riftbound is played. And so not only
that, but the disruption that the chaos
domain brings for the misfortune
dazzling deck is so different. We have
already seen the mind splitter, but I
have to also think of cards like soul
gorgger that could exist in this list to
bring back more units that you would
otherwise lose. And what does master get
to do about that? Yeah, it is
interesting cuz you know you will
eventually run out of units if these
Auroras are going on long enough. And I
do think, you know, Chaos has some of
those tools to get the units back into
the deck or play them from the trash and
do it again and again. So, in a way, I
think if it goes long enough, Sam Sans
really is going to be favored here.
>> Stack deck looking for some more cards.
Of course, once you get double dazzling
out, you really get to do whatever you
want with your runes on your turn. Um,
in the same sense, Clyde only really
played immobilize and then grabbing
another tasty fateful off the top from
his dazzling on his turn. But sabotage
coming in here on the side of Samans,
but a defy to have it. So, you already
know what's in my hand. I don't want to
give you any more information on the new
stuff that I've drawn, but the first
contest here coming in from Sans Sands
of the Mountain Drake moving into that
Master Y. 10 versus 8.
>> 10 versus 8. I like those numbers. But
now it's 10 versus 10
>> in a draw here on the discipline as
well. This is only a trade.
>> Well, this is really where Za's
hourglass might get its chance to shine
because, you know, a trade I would
gladly trade that hourglass for that
mountain drake. That looks like a great
trade for Clyde and I think he would be
okay with it. So now it's up to Sam Sans
to decide if they can, you know, turn it
into something a little less one-sided.
>> What would you expect here? There's
really not a ton of tricks I can really
think off the top of my head if this is
like a fight or flight that we typically
find in these misfortune decks. Um, I
even think of like cards like challenge.
Like you could play it now, I suppose,
on the action speed, right? You're
allowed to pick that and you could maybe
get some extra mileage out of your
mountain like first before it dies.
>> Yeah, Saman's definitely, you know,
without the calm doesn't have access to
all the tricks like on guard and
discipline to kind of win these fights
honestly. But Chaos does bring those
movement tools like fight or flight
where she's she could say, "Hey, maybe
I'm not going to threaten killing your
Y, but at least I kick it back to the
base, get to keep my mountain drake, and
score." But the big one she has is
Bullet Time, which is Misfortune's kind
of haymaker. Dump all your runes, deal a
ton of damage, and that could lead to a
pretty big swing turn later in this
game. I I would love to see a card like
Bullet Time be the reason why we sack
all of our runes at the end of the day
because, you know, Clyde goes for like a
huge hold turn or, you know, puts all of
their units up into battlefields ready
to be available for a play like that.
But instead here, we are going to be
playing a primal strength to be buffing
up. Well, no, actually, sorry, that was
just one of the cards we revealed. We've
got a dead bloom predator coming in here
first.
>> No, I think I think that I think you
might be right. This is a primal
strength on the predator. Oh,
>> and while
>> I missed the predator play that happened
yesterday, but yeah. So, or last turn,
primal strength here contesting against
basically doing your own little white
flame impersonation.
>> Yeah, definitely. While a lot of the
smaller might boosts are in calm, that
doesn't mean body bodies got the big
punch. And that dead balloon predator I
believe is going to go all the way up to
a 15 to look to contest this 10 on the
white flame predator or protector
going to get another point on the board
here for Samans and Clyde is now losing
more units more quickly obviously one of
which was replaced with the zonas that
we saw but it means as more units come
out faster for Samans what is Clyde
going to do to keep continue pace and
keep those units into play because
remember we know that Clyde has things
like dead boom predator in hand.
>> Yeah, that's a great question. I think
Clyde is just going to do the best he
can to kind of keep up, make sure he
maintains that point lead he already has
as best as possible. Sam Sans right now
thinking about, hey, is it worth going
to the sigil of the storm? Is should I
expose my mind spplitter? Do I want to
have to recycle a rune to that sigil
cost? And it looks like the answer is
yes. And now we're going to the end of
the turn for the double Aurora flip.
>> Do you think how how many units do you
think are in this deck? I think that's a
big question we have to ask ourselves.
>> That's a great question. I think it's
pretty player preference. I've seen the
range of, you know, usually like three
dead bloom, three mind spplitters. After
that, it could kind of fork a bit. Maybe
you just play a gorgger or two to like
reby. Maybe you play a big volley bear
to have a, you know, a real haymaker
option. We already saw like a mountain
drake come in here. So, my guess would
be somewhere in the range of 10, maybe
upwards of 12 if you really want to make
sure you have all the hits. There's that
Volibar, the imposing one on the body
domain. And then we also have a mind
spplitter that we're going to be playing
for some extra disruption. So, uh,
although the sabotage did get defied
earlier, we are going to still be be
able to see the cards in Clyde's hand
that we didn't now know from earlier.
Mindsplitter is going to be going first
here. And then we're going to put that
Volibar imposing onto the battlefield,
which is where you get the full
advantage of its other abilities.
>> Yeah, Saman's really just using both of
these Auroras to full effect. Going to
take out another white flame with that
Mindsplitter and really just look to
pick apart any offensive that Clyde
might have. It's so smart because if
both of you are playing the similar
amount of units, the fact that
mindsplitter is essentially removal but
from the hand makes a huge advantage
here for Samans.
>> Yeah, now Clyde's going to have to
figure out what he can do because again
with just one Aurora to two, he's going
to have to close this game out fast if
he wants a chance to win.
>> He's in the tank. He's thinking really
have to assess here on what to do
because all of a sudden you'd think man
I I was the first player to play a
dazzling Aurora this match. I got early
points. We're playing to nine. It's
exactly the kind of game we want. But
the second Dazzling Aurora here from
Samans is really the game changer
>> thinking doing math. Definitely don't
want to be hasty.
>> There's that deadline. We know about
going and trying to contest against the
mind spplitter.
>> Yeah, the Volibar does say when you move
to the battlefield, right? And dead womb
isn't moving. You're playing it there.
So,
>> I believe it does. I It seems like
they're checking that right now to be
sure, but if that is true, then a draw
would not happen here.
>> Yeah, that seems to be the case as we
are going to now go to a showdown. Dead
Bloom versus Mindsplitter 8 to 7. Ooh,
you talked about this already, but here
comes a bullet time. And at least when
it comes down to choosing whether you
defy this or not, you have to make the
decision before the amount of runes you
choose to recycle on for the effect. So,
it's on Clyde to make that decision,
right?
>> Yeah. very nice advantage that bullet
time has cuz you know if you had to
spend all the runes up front and then it
got countered there's probably not much
coming back from that. So I do see a
defy in Clyde's hand and he's going to
he's going to have to think here do I
want to do this and it's interesting to
think I can't tell if Samans has eight
runes but it's interesting to think
would they dump them all to just kill
the dead bloom and keep the mind
spplitter or are they just looking to
recycle you know just one make it a nice
honest trade. I think the trade is
probably the best call. Again, you're
already using your cards to eliminate
more of Clyde's units out of the game.
And assuming again, we haven't
necessarily seen everything fully on
Samson's deck, at least when it comes to
units. Maybe we have. I'm not really
sure. Don't know the full picture, but
if we have things like Soul Gorge, we
can really take advantage of just doing
these trades. Okay. And it looks like
Clyde is saying,
"Oh, wait. They might
>> I think we're getting judge confirmation
about that interaction that we just
talked about which is making the
decision to defy before the other extra
cost is paid. Um so just getting
clarifications we want to make sure we
dot all of our eyes and check our te's
and the players want the full
information of course and clarification.
Um which makes sense. So this gives us
some time then here Frank you're staring
across I look at double tasty faithful
which is draw and channeling of runes if
you do end up paying any power costs. a
honi that we kept alive because of our
zony's hourglass. And now we've played
this dead bloom from our hand plus all
of the different units that are already
in Clyde's trash. How many do we have
left? That's two white flames gone. We
probably of course have more dead
blooms, but I can't imagine there's a
ton more tasty fate folks. And that
champion unit is a once per game
basically.
>> Yeah, that's a great point, Barrett, cuz
I imagine when Clyde built his deck, he
was thinking, "Hey, how many big units
do I need to maybe overcome an Annie,
overcome a Kai'Sa?" not how many big
units do I need to just win the absolute
triple dazzling Aurora and play Slugfest
and he could really be at risk of
running out soon.
>> We do see instead of the Defy coming
through, it was just a little bit of
extra damage coming through for that
bullet time and Clyde has one of my
favorite cards and mechanics that exist
in Origins Rune Prison to stun a unit
which says that this mindsplitter is
going to do no damage. Yeah, little
little shout out to Rise coming in with
the with the rune prison. And with that
stun, the extra damage from bullet time
isn't going to matter. The mind
spplitter is going to die. And very
important, the dead bloom is going to
score the point and get Clyde up to
five. So now he is on pace to win in two
turns and get to that critical point of
nine. Yep, of course having to recycle a
rune there that we just witnessed
because of that sigil of the storm. And
as we are going to probably end up
passing back to Sam Sands, we did spend
quite a bit of our runes there
power-wise. So, not going to see like a
third dazzling hit the table or
anything. Not even maybe a big unit. But
now it's basically up to Clyde on how
we're going to assess where to move the
rest of these units that we have and how
many then are left for the rest of the
game.
>> Definitely. And the real thing, you
know, this is where the misfortune
legend bounty hunter really comes into
play. That ganking is huge. You may
think Voly Bear is trapped over at
Aspen's crime, but a quick gank would
bring him over to the dead bloom, but
here's a huge attack from Clyde.
>> Yeah. So we've got honed ye coming in
with double tasty fa folk and we are
really just looking for a trade to get
that volar off the table and it makes
sense right the giant shield that occurs
off of that volar imposing the dead
bloom three units for one Samans
probably feels really good about that
>> yeah but you know Clyde he does get to
bounce back some of those runes some
cards from the death from the fay folks
and I he did just must decide hey if
this Volibear sticks in play I just
can't win I'm going to have to take this
trade now while I can
>> here comes off the top We knew there was
a couple more dead blooms still probably
in this deck. So now we have one. Do we
take the trade one for one against the
opposing dead bloom or do we put this in
our base or reinforce the other
battlefield?
>> I mean if Clyde also Nope. It's just
going to be a trade. I was going to say
if you somehow had an extra trick like
on guard to push that in his favor. That
would be huge. But for now he's just
going to say I'm going to take the
trade. I'm going to try to slow you
down. I've got my fifth point and let's
see what you can do. Samson Sans
>> five points officially two turns with
double conqueror holds to get to a win
there. Samson still going to have to
play some more catchup at least in the
point game but like you said that's not
the priority of these dazzling decks.
It's about establishing the board state
and the dominance going to go up to
three here now and now it is up to
Samstands to either just go for the
dazzlings at the end of the turn here or
see what we're going to do with our
seven runes.
>> You know the more we are talking about
this Barrett I think there's a very real
chance that this game just comes down to
who runs out of units first.
and in the same time while you're
running out of units. But a mountain
drake being very good to help contest
against that dead bloom or at least tie
with it. And then now the third mind
spplitter coming in here and there's not
really a lot you can do about that one.
It's a unit with the ability of
sabotage. Not sabotage itself, but plus
up.
>> Yeah, these minds spplitters have really
really just been backbreaking. kind of
really showing why a lot of people go to
these chaos builds of Dazzling Aurora
because just it's just such a powerful
card to put into play and not only get a
lot of might on the table, but just take
out the most important card in your
opponent's hand. And Clyde has got to be
feeling that right now. Mountain Drake
being played to support and reinforce
that first mine spplitter. But the other
min spplitter just coming back to the
base for Samstands and getting that
charm out of the hand for Clyde I think
was huge because that would have been a
way for him to take advantage and maybe
force something like this mountain drake
to fight this dead bloom and maybe a
couple of tricks to get over and might.
>> Definitely. And Clyde right now just
doing the counting. Again, we are
playing with open deck lists at this
point. He's trying to figure out, hey,
you know, I've seen what you've used.
I've seen a lot of cards go to the
bottom of the deck from these auroras.
What's left?
Not a whole lot, Frank, as I think we
are quickly approaching critical mass of
this game.
>> Yep. Now, Clyde is counting his own
units, being like, "What do I have
left?" And it's really just uh who's
going to run out first. A little afraid
it's Clyde right now, especially because
that don't want to discredit that
misfortune that's still hanging out in
the champion zone.
>> I love the confidence here from
Samstance because they didn't use any of
their runes. they it's just filled in
time for tricks and you already know
that you're playing against double the
defy in hand.
>> Yes, Saman's just saying, "Hey, I've got
this drip coming in from the dazzling
Aurora. I don't really need to worry
about committing my runes right now. I'd
rather just keep him up for tricks and
make sure that Clyde can't do the one
thing that he really needs to do and get
that point total up to nine.
>> And here comes a Volibar imposing from
Clyde himself. gonna obviously well I
think we're making the decision where we
want to put it as it's um still
posturing but if we put it in our base
it doesn't get it access to its
abilities to help but with the dead
bloom it then leads it susceptible to
any sort of abilities that could do kill
it through removal.
>> Yeah the big sometimes the big bear just
don't care but right now it's going into
the sigil and this might be a great
opportunity for bounty hunter to kind of
show the full breath of why this
dazzling aurora deck works. Yeah,
passing back. Getting one hold point up
for Samstands. Now quickly approaching
the same point total for Clyde.
And but the biggest thing here though,
Samans didn't play anything that full
turn cycle. We didn't we didn't play any
cards aside from the Dazzlings of
course. And you know, there's only so
many units that do exist in these decks
that we talked about. But I'm waiting
for things, you know, things like fight
or flight. They're going to help close
out this game. I think of the cards like
challenge that we've talked about that
are really going to help target these
pesky units like that bear imposing and
maybe get it off of the board without
having to actually fight it.
>> Yeah, you know, Sam Sans might not have
the disciplines, but they do have the
discipline to hold back their tricks,
save them for when they need them. That
one
>> I like that one.
>> Uh I I've been doing puns all weekend,
Frank, you know, so I'm a big fan of
them. Of course, challenge coming in
here. Now, of course, when you play
this, you do have to declare the targets
and what you want to be fighting with
each other. And then we have the
decision as Clyde, do we want to defy
it?
>> And it looks like the answer is yes.
You know, it's interesting because you
saw Clyde really just sacrifice a ton of
units to get Saman's Volibear off the
table. And it's going to be interesting
to see what Saman does to get Clyde's
Voli Bear off the table or if they even
can.
>> Yeah, it's dare I say the biggest unit
in Origins.
>> Definitely. And you know, thing I'm
thinking about this is game three. we
have to remember. And I do think both of
these decks kind of keep some extra
units in the sideboard for matches like
this to make sure they don't run out.
And that's probably where things like
these Voli Bears and Mountain Dre are
coming from. So there might be a couple
more than you might initially anticipate
for a game one scenario. I
>> I think that makes a ton of sense and
you're 100% correct. And so we're just
kind of, you know, playing a couple more
cards. I think we have officially hit
the state based off of all the cards for
Sam Sands. We're officially out of units
in the deck for Samands and we are not
ahead in points. This matters a lot when
it comes down to how does Clyde close it
out. Well, if both of these units are
just going to stare at each other on
these two different battlefields, Clyde
inevitably wins.
>> Definitely. And it's interesting to see
there no soul gorgers from the side of
Saman saying, "I'm not rebying anything.
I've just got the units I got." And it's
interesting to see if Clyde is in the in
the same position. And that is the weird
almost advantage of being the single
Aurora player is you kind of run out
slower and he might have more in the
tank.
>> Charm coming in here. We knew that he
didn't have one earlier, but Clyde now
getting access to one that he drew in
the past couple of turns. Charm going to
be able to help basically function as
removal for one of these units on
Saman's side.
>> Yeah. And Saman's flicking furiously
with those cards in the hand. Feeling
the pressure. Going to see if they have
a clean answer to this charm.
Looks like the mountain drake's popping
over.
>> Mountain drake is the chosen target. It
moves over to the battlefield. Showdown
has now started,
>> but Samans is the attacker.
>> The Ye legend, I believe, is a trigger,
which means since we have two units
here, it's going to officially have
missed the window. So even if one
leaves,
>> yes,
>> checking that right now. So then in
within the showdown, we have a rebuke
coming in here where we're going to
target that imposing Volibar. Put it
back into the hand.
But we have a trick of our own. The Ong
Guard that we have talked about
basically the whole game now being
played here to give plus two. And then
now another bullet time coming in. And
then we have to make that decision once
again. There's that second defy that we
knew was already in the hand of Clyde
using the exact pieces needed. And so
that drake is going to hit the trash.
>> Yeah, almost a disaster scenario for
Clyde where the charm could have
backfired, but he knew he had just what
he needed to make sure that he could
keep it up. And there's a dead bloom
onto the mind spplitter and the hand
comes out.
>> There it is. The match going to Clyde.
Master ye dazzling take it down. Just
not enough units for Sams, but really
felt like we were in the driver's seat
there to really take that down. But
impeccable match. I really would love to
have seen what games one and two looked
like, but that was a great game three
for us to look at.
>> Yeah, really amazing match, really
amazing matchup. Sometimes just great to
see giant units going back and forth.
And I guess it turns out sometimes one
dazzling Aurora is better than two.
>> Well, impeccable players, impeccable
decks, impeccable talent, not just there
in the tournament, but sitting right
beside me, of course. Frank, it's been
an absolute honor working with you this
weekend, and I'm a little sad that I've
got to say goodbye to you. But for
everyone at home, we do have some more
exciting gameplay that's going to be
coming up here shortly. Frank, before we
say goodbye, of course, I do want to ask
you, what was your favorite deck that
you saw this weekend? Uh, so you know,
my favorite deck, it's just always going
to be Teemo right now in Origins. I know
Prismaticism started the day in the top
64 cut playing the Teemo deck even after
we saw them take an early loss and, you
know, I'm excited to get back out there,
get on the floor, and find him and see
if he's still in there battling.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Team Oo does have some
representation here in our top 64 across
the day and I'm excited to see even an
update on what decks are progressing
throughout the tournament and who we are
slowly approaching to maybe end up in
that finals match. Frank, any final
thoughts?
>> No, I mean I'm just excited. You know,
I'm going to watch the end of this, not
from the booth, but from the seats and I
just want to see who wins.
>> I'll be right with you in a little
while, but we're going to cut away to a
break and we will be back shortly here
for some extra exciting gameplay here in
Houston, Texas.
[Music]
Another stop here at the Houston
Regional Qualifier for Riftbound is the
merch store, the Riot Games merch store,
where you can buy not only Riftbound
accessories such as sleeves and mats
featuring the overnumbered legends from
Origins, but plushies from League of
Legends, Elder Dragon, Tom Kench,
tippers, and so much more. KDA merch. I
can only imagine coming to an event like
this and not only being able to pick up
more card game accessories, but statues,
figures, and statueets of some of my
favorite champions from League of
Legends. But there's some good stuff
here. You want to follow me through the
portal.
There's some exciting things for us to
check out, at least in the display
cases. Not only can you buy those
statuettes, but you can also buy statues
wall hangs of some of your most favorite
champions in the entire game. misfortune
of here and I think the most popular
item this weekend, the world's 2024
Riftbound bundle. Now, this was
something you could only get off of the
riot store online, but now they are
available in person here in Houston at
the regional qualifier. Of course, a
nice little showcase of some of our
favorite statues and legends from the
game of League of Legends that we love
so much, including Ari, who has multiple
skin lines for you to support. And of
course, Darius standing triumphantly
just like he does in Riftbound. So, if
you're missing out on any of the Riot
Games merch that you can check out and
that you want to get a hold of
yourselves, make sure you stop by to the
merch store section.
Welcome back, Rift Bounders. I'm excited
to be joined officially with Aaron
Barrett for the second time this
weekend. I will shake your hand if you'd
like.
>> Yeah, whatever.
>> Welcome. How are you feeling today?
>> I'm doing great. I mean, I got to watch
some early matches. They were really
awesome to watch. And now I get to be
here and watch some more even more
awesome matches with even higher stakes
as people get closer to to our finalist.
>> If not the high I mean every tournament
round that we go through, they get
higher and higher stakes. And so it
feels almost like I I feel myself
shaking a little bit more as the rounds
go through. I can only imagine the
players that we're going to be able to
watch going through here and talking
about those impeccable players. Luckily
enough, we've done a pretty good job of
getting a lot of extra interviews and
getting the insight of these players
going into this event. So, one of the
feature matches that we're going to be
able to talk about in this top 16 that's
going to be coming up here shortly. We
had a moment to get a little bit of
insight from them as well. So, we're
going to go ahead and show you all some
insight on our upcoming feature match.
[Music]
All right, I'm here with Allen's EQ.
You've just made it into the top 16. How
does it feel to be dominating in another
Riot Card game?
>> I wouldn't say dominating. I think I'm
doing just all right, but I had a doubt
today. First match out of years that I
actually felt shaky. I had like my hand
wasn't steady. I didn't have that since
last time world's finals pretty much at
Run Terra and I'm going to tell you it
feels amazing having that feeling back.
>> Bro, that is excellent. I love that.
That's what I want to hear, Alan. So,
how has the run been going overall? I
know you're on Kai'Sa. How's the deck
been humming?
>> I mean, there were no believers in my
version, but it's been proving and
proving back and back running undefeated
in scrimmage back here. yesterday being
undefeated again. Today having two-1
both games, losing one game to the
Kaisa, losing one game, small games to
the E, but just being able barely to
pull through. Those were very tough
games.
>> All right, Alan. Well, I don't want to
keep too much of your time. I want you
to focus on your top eight match. Uh,
but thank you so much for coming and
talking to us and uh, good luck in the
rest. We'll send it back to the desk.
[Music]
>> And there we have it. Allan ZQ. We had
the pleasure of watching him yesterday
and making a deep run here in this
tournament. I mean, we saw the kind of
plays that he was making yesterday. It's
very easy to see why he's here.
>> Yeah, I mean, his play yesterday truly
impeccable. Had some masterful usage of
Candleit Sanctum and stacking cards in
his deck in a way that was really
favorable for him. You know, previous
Legends are in terror world champion.
Not shocked to see him doing well here
today and I'm really excited to see him
play some more uh this round.
>> Absolutely. But we don't want to keep
our viewers waiting, of course. Top 16
underway going in Alan ZQ who we just
highlighted placing playing Kai'Sa of
course against the mirror in KGO and had
the pleasure Aaron while you know with
Frank that we already did watch a Kai'Sa
mirror and the intricacies that go in
this back and forth really are difficult
to execute and fundamentally at the end
of the day I really do think the best
player will end up the victor of this
match.
>> Yeah I mean the Kaiser mirrors are
really skill intensive. There's a lot of
decisions on a turn-to- basis. That's
part of the power of Kaisa. The deck is
really flexible. There are some rooms in
the deck building where you can
potentially try and get an edge. Some
people really think cards like Time Warp
are really strong in the mirror. Some
people think they're not good at all and
they play zero copies. Uh depending on
where these players are, they could both
have completely different philosophies.
>> Yeah, and as Frank has been telling us
all day today, these are open deck
lists. Both of these players know the
full information. And you said, you talk
about the time warps. We got to witness
George G play a double time warp. Two
turns. Took three turns in a row for the
win. And so we'll have to see if both of
these Kaisa players really do value
doing that. Battlefields of choice here
are double reavers row for game one. And
I think that's going to create some
crazy dynamics I think.
>> Yeah, doubles reavers row is a type of
game that feels so different than normal
riftbound. A lot of the time in
matchups, especially with the kaisedc
units like Darius and Thousand Watcher
are really good at going in and removing
your opponent's units. Here though, they
just kick them out. Uh the battle for
units at the base becomes a lot more
important. things like falling star
falling star and a caffeine rain more
valuable than ever
>> absolutely early turn two plays or turn
one plays of course with our two drops
patty porro versus watchful sentry and I
think that's the other point is that
it's not so much I think about that
dynamic of moving the units like you so
pointed out but when I don't see a
dreaming tree this early on at least in
the beginning of this match it means I
think the cards we are going to be
drawing are purely because the cards
themselves say draw one so does it
almost feel like the player that plays
more cards that draw will find more
answers quickly to then take advantage
of this game.
>> There is some value to that. Really
interesting action here. This watchful
sentry running into a pouty porro. Uh
maybe trying to either have a cleave or
bluff a cleave get this pouty porro out.
Uh interesting choice from KGO of do I
think you have it. Um I will say that
this is a matchup where since it's
double reavers row, a lot of the game is
about can I get ahead and stay ahead on
those points. Card draw matters and
finding the correct answers at the right
time matters, but definitely less
important than a constant board presence
and pressure on your opponent.
>> Speaking of board presence, probably one
of the best turn twos we could have from
KGO, right, with the two drop then
followed up by the two costing Knox's
hopeful now with the Legion ability and
Allen of course has some more units of
their own and it's just double watchful
sentry. So talk about card advantage,
right? Drawing and replacing.
>> Yeah, this is really going to put what I
just said to the test. We have KGO
putting more stats into play. Nox is
hopeful really big for its cost and
Allen just having all these one might
units really going to be a situation of
okay I can capitalize and get some cards
hopefully that's good for me I will say
in a game with reverse row you just saw
it there the watchful sentry got taken
away a lot of its strength normally is
that ability to conquer give you a point
and though it gets removed you get a
card back but that's just not quite the
same in a double reaver rogue game
>> yeah I'm excited to see what we're going
to do with these wadful centuries when I
can only imagine as we now see this
Kaisa survivor getting accelerated from
KGO going into this Reaver's Row going
to get the conquered draw effect. What
are these one might units really going
to be able to do unless they're being
supported by you know some of the spells
that you know Kaiso is able to play.
>> Yeah, there's an interesting option for
Allen here where you can potentially
just send all of your watchful sentries
into this pouty porro. It means you
won't be able to run away with more than
one of them from the reavers row. But do
you even really care? They're kind of
here to score some points and die. And
Allen is going second and is behind on
this points race. So that type of trade
is exactly what he's going to be needing
to make here in the early turns.
>> Do you think going first in this mirror
match is so strongly important when it
comes to actually closing out the match
as a whole?
>> Going first is important of course, but
there is uh decisions you can make
during deck building. Things like time
warp are really strong and allow you to
break serve, but if you have those in
your opening hand, especially while
going second, they can lead to really
clunky draws. uh you you're really much
more interested in having a lot of those
cheap plays, hex tech rays, void
seekers, maybe a Darius to break through
a board and attack their stuff. Uh so
that in that deck building element is
where the play draw gets pushed even
farther.
>> Absolutely.
>> I love how we're going to see a lot of
these units stick around for quite some
time. So in this turn, you saw the
watchful sentry go back to the reavers
row and Kio once again pulled out the
pouty porro. In the previous turn, Allen
made that play potentially saying, "Hey,
I have a cleave." And Kio once again
believes it. Allen is really posturing,
"Hey, I have this cleave. This is
something I'm going to be using." And
he's doing it again here, moving this
watchful sentry into the Kai'Sa.
However, it looks like Kio said, "Okay,
maybe as a stupify here in case of the
cleave." And it's funny, right? Because
that same exact posture that ended up in
presented, we then did a similar tactic
on the other Reaver's row, but Kio said,
"No, I'll keep my Kai'Sa here." And then
we did see that cleave come through to
go over. And so we have to have the
retreat come through for KGO to keep the
Kai'Sa and channel us while we do. So
>> yeah, these Watchful senties maybe only
one might. Still scored points into a
two and a four this turn.
>> I did eat my words. You are 100% right.
Kaiser Survivor coming in unacelerated
of course just getting some extra units
onto the table passing back to KGO and
we're are now hitting the key eight
energy or runes available to us so that
things like accelerated watchful
thousand tail watchers are available and
on the play now but when you're staring
across all these one might units not
really so much to do there.
>> Yeah, watch uh thousand tail watcher you
know good for breaking big boards. This
is not a game about big boards. Reaver's
Row kind of says that's just not what
we're doing here in KGO. Still ahead on
this points race kind of gets to dictate
the flow of how good something like that
actually is
where it gets tough for sure.
Do you think it's as important to go to
five now, maintain that lead that you
have on the points while also still, you
know, presenting all of these difficult
situations on whether or not you use a
reaver's row or start trading some
resources from Allen. I mean, we do have
two readyied runes. We do have cards
available to us to help us out.
>> I mean, getting the points in the
Reavers Row games are pretty free. The
only things you have to worry about are
potential things like void seekers now
being able to remove your units cuz
they're at the battlefield. But any
combat, you always get that option to
run away. So taking the points are
pretty free. Kio mostly just thinking
there, do I need to play and accelerate
this Kai'Sa? Is it worth it compared to
just going in with one of my other units
I already have in play to get this extra
card. Um now less runes up. Something
like this hex tech ray potentially
removing the Kaisen, not letting a card
draw happen. Uh makes it where maybe KGO
doesn't feel as good about this play or
putting these things in here compared to
just running in with something that is
less valuable.
>> Yeah. Uh, our cleave of our own though
going to help out and give the assault
three. Stupify in response.
>> Allan just cycling that stupify. It
doesn't impact the combat. I don't think
Oh, in response. Yes. So, it's going to
die from the hex tech ray, the cleave
action. Gets to respond, kill it. That's
a pretty big blowout for Allen. That's
the type of things you really need to
break the serve. Uh, not stopping the
point, but definitely getting a lot of
energy value. uh KGO spending five for
the Kaiso, one for the cleave, and Allen
getting to get rid of that for just the
stupify and the hexte ray.
>> I've never seen so many one might units
take these kind of trades because of
those masterful decisions that you just
described that I I kind of was in awe
and I'm glad you explained it because it
was very very clutch and the idea of
already having deal three. But as we
pass back, we did again get that point
for KGO going to five. And now I think
it is up to Allen in a prime spot for
him to really come back here and tie up
those points.
Yeah, I really want to go back to that
previous combat. Kio had let the hex
tech ray
resol. It's one of those things where
when you are attacking into a unit right
there, you have that opportunity to play
your cleave first. You could have chosen
to make your unit large enough where it
wouldn't have been removed. Yeah. But
you have to preempt knowing your
opponent's gonna have this hex tech ray
and the stupify. And that's one of the
really tough decision calls you have to
make in these Kaisen years.
>> Yeah. Action timing versus reaction
timing like when that stupify came out.
It's it's why the game is so intricate
and fun in my opinion is this kind of
highle gameplay that we're talking
about. Slinging spells that we know so
well. Uh moving things in of course
going to be able to contest and get that
point for Allen. We did end up losing of
course one of those watchful sentries as
now another a falling star going to be
coming in here to completely remove the
units off of KGO's board but having to
pay that deflect cost of course.
>> Yeah, Kai'Sa already used having to
spend all the runes in the falling star
but letting these watchful sentries go
in and score points. Allan early on
saying I could let you kill my watchful
sentry and draw a card or I can run it
away with the reverse row saying I think
these sentries will be worth more than
just a card later and he's really
proving that out now.
And we're in another situation where
Thousand Tail Watcher to me doesn't look
like the like the best line when it
comes to like accelerating it and
getting onto the board. We we are now
really losing access to the units that
we had available. Now they're all gone.
But Darius, I think, is a good way to
get on there for a little bit cheaper.
Just requires you to play a second card.
Raven Bloom, another unit, of course.
So, seven might on this Darius going to
be able to contest one of these
battlefields at least.
Yeah, Darius here definitely much better
than the Watcher. Going to take a whole
turn to do that. Darius at least lets
you play the another unit so you're able
to condense both battlefields next turn.
Kio going up to that number six. Really
important that Darius if Allen goes in
just gets to go back to the base. Gets
to probably go in as a seven again.
Likely taking another battlefield. So
Allen's really looking to have more of a
solid removal answer for this Darius to
make sure Kio can't get that win next
turn, which still may be hard if Kio is
holding something like that Thousand
Tail Watcher making it where Allen can't
really hold the battlefields in a really
great way. Pass back hold to 6 for
Allen. As we now move in with both of
our units, the contesting for five might
versus five might.
>> Kio gets to decide here. Do I think I'm
going to win on my next turn? If I think
I'm going to win, then I want to break
this various back because it's going to
be a seven and your units are always
only going to be a five and I get a plus
two that is worth a lot in this big
numbers fight we're about to have with
all these spells.
>> Yeah. And yeah, Allen's EQ being only at
seven means like it's impossible for him
to win this exact turn unless something
crazy were to happen. Not being at the
threshold to play something like a time
warp that we've talked about. can't take
the extra turn to just kind of steal the
win, but instead just a pouty porro to
reinforce the other Reaver's row with
that watchful sentry passing back to KG
KGO. This could be the game, but a lot
of readed runes on the side for Allen.
>> Yeah, I mean this turn is it. Allen is
at seven, has both battlefields, is
threatening to hold to win. If both are
removed, then that probably means Kio
went in and scored both and is winning
instead. I would be shocked to see
another turn of this game after this
one. five energy for his second Darius
Trifarian. One card as played on the
count right now
and then before it looks like probably
the next card that would be played would
be some sort of spell from our hand
which would then allow this Darius to
gain both of these Darius to gain as the
cleave now being as my choice to give
this assault. It will gain the extra
three. We've seen this all the time.
It's for that 10 might swing that a
Darius is allowed to do. But now with
this other Darius, we're allowed to
swing in with it as well. And no answer
from Allen means game one goes to KGO.
>> Yeah, I mean there was a really
important turn there where Allen was
able to kind of claw back from going
second and being behind by getting a
huge energy advantage by using just a
couple one-cost tricks against a four
and a five. Not enough to come back
though.
>> Absolut absolute calculated gameplay
from both of these players. KGO though
being able to get the win there as now
our battlefields are Arena's greatest
from Allen's EQ on going first when play
and then we have KGO for the candle lit
Sanctum
Arena's greatest always the play first
Battlefield never will you see this
going second any of these players plans
uh really emphasizing that yeah
sometimes the Kaiso deck does just get
to be an aggressive deck you can run in
and score points and that extra point
from the greatest puts a ton of pressure
on the opponent in a game where they are
already starting on the back
No play on or no cuz we're just on this
showdown still but moving in with the
powder poro and we are going to pay this
early deflect cost but like we saw a
little bit earlier it does impose that
deflect cost onto the spell. So Kai'Sa
is allowed to help out with it as well
but we still got to use one.
>> Yeah the hex tech right there paying one
that's a huge decision for Kio that's
going to have a massive impact on the
next multiple turns of the game. down
one rune now I can't play two things
sometimes maybe I can't play three
things later those decisions really hard
to make but values Allen not getting
that point especially because again that
Reena's greatest put an extra point on
the table and is adding extra pressure
to KGO
>> was answered by the retreat and then
because we were so early on in Allen's
turn just plays the porro once again and
keeps one up but like you said denying
the point and that's what matters when
you're going first
>> Kio not playing the Kaiser survivor here
even though they have four runes pretty
loudly saying, "I have a trick." Uh,
with the bounty por though, Allen's
like, "Yeah, sure. Deflect. Do whatever
you're going to do. If you want to avoid
seeker this, so I'm down for that."
I've seen so many uh Kaiser survivors
come in on like just the four runes and
you play it obviously unacelerated cuz
you can't afford it and then you pass
back to somebody else and they falling
stars and it feels like you lose control
very quickly because all you spent on
your turn was playing the Kai'Sa
survivor and for some of these Kaiso
lists, that's the only one they're
typically playing.
So, this sequence was very interesting.
Allan went in. Kio said, "No, I'm
actually not going to remove that, which
means Kio has these four runes ready and
may not get another window to play any
cards this turn." I wonder if this four
energy is just going to kind of get
wasted even with the potential of
playing a Kai'Sa.
>> And that seems to be exactly what's
going to happen. No chain started at all
because we just played a unit and passed
for Allen. whole turn cycle of doing
nothing is really rough.
>> Yeah, that's really interesting from
Allen's side here. That Kai'Sa is face
up, knows KGO could play it and shows
not to and shows not to do anything to
this pounty por. So, you got to be
thinking, what can my opponent be
holding? It must be something that makes
them really value the protection of this
Kai'Sa. Maybe a low unit hand, a lot of
spells, a lot of removal. And maybe
we'll see some of that here. I could
imagine, yeah, a falling star on this
board. pretty good thing to be playing
getting both units even if you have to
pay the deflect for that pouty porro.
>> Yeah, one of more expensive right you
know because of that deflect cost but it
does get all of the units off of the
table and maybe now we see those four
runes we wasted them or you wasted our
time not doing anything before but of
course we can play a lecturing Yortle
get us some you know refund itself and
now we at least have the unit lead when
going in.
>> Yeah, Yortle a nice unit here if you're
kind of low on threats is like replaces
itself. You're not too worried about it
dying. It's pretty small, but it still
does threaten to take those points.
>> Instantly answered by an accelerated uh
Kai'Sa survivor from Allen's EQ. And
here we see what we saw him really have
success with yesterday. This candle atit
Sanctum, which this one's not even his
uh being used with the on conquer draw,
being able to take a look at these top
two cards and decide where you want to
put them.
>> Yeah, one on top, one on bottom. Gets
that one from the Kai'Sa immediately.
Probably a uh pretty good card if you're
willing to take it. At this point, you
have a lot of card. really looking only
for specific things. Either removal
spells to not lose the tempo you have
ahead of the game or some type of big
finisher.
So at the current state catching up a
little bit we played a watchful sentry.
We passed. We kept two up for Allen but
we have now gained that point lead that
we were going to otherwise have
typically from going first anyway. And I
think a lot of it came down to is
because we felt like we we took that
whole turn off from KGO. So it's it's
like we spent some time denied some
points. That was the time for us to
resolidify ourselves, but then it feels
like once again we're kind of in a
normal game state of what normally looks
like when you go second.
>> Yeah, I mean KGO is doing an okay job of
keeping the board clear and catching up.
Void seeker making Allen do the retreat
on that Kai'Sa, but that is still
another accelerate unit in Allen's hand.
going to be able to put pressure on both
these battlefields again. And still had
another one mana play to try and remove
this lecturing. Really pushing KGO back
off the board again. You don't get to
have units. I have accelerate units. I'm
going to keep scoring. Pressure,
pressure, pressure.
>> Yeah. And full rune usage, right?
Because now then we also had a hex tech
going for the conquer forcing a retreat
out of KGO and now just has to play a
two drop. Can't afford the lecturing
yortle anymore because you had to pay
the one on the retreat.
>> Yeah. And you can look at this game.
Allan going first of course has a rune
advantage but also Kio did kill that
Porro early paid that deflect cost. You
can see it in the rune counts here. Kio
only with seven. Allen over here with
looks like 11 runes. The retreat adding
more to that really gets to play his
cards in the way he wants every single
turn. And it really gets to dictate
things like this candle at Sanctum. More
expensive cards usually pretty strong
and more powerful here. A lot of times
early you're pushing those away or if
you spend a lot of your runes, Allen
gets to choose to keep those.
>> He likes them. They must be good.
They're going to help close out this
game hopefully for Allen as we are
quickly approaching more points for
Allen. Going to be going to five once
this accelerated Kaiso goes through
because with no ready runes on the side
of KGO, there's no contest.
>> Yeah, a situation where one of those
time warps or any fancy spell here
really would shut the game really,
really quickly. But also Allen just a
pretty full hand in a lot of options.
KGO here potentially needing something
like an AAN rain to really clear a large
board and be able to catch up. Thousand
tailed Watcher on this turn potentially
pretty good if Allen doesn't have a lot
of actions or reactions to fight back
against that killing both these units.
>> Patty Porro coming back keeping four up
once again always posturing that we have
some sort of answers as that is the
bread and butter for these Kaiso lists.
>> Yeah, even if you don't have these
tricks there's so much value in just
holding up this synergy. There's so many
different little ways of removing
things. You have hex tech ray, void
seeker, retreat, uh, stupify, smokec
screen, and your opponent has to respect
each of them in slightly different ways.
So just saying, okay, I have four up. I
can have so many combinations of those.
Your choice of which ones to play around
can put a ton of squeeze on someone that
is already behind and maybe really
doesn't have the luxury of playing
around much of any of them.
I don't envy KGO's position. I think the
Watchful or Thousand Tailed Watcher is
not a bad play, but with only the
support of this Raven Bloom student, it
still leaves yourself a little
vulnerable at essentially all of your
runes. Again,
>> yeah, if you're having to spend eight
and do it accelerated, you're only
leaving one up. possibly have a hex tech
ray retreat or a stupify but even then
that raven bloom student's going to be
pretty fragile if Allen has another one
of those removal spells hex tech ray or
a void seeker which means your thousand
tailed watcher maybe can't clear both
battlefields you're really likely to get
the kai'Sa but the watchful sentry maybe
just doesn't even get removed
Seems like we are going to commit to at
least playing it without the decision
for the accelerate per se as it's going
to instead be the thousand tailed
watcher plus the falling stars and
because it gets these units very very
low in might and it looks like we're
even going to target the pouty porro in
the base paying that extra deflect cost
again.
>> Yeah, this is another avenue of why
Thousand Tilled Watcher is so powerful.
Falling star also one of the stars of
the Kaiso deck. But those two together
really let you just remove any two units
pretty much anywhere a lot of the time.
And this is a situation where for Kio to
kind of catch up means to really hope
Allen can't take a battlefield next
turn. So getting to take that thing out
of the base and remove the Kai'Sa freely
uh leaves Allen with no units and says,
"Hey, do you have a Darius or
something?"
>> Yeah. And there is that hex tech ray.
That was one of the cards we had access
to for Allen, which is going to get rid
of that Raven Bloom student. So again,
although we removed, you know, the two
more threatening pieces, it means that
there's going to be a hold point here
for Allen. And it means all he really
needs is one accelerated unit to get the
most amount of points he could have
gotten in this next turn. And he still
has so much to be able to play with or
like you said, things like a time warp,
but instead a Cathon rain is going to be
the answer to get rid of this thousand
tailed Watcher.
>> All right. So Allan is saying, "I don't
have anything that can score a point
this turn. I have to do this. I'm going
to remove your thing." Probably still
feeling like pretty good shape. The
point differential here, massive. KGO
needs a lot of things to go right. Being
able to potentially remove this watchful
sentry and have Allen just be on all
spells, no waste to score for a while.
But potentially next turn, a single
accelerate unit is not the same level of
power because this was the turn where if
you could do that and get both, you're
really threatening a lot where once you
get to seven, but you're only scoring
that one battlefield a turn, it's just
not able to close the game.
>> In six though, six to one,
one of the largest non Aurora matchup
point discrepancies I've seen most of
the tournament. Um, but you know, KGO
being up a game, not exactly like the
highest level of pressure, but you
definitely still want to make sure that
your opponent can actually close out the
game because like you said, the way and
the way that cards that Allen is
playing, Athenian Rain not taking the
second point instead going to seven to
be in a scarier position while also
holding both battlefields. It does tell
a lot.
Yeah, I mean I can believe Allan was
more interested in holding something
like a Darius because that is a powerful
play from your hand in the turn where
you're trying to go for seven
wa uh thousand tail watcher just trading
for a cathon rain though often you can
get another unit or something out of
that rain and kind of just accepting the
middle bar. So definitely is telling uh
that Kai'Sa getting removed by the void
seeker really bad for KGO now definitely
has to use real removal on watchful
sentries and uh it looks like does not
have any of those
>> that play that play alone enough to give
the game to Allen's EQ as we are moving
on to game three and the battlefields
are going to be even more interesting as
we already know we Allen plays this
candled at Sanctum so another one coming
in here and like you said now it is
KGO's turn to bring out his arena's
greatest going first.
>> Yeah, just a little swap their positions
as move around the board and both
players uh starting off with a card that
I think was kind of the star of the last
game, Pouty Porro, again really
impacting KGA's runes last game. I'm
very curious to see if this is the type
of game where Allen feels forced into
hexte rang in a similar way just because
KGO is now going first with that arena's
greatest
>> and I think Allan learned based off the
results of that last game. Maybe that's
not the decision that we do right off
the get-go in the beginning. But that
means an early candlelet sanctum use
here from KGO could go a long way for
even more advantage.
>> Yeah, we're seeing a couple just normal
units off the top there. This powdery
poro and this Noxis hopeful. If KGO has
the option to play Kaisen next turn plus
Noxus hopeful, that's a pretty good
turn. Two four might units not removed
by Falling Star easy. But if there's
other two cost plays that it could play,
maybe not interested in taking these and
looking for some more impactful cards. a
decision whether this game is about me
playing to the board or me wanting the
most powerful and the most card
advantage possible.
>> I love that idea being able to set up
that Knox hopeful Kai'Sa survivor turn.
But current Potra is keeping both of
them. It means that we do value having
that pouty porro as well at some point
in the next two turns.
>> Possibly KGO has some way to draw a
Shakard play both of them. I'm not
entirely sure. uh maybe is planning to
do something like uh stupify given the
opportunity in this turn just you know
stupify my poro draw them both so I can
play like three twos in the next turn uh
that would be really impactful on the
board really quickly depends of course
on what Allen is going to do here. Yeah,
but we had another situation where Kio
didn't actually play anything with his
runes going on that turn two and all
does is play Kai'Sa survivor
unacelerated. No chain at all is
created. So, and then he passes once
again. Although you give the whole point
for the Pouty Porro over again, one
whole turn where we didn't do anything.
>> Yeah, but this one's a little bit
different. Allen also didn't get
something out of it. He was concerned
about a potential removal spell. Did not
move in with this pouty porro. didn't go
in and offer the trade or go in into the
arena's greatest to try and score a
point. Some of that could be fear of
retribution in a accelerate unit like
that Kaiso survivor. But some of it
could also just be I really do want to
make you waste those runes. That could
be a situation where actually at the end
of the day both players are pretty happy
about how it went and one of them may be
wrong about the situation.
>> We'll clear the books. We'll handshake
across the table. We'll be like I I'm
okay with that as long as you're okay
with it. And then there is a stupify. So
you had the correct read on the idea of
just like that could have been something
we had to just get value out of our
runes but that opportunity wasn't
presented to us for KGO and you know
even the way that we looked in how we
looked at our deck for the candle
sanctum it looks like the Noxis hopeful
will get played but not alongside that
Kaiser survivor yet really holding on to
it in this game.
>> Yeah seeing that stupify on the Kaiser
here I am curious if we're going to see
a falling star trying to remove both of
Allen's units. Maybe not. Maybe it was
just spending the stify to get the
legion going on the hopeful here so they
can hold up once again those three runes
threaten that void seeker. But if you do
have the falling star here and remove
both of those things in the base puts a
lot of pressure on Allen to have a
pretty quick return to the field.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> I'm excited to see if he has it. I mean
I I think I think that play and line
sounds incredibly strong but really
wondering where to put this hopeful even
going to support this uh scandal. you
you I've seen that hand motion before.
You play your card and you just kind of
shake it around like I I don't know what
I'm doing. I guess here's good enough.
Uh you know, sometimes that's just what
it is. The Kaiso deck, you could have so
many things to play around. Uh putting
six might into the candle sanctum. A
pretty good number for a Darius to fight
into. I imagine Kio was considering what
he would do in retribution of a Darius
coming down. Uh, only three runes up,
potentially some retreats, maybe a void
seeker to make a trade. But I imagine
Darius looking really tempting to Allen
here if he has access to one, especially
plus a cleave or stupify.
>> If the I'll use the word bait. If the
bait is that KGO wants Allen to do the
Darius play, if it's a cleave, I think
it's pretty scary unless we take the
trade. But I think right off the bat,
we're going to see obviously the Darius
will come in, but with it's only going
to be seven might, which then means the
three leftover runes that KGO has really
has an opportunity here for him to
support this.
>> Yeah, I mean the the Kaiso deck is not
that good at protecting its units
outside of retreat. Anything that would
make this combat not just end up with
Allen taking the board is something like
a void seeker. You have to remove it and
still trade off all your units. And I'm
not sure Kio is super happy about this
situation. is thinking pretty hard. I
would like to believe during the last
turn while playing this Nox is hopeful
this was a situation that was definitely
going through their head and you would
kind of have a plan here. Allen is all
exhausted. All the runes are gone. No
energy available. So KGO gets full
knowledge of how this turn in combat are
going to play out and seems like it's a
pretty difficult decision.
Are you a big um while our players
decide uh are you a big posture reader
of like I I asked you this earlier I
think but when I look at the way that
Allen's EQ is sitting and they're kind
of laughing a little bit at each other
while KGO is in the the tank right now
um and like you said the handwaving of
the card you know Allen looks as cool as
a cucumber.
>> Yeah. And all your runes are exhausted.
What can I do? I I don't know what you
could have with this Darius. I think you
got Void Seeker. That's fine. Uh, it's
all in your hands now, KGO. You show me
what's up. And sometimes this just what
you got to do. If you're sitting there
stressing while your opponent's tanking
about a tough decision, it kind of just
can get in your own head. So, the best
thing you can do is just be like, "All
right, I will see what happens and then
I will start thinking again." Looks like
it's just again like you said going to
be that direct damage coming through
with the hex tech ray where although we
lose both of the units here for KGO. Uh
we are at least going to get that Darius
off of the board. But this presents a
prime opportunity for Allen's EQ to come
in and match up the score and a bonus
draw from the Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah, that hack tech ray leaving up two
energy. But that's not enough to play a
void seeker and threaten the Kai'Sa.
Potentially could have had another ray
and a stupify but doesn't. Allen's got
to be feeling really good after that
turn. a board that seemed pretty
favorable for KGO turned around really
really quickly and again KGO wasted a
little bit of energy and got three for
one by that Darius.
>> Yeah, three for one. I don't want to
hear that when I'm playing games.
>> Interesting note here. Kio only has one
mind rune. Even if there is a thousand
tail watcher wanting to be played, it is
not actually an option on this table.
>> Yeah, Darius though is a good rebuttal
at least when you just got rid of your
opponent's Darius. And then the pouty
porro followup here that remember we
ended up keeping on top of our deck that
we saw earlier to draw at this kind of
particular moment means this Darius is
going to have the seven might to
hopefully contest against the survivor
and of course Allan's EQ is completely
tapped out. So a trade out for that unit
getting over and KGO will go back up in
four points for the score lead.
>> Yeah, keeping the pouty porro with the
intention of oh I need something cheap
to play with this Darius I've been
holding totally makes sense something
that is worth having. Now this pouty
porro gets to pressure the candle. Let
Sanctum potentially trade in with the
porro there. Allen uh really wanting to
score and get rid of this Darius, but it
is less crucial for him this turn at
four points. If you're able to take the
arena's greatest, you're only going up
to five. That odd number less
threatening than an even number. Uh so I
could see a turn here where if we can't
remove the Darius, it's very possible we
just back our stuff up, play some stuff
to the board, and really set up for a
big future play. Uh especially if the
idea is, you know, maybe we're able to
take both battlefields, go to six, and
set up a time war.
more mine runes at least of the uh the
use for Allen here. But a void seeker
coming in first
targeting dealing the four damage to the
Darius which means this watchful sentry
looks really good into it at least for
trading with it and then getting also
the bonus draw from the sentry and there
is it's going to have to go through not
having something like a retreat at all
this game it looks like for KGO to
support and keep those kind of units
alive. Yeah, and as I was saying about
the points, Allen's at four, not doesn't
really need to go to five. Is actually
pretty happy on this board just to clear
the Darius, even if it means he didn't
take the arena's greatest. Yeah,
>> just, you know, finalizing more units,
getting them in position for later for a
potential, you know, hold here or if the
contest doesn't come through for the
pouty porro of just like Allen really
being in that position where he just is
allowed to have a whole another turn
here of setup as long as he scores one
or two more points than things like that
time warp play on the table like you
said. But being able to set up here and
then also set up on the next turn, I
think is a prime position to be in when
it feels like KGO is constantly trying
to play catchup.
>> Allen chose to leave this pouty porro in
the candleit sanctum, possibly thinking
like, hey, if you want to move your
pouty poro in and we trade, that's fine.
But it's one of those things that is now
allowing Kio to potentially use an
accelerate unit as a removal spell.
Normally if one of the things you do in
matchups like this is keep your stuff
safe in the base because Kai'Sa is so
good at conquering and removing units at
the battlefield with their accelerate
units like Darius Thousand Tail Watcher
Kai'Sa and a lot of times you can
disallow them that opportunity. Allan
saying, "Okay, if you want to accelerate
into my pouty porro, maybe I have
retreat, maybe I have a stupify,
whatever. I think I'm happy with you
playing units." And it looks like Kio's
maybe going to go for that line here by
playing this Kai'Sa.
>> Finally coming in from the champion unit
zone as you said, going to go for the
conquered draw.
>> Taking the other battlefield says the
pouty porro. No, you can leave that. Um,
potentially afraid of the hex tech ray
coming out of Allen really needs this
card off. Kai'Sa maybe and doesn't want
this trade to occur.
But that poro trade coming in here now
for KGO. You pointed out earlier and
actually going to try and take it over
with a cleave play on top of it.
>> If Allen does have that Hexte Ray could
offer the trade by Hexte Raying the
other Pyro. However, that would cost two
runes cuz the Kai'Sa is already
exhausted and the deflect.
>> Getting the six points this turn though
for KGO. I'm all of a sudden kind of
rooting for them a little bit more. But
the Kendall Sanctum going to take a look
at the cards and they are the breath.
the breath coming out of KGO really
going like okay well these are Raven
Bloom plus Void Seeker maybe not what
we're looking for necessarily right now
in this point in the game Void Seeker
potentially pretty good on a big turn if
you need to just remove the units at the
battlefields and then move in however
Raven Bloom Student keeping that's kind
of an idea of like oh I think the game
is going to go a while I need to be able
just to play nonacelerated units into my
base getting rid of both of them saying
this is just not what the game's about
anymore
Big turn here coming up for Allen to see
how he solidifies his place in this game
as it is game three. Both of these
players make it or break it here in top
16. Player goes home. One of them moves
on.
>> Yeah, Allen does have enough rooms to do
something like the time warp, but is
unable to take both battlefields without
playing more spells. Can only play the
time warp if that's the route. So no
just victory on the table here, but a
thousand tailed Watcher always good at
clearing these battlefields. One of the
most important cards in a matchup like
this one.
>> Going to be accelerated here, which
unless that means a double mind channel
next turn means, you know, things like
the time warp are off the table. But
here it is very easily trading into this
Kai'Sa knocked down to one might because
of the thousand tailed Watcher. And it
even means the pouty porro is going to
be easy to trade into as well. Yeah, Kio
here could have a combination of hexte
ray and smokec screen to remove the
thousand tail watcher. But even if that
is true, there are two more units at the
base ready to come in and fight both the
Kai'Sa and the Pouty Porro.
>> Yeah, going to take that Allen going up
then to five points. And now this Powyp
Porro versus other Powyp Porro, but one
of them's got a little bit more might.
>> Kio having to make a big decision here
on do I do something here? If it's a
removal spell or a stupify, I'm gonna
have to pay deflect, go down on runes.
Currently on eight runes themselves,
which is kind of what you need to play a
thousand tailed watcher plus something
else or something like that time warp
and a situation where every single rune
matters as you are trying to get over
this finish line to get to those eight
points and Allen's about to threaten a
win by having both of these
battlefields. Luckily, we do still have
the daughter of the void legend ability.
Um,
which will help even with the deflect
cost as long as it is one of those kind
of tricks that's not just a retreat for
your own pouty porro because that
wouldn't stop Allen from taking the
point,
>> right? A stupify here would work that
doesn't have a natural power cost, but
smokec screen, void seeker, hex tech,
all of those do and will cost that extra
rune even through the daughter of the
void. Looks like it's going to be a void
seeker, which is going to help at least
give another extra card draw for KGO.
>> Yeah, this doesn't actually stop Allen
from taking the Candle Lit Sanctum. This
Raven Bloom student gets to go in
immediately. To me, if I'm Allen, I'm
thinking, okay, Kio is saying that they
need to draw cards. They need something
else that's not in their hand. So,
they're forced to play this Void Seeker
cuz that pouty porro being there maybe
not that relevant to the game overall.
This is one of those situations when
your opponent's playing candle at
Sanctum. The game's really close. Yeah.
>> And they're tanking and there's two
>> and if they ever end up saying, "Yeah,
I'll keep both on top." You're just
like, "Oh no, what is happening?" Uh,
but Allan putting some real thought into
this one. It a really tough position.
It's what do I think is going to matter
next turn?
>> If I'm going to get a next turn.
>> Yeah,
>> very likely on this board. hard to break
through both the thousand tail watcher
and the Raven Bloom student for Kai'Sa
with nine runes. But
is this a game that's going to continue
past this next turn cycle? I would say
it's pretty unlikely and Allen is trying
to figure that out himself.
>> I I'm over here while we're thinking
about the candle lid obviously as we
pass back. I'm trying to think like what
does KGO do here? And aside from using
some like mass removal, Athenian rain
type ability, but again, that doesn't
resolidify your pace back onto the
board, which then means it's a prime
opportunity for Allen to just do like
accelerated units, you know, finding a
way back into the game or just starting
to play more units.
>> Yeah, this is a situation some Kaisoist
will play cards like Legion Rear Guard
cuz they're very cheap units that
accelerate and can steal points. Kio has
the Athenian rain clearing the board. Um
Allan not having something like Legion
Rear Guard in his deck means he can't
really just take both battlefields from
a hand with only 10 runes that requires
two Darius pretty unlikely is possible
though. Uh but most of the Accelerate
units are pretty expensive and pretty
clunky.
>> Yeah, I was counting you know how many
runes do we have? Is double Darius on
the table? Like is that a real thing
that we could do? Even then the seven
might would have traded with the
watcher. So it's so hard. At least
getting a Raven Bloom student down for
KGO though means that like he's first to
start putting units back onto the board.
But for Allen, as we're just kind of
exchanging this uh playing units now, at
least this one draws a card for a new
option.
>> Yeah. So Allen here not able to take the
battlefields. Yeah.
>> Not going to be able to really hold
them. Is going to have to threaten a lot
of spell action. KGO has a Raven Bloom
that's going to get to go into one. If
you assume there's a second Accelerate
that's threatening the win. And even if
Allen doesn't have anything, has to
pretend that he does.
>> Yeah. I mean, and it's why we see cards
even like this falling star being played
just for a single removal because you
just cannot allow your opponent to have
those units still to then threaten the
double conquer for the win because it's
just not one of these things that these
decks do. It's all about setup and then
going for it. Double conquer plays are
pretty difficult for these decks that
don't have units out.
I think in Kio's hand, I saw a flash of
a time warp. Not the type of card you
actually want at this stage. There was a
situation potentially earlier. We could
have set it up, but never was able to
get to those 10 runes and really
maximize its potential. And it looks
like it's going to be true in this game
as well. Already at six points, maybe
only needs one conquer and a hold if is
able to get a unit in play and then get
to their next turn. But Allen also is
threatening that win. So having a card
like Time Warp in your hand that takes
time and takes resources when it could
be something else, another piece of
interaction, another cheap unit you
could get into a battlefield. Uh, it's
really showing the pain of having that
card here.
>> This being the second card for this
turn, but I guess not valuing. Or is it
the third card? Did I miscount?
>> It was the third card after the falling
star,
>> right?
>> Allan not wanting to go in realizes
going to seven not really mattering. It
makes your Darius better. But what Allan
did do, exhaust out. No runes available.
If you have some way to win, great. I
don't think you do. That seems really
unlikely from nine runes.
>> We're just playing a bunch of cards that
draw cards. But currently Allen has game
on board. If these battlefields are
contested, holding three up is enough to
stop one of these conquers, but I think
it comes down to one sort of accelerated
unit of any capacity here on Allen's
side.
>> Yeah, not a lot needed for Allen to win
here. It matters. Is there an answer to
this lecturing? Does KGO have a void
seeker or a hex tech? There is one. If
there wasn't, the game would end right
there because nothing's removing this
Darius, which is these mana runes. And
but Allan, you know, a full grip of
cards, tons of possibilities, and even
if doesn't succeed this turn, probably
pretty good at setting up for the
future.
>> There it is. An accelerated watcher
probably coming in here with only two
runes up for KGO. I can only imagine
>> that that's got to be game. I don't
think there's anything Kio can do with
just two energy into a seven and a five
might unit. Uh this is well played from
Allen coming back from a game where on
the draw against the arena's greatest
KGO getting that early lead, but Allen
finding the way to come back here. And
there is the handshake.
>> There it is. The best of three series,
the Kaisamir almost all the way down for
the time for both of them. But Allen's
EQ going to be moving on for top eight
on Kaiso.
>> Yeah, I mean you can see it there on the
table. Players revealing their hands.
There is a retreat, the third lecturing,
and a time warp. A lot of those cards
really good in the early game, the
lecturing goal or the retreat. Things
you want when you're trying to score
points and and bounce back and forth and
play this trading game. Not good when
you get to that in-game situation where
you're just like, I need accelerate
units. I need to remove your units from
the board. The only thing that matters
is both of us threatening this every
single turn until one of us blinks. And
Kio has the time warp, never has enough
energy to play it, putting him in
position with a card that kind of
doesn't do anything. Allan getting to
play all those tools, play all those
resources and in the game.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I It's so vastly
different to me. I I know you weren't
here earlier, but being able to watch
George G navigate the mirror in a
similar fashion, very calculated. It
some of the highest level of gameplay
that I think we can ask for right now in
Riftbound. And there's only so much more
to come in the future. Even in this own
tournament, I'm sure we're going to see
more levels of that same gameplay. But
Allen's EQ really showing his expertise
and his uh vetery in card games and
strategy games.
>> Yeah, there was a lot of points in these
games and we we've seen this a lot with
Allen where you know I am behind. How do
I get ahead or how do I close the door
before you catch up? He's done a really
great job of capitalizing on those
situations in the first game which he
did lose. He made a really good play
that got a huge tempo swing of answering
a Kai'Sa plus a cleave with only a hex
ray and a stupify. a really great combat
for him that both put him up cards and
energy value in just the amount of cards
he got to play and then capitalizing
again in game three where he's behind on
points going second and is able to
regain that tempo through making very
similar style of play.
>> I am so conflicted here Aaron. I don't
know if time warp is good. I don't know
if time warp is bad. I saw it I saw
double time warps today from George G. I
saw time orbs being stuck in hand, not
really getting us there, but it's a
question that will be answered, I think,
throughout this tournament and hopefully
at the end of the day. Uh, we've got a
couple of pieces of content we're going
to be shoving over so we can catch up
before we lead into our next feature
match.
>> All right, I'm here with Shawn Dollywal,
the tallest Riftbound competitor I could
find in the room. He's just made it to
the top 16, though. Sean, please uh you
know, tell me a little bit about your
run, how it's been going, and maybe some
of your preparation.
>> Um, so I prepared with Tar. Um, and like
he he basically, you know, he's such
such a good card game player. Um, he
explained to me that, you know what,
like, uh, he's been playing Kai'Sa a bit
and then he started playing Annie and he
thinks Annie's the best deck and like
after testing a bit, I also believe
Annie's the best deck. So, uh, what I
did was like I just went to like two
Nexus nights and like just played a bit
of Kai'Sa. It was like best of one,
learned the game, and then uh we did
some like, you know, eight hours of
testing on the Sunday. Uh and after
that, I felt like really prepared. I
played against all like the top
decksish. Um and then, you know, a
little bit more here and there, like,
you know, through the flights on
Thursday. Friday was really important.
Like the skirmish went 5-1, and I
learned so much. And then, uh yeah,
yesterday, you know, the run's been
good. I lost one game yesterday, uh due
to a misplay. Uh I I lost a couple games
here and there due to like not knowing
how cards work. Um, but other than that,
like, you know, I was able to still
two-1 a lot of people. Uh, and then
today it's been going great. Like, you
know, I've won both die rolls. I I've
drawn well. I haven't missed my two
drop. Uh, you know, I've needed I got
the cards when I need them. So, like,
you know, a bit of luck and like, uh,
you know, trying to play tight and and
it's been fun. It's a good game. So,
>> well, you're no stranger to to success
in TCGs, but moving on, you know, top
16. How are you feeling about your
chances going forward?
>> Um, I'm feeling good. I think I I think
I have one of the best decks in the
room. Like I think Tark came to like a
really good list. I feel great into
every matchup basically. I'm sure there
are some bad ones, but like you know I
feel good in every matchup. I feel like
I can win. Um hoping to win the die roll
and you know really hope to top eight
and go from there. So just praying you
know. Yeah.
>> All right. Congrats on the run so far
Sean and hopefully we'll see you
continue to move forward in the
tournament. We'll send it back to the
desk.
>> All right. And I'm here with Cody
Williams, winner of the best of Victor
here at the Houston Regional Qualifier.
Cody, tell me why Victor and then, you
know, you can tell me a little bit about
the run.
>> Yeah, so I played Victor cuz honestly, I
think it's a really good deck. Probably
one of the best decks in the game. I
mean, I beat five Kais. I lost to zero
Kaiis. I think the Kaisa matchup is
actually good if you know what you're
doing as Victor. So, I I brought it to
try and win.
>> I like playing the deck. I make one
ones. One ones are sweet. Uh, but I also
could win this and I won this and I knew
everyone was everyone's craping on
Victor. Like it's not good. It's not
good. It's a meme deck and I'm like,
"Dude, this deck's sick. You guys just
don't know yet." So, I'm excited for
when people like get to see the list.
Maybe get to try it for themselves and
actually maybe we shake up the meta a
little bit with uh the actual Victor.
>> Look, I think that is big. I mean, tell
me you you ended up beating all the
Kaises you ran into. What were the match
ups that ended up giving you trouble and
knocking you out in the end?
>> Well, Annie is tough uh just cuz you
have no agency. Annie is tough for
everyone. So, I lost to Annie. I beat an
Annie. And then in my top 64, I played
against mid-range G. Mid-range G is
pretty hard if they know what they're
doing cuz they have a lot of counters.
So, uh, and you know, I'm a little
inexperienced at matches that aren't
Kai'Sa. So, so he definitely like just
kind of steamrololled me there. But, uh,
other than that, I can be pretty happy
with the rest of the meta. Like Aurora
is like so so easy to play against.
>> All right. Well, you're saying that some
people are not knowers about the Victor,
but for any Victor fans at home, is
there anything you can enlighten for
them as to why you think Victor is so
good? some of the cards that maybe made
the difference this weekend.
>> Singularity
Rex.
>> Okay,
>> watch her. And then here's the spice.
I'm going to give you the spice ahead of
time. Um, but it's Call for Glory. You
run the card in your deck. It's a three
pump. You get to play around all the
tricks and you get to attack Super
Greedy. And if they have a trick, you
have a trick. And if they don't have a
trick, you get to attack Super Greedy.
>> All right, that sounds good to me. Well,
congratulations on your finish and
hopefully we'll see you at, I don't
know, Bolognia, Vegas in the future.
>> For sure.
>> All right. Well, back to the desk. We'll
have more ripout action here at the
Houston Regional Qualifier.
All right, I'm here with CBN, freshly
minted top 16 competitor, taking all the
way here with Annie.
>> How has the run been going?
>> Uh, it's been feeling great. So, we've
had one loss so far and an ID in the
last round of Swiss yesterday. Um,
obviously 20 today, so we made it to top
16. Deck's been feeling great. I
actually decided to switch my strategy
of how I sideboard mid tournament
yesterday, and so that was a first
experience for me as I've played a lot
of card games competitively. That that
was the first time I've ever done that,
but it worked out really well. So, we're
just we're just happy to be here.
>> All right. Well, I mean, it's paying off
and looking forward into the top 16. How
are you feeling about your chances?
>> Uh, I feel pretty good. Um, the the
newfound strategy that I've had uh has
been working pretty well. Uh, you know,
the there's a lot of like Aurora MFS out
there and stuff. So, um, feels like some
favorable matchups out there. Uh, not
not too scared of many decks. Just uh
hoping to dodge some mirrors. Somehow I
have not played any mirrors in my whole
run, which is crazy. But uh yeah.
>> All right. Well, I know you make some
ripbound content. Why don't you go ahead
and let the people know where they can
find you?
>> Yeah, you can find our content on
YouTube. It is true champion Gaming.
We're actually going to have a deck
profile of this list that I'm running at
the event on our channel next week. So
definitely go give it a a like and
follow.
>> All right, that's huge. We'll see if
Caven can continue advancing through
this run as we head back to the action.
>> Welcome back, Rift Bounders. I'm joined
once again with Aaron and I'm Barrett.
So we're here for the second feature
match that we have in our top 16 as
promised of course and we want to give a
little bit of insight for the viewers
because uh we've watched a lot of
gameplay. As we get closer and closer to
the edge of this tournament, we are
going to see some people that we have
already seen, of course. And this we
have the Master Yi mirror match. So, we
just talked about Kai'Sa, other big
heavy hitter in the room, right? Master
Yi, but Master Yi is one of these like
especially
interesting decks because people are
playing two different distinct builds of
it.
>> That's true. Yeah, there are a couple
different E builds people can be
playing. There are some that are playing
a normal kind of mid-range game, some
cheap units, things like first mate,
dead bloom predator, white flame
protector, reasonable game plan backed
up by pump spells and tricks and counter
spells like defy. Um, and then there are
builds playing dazzling aurora, not
playing any of those cheap things, just
leaning in dead bloom predator, giant
monsters, playing more of the early ramp
cards, catalyst of Aons, and just trying
to outsize the opponent. Both of them
outsized decks. One of them even more of
an outsized deck. More of those bigger
monsters. Uh Ye being a legend that's
pretty open-ended and gives you some
strong flexibility in how you want to go
about your game plan.
>> That's a great assessment. I'm going to
make you pick a favorite though, so you
can't run away from that question. But
that means we've got some gameplay we're
going to be jumping into though for a
Master Yi matchup. We've got Clyde who
we saw who is sporting that dazzling
arena. And I'm excited to see what uh
ESR is going to be playing for us on his
version for Master Yi. But I must make
you answer Aaron, if you had to pick one
of those two variants, if ESRs is this
kind of mid-range version, do you think
there's a favorite?
>> Yeah, I would really have to lean in the
dazzling Aurora build. A lot of times in
games like this, the important thing is
being just one step larger than your
opponent. If you're too slow compared to
them, you're gonna get run over. They're
gonna take Battlefield. It's gonna score
points. You're gonna lose. If you're
just a little bit bigger and you both
score points at roughly the same pace,
your deck being larger and getting that
little bit more value should be able
enough to lock them out.
>> Absolutely. As we see the double viomos
layer coming in here for both of these
players. I think that's a pretty safe
bet. You know, again, we're at open deck
list at least for both of these players.
But we've immediately now been our
answers are given ESR playing that kind
of mid-range version versus Clyde who we
saw earlier today on this dazzling
Aurora variant. And it was a very close
game. went all the way to game three
versus a Misfortune uh playing Dazzling
Aurora as well and just being to barely
able survive it out because cards like
this Zonia's Hourglass being able to
reby one of these giant units that
you're playing off the top. Yeah, not
the start Clyde is especially excited
about much happier to have something
like a find your center. Get that rune,
draw that card, kind of race as quickly
as possible to those big monsters where
ESR doing definitely what they want to
do. starting with this small unit
getting to score some points has to get
ahead so that if something like a
dazzling Aurora does come down they have
the potential to close the game out
before Clyde takes over followed up by a
Kiana. So no two units here but you know
as long as we start getting units onto
the board to get these two points per
turn for ESR. That's the pace you're
kind of looking for when as you watch
the dazzling Aurora deck kind of set up
and ramp like with this catalyst of Aons
to get to the point that they want to be
at in the game. Well, catalyst of Aon
means you're not too sad to not have a
find your center. You're already at
seven runes. Next turn, you're going to
be at nine. The magic number for playing
that Aurora. And even if you don't have
something like an Aurora, you still have
access to dead bloom predators backed up
by this hourglass or the master from the
champion zone backed up by a couple pump
spells.
>> Absolutely. Catalyst of Aons of our own
though from ESR, which you do see a
couple of times being played in this
kind of mid-range version just to get
yourself to that point in the game where
you're allowed to play your own dead
bloom predators or white flame
protectors of from your hand.
Going for the draw here on the conquer
effect of the Kiana. Could have chose to
channel, but we played a we played a
catalyst, right? So, we already got our
two channels that we needed.
>> Yeah. Again, big number for the build.
Not playing Dows Aurora. Eight is the
most expensive card you're going to be
playing. Going to have nine next turn.
potentially able to play an eight drop
plus have another trick on guard, charm,
defy, something of that nature.
>> Big turn here. Does Clyde actually have
it as we go to the nine runes? Cuz if
not, you just kind of have to feel like
you have to play the units straight out
from your hand if they're stuck there.
Honed Ye coming in from the champion
zone though instead of a dazzling going
to contest against this clockwork
keeper.
>> Yeah, and if you had the dazzling Aurora
there, you're certainly going to be
slamming it. There's no way there are
any answers to that coming this game
with how early it is. But not having
that, having the ramp, having to play a
much more fair mid-range game of Clyde's
own, similar to what ESR is probably
about to do in return.
>> Yeah, pass back of course get the hold
with the Kiana. Obviously didn't attack
into it cuz you would have just been
trading, but you do have your own zonas
hourglass that would have been able to
bring your Yi back. But as we pass going
into it, I think this could be, you
know, an opportunity like you said where
we go that ramp earlier putting us to
that nine dead plume plus on guard would
be nice to do here against the E, but
you are still staring across two readyed
runes from Clyde. You brought up the
fact that the master E would have traded
with the Kiana if they go in and I think
that's a really important point for the
Master E mirror. Both players are much
better at defending and holding than
they are attacking. Normally the
attacker is so favored, especially in
matchups like Kaiso where there's so
many big accelerate units and thousand
tailed watchers. And here there's some
of that and there are combat tricks, but
if you're able to hold up your tricks,
that plus two from the legend just makes
combat super painful your for your
opponent. They have to risk so much
going in because the numbers just are
almost never going to be in their favor.
>> Find your center channel draw. Pit
rookie coming in going to give a buff to
this Kiana. Make it a little bit more
sticky onto the board. We even have one
of those exclusive riot buffs. I wish I
had some of those. Those look so
beautiful. Star War then coming down as
well.
>> Don't press your luck.
>> That's not what that was. But I do think
they are gorgeous and I'm excited to see
just pieces like that in general being
nice little fun giveaways for when you
know are interacting with, you know, the
developers of the game.
>> Quiet didn't have a really big play last
turn or wanted to use the Ei and hold up
some protection. I was curious if there
was another big one here, but it does
seem like there's this dead bloom
predator ready to pick a fight.
Obviously, still no dazzling Aurora. I
think that would have been the play
here, but you know, sometimes you don't
need the Aurora if you just draw enough
big monsters and have some good early
ramp.
>> Yeah, seven might to eight even with the
Ebuff. And it looks like we don't
necessarily have a trick or afraid that
if we use ours, it'll just be
reciprocated by Clyde. So, the Conquer
is going to go through.
>> Yeah, I think I was able to get a
glimpse of ESR's hand there. It looks
like things like find your center and
other units, not any protection spells,
a charm available, but Clyde has both
the battlefields and units are much
larger over there.
>> Wow. Even paying and getting a bonus
hidden card here for Clyde can only mean
that we've got probably double uh double
zonas hourglass. Maybe there's a pocket
that we could talk about, but I doubt so
in this Dazzling Aurora variant.
>> Yeah, this is a pretty face up hidden
card. The good thing about Hourglass
though is it is hidden. You can choose
when you're ready to try and protect
something. So, if you're valuing the
dead bloom predator more than the knee,
which it looks like we are because we
hit the hourglass there. So, you don't
have to flip it until that dead bloom
predator starts to get pressured.
Eight energy here using for a white
flame protector. It looks like it was
going on top of that pit rookie, giving
it the extra eight might for the turn,
which is going to allow again only
really for a trade on that dead uh dead
bloom. But we do have the option to
attack into the honed Yi instead. I
would imagine we're going to get that
honed attack here. Again, there's a
charm in ESR's hand, which means if
you're able to fight that Master Yi and
win the fight, you're then able to
either charm it again cuz it's going to
live from the hourglass or attempt to
charm the Dead Bloom out of that
battlefield. discipline coming through
going to draw us a card unless this gets
defied if there's one in the hand as I
can kind of see looks like that's not
going to be the case here but going to
10 and 10 means there's just the trade
it's basically as if you went into the
dead bloom but that would have been way
more of a disaster
>> yeah I mean this situation is a pretty
big disaster too ESR can take that
battlefield now but that unit's pretty
small not able to charm either of
Clyde's units here just in a situation
where things are pretty tough I think
there's maybe a first mate in the hand.
Doing that and moving in the white flame
protector and then doing a charm
possibly gives you the ability to remove
one of these units in play and start to
catch up and get these points in this
hold before Clyde's bigger in-game comes
online fully.
>> That seems like a great play to me and
it's one of the benefits when you are
playing this kind of mid-range version
is that you get cards like first mate
because you know you don't want to be
playing cards like that in the dazzling
variant. So, white flame's going to go
in. Still get that conquer up for ESR.
Going to five. And it looks like that
charm is coming through here to try and
get it off the battle. Get it off the
eight plus the 10. But discipline does
get the plus two. But of course, we have
the zony's hourglass that we are allowed
to activate. And it's just going to save
itself from there. Discipline wearing
off as the unit was then recalled.
>> Yeah, this is a turn where do get rid of
both hourglasses. Now, if things die,
we're at least ahead. But I think that
was a lot of ESR's kind of power there.
does have the white flame protector in a
battlefield. That's going to ask a
little bit of Clyde to get through with
that Wu Blademaster. But a white flame
for a white flame, trade for a trade.
This Yi is about to go to town.
Am I getting bamboozled? This is a
dazzling deck, right? I mean, I remember
him playing them last time he was on
here. But we are just raw playing all of
the units that we end up drawing for the
turn. And they're just as good as you
play them from the top of the deck, then
from your hand, of course. And another
hidden card here. I can a third Zonia's
hourglass off the get-go in game one.
>> Yeah, it's pretty massive these
hourglasses this game. I had mentioned
at the start Clyde maybe not super happy
about the turn one hourglass, but when
back to the catalyst of Aons and still
able to play the big monsters ahead of
time, it is worth a whole another big
monster. This hourglass is the same as
saying I'm going to spend one power to
get a whole eight might unit later.
I love it too when you know cards like
white flame protector not just give the
plus eight might when they come in but
it is still that eight might body for
later and now it's going to be a rough
situation for ESR because a play like
that was exact cuz it's different where
if it came off the dazzling the white
flame protector is almost even a miss
right cuz it doesn't actually really do
anything for you right away whereas when
you play them from hand that's where the
full value come from because you could
pick it and then swing with a unit yeah
this is why people like the master e
dazzling aurora variant compared to
something like misfortune The Misfortune
deck certainly more allin with its units
and its Aurora. You just don't have the
same level of power and ability to just
play kind of a normal game. Part of that
is having access to find your center
with calm gives you more good ramp and
things like ancient hourglass make you a
little bit more robust compared to
misfortune's really bursty powerful in
games and things like bullet time.
>> Does that find your center you talked
about earlier? We finally are going to
play it. Um, and it is only class one.
Uh, as we both players are three away
from the victory score. Um, and it's
going to draw us a card and channel. And
now we are going to tap out for eight.
It looks like a dead bloom. No, white or
tasty fable accelerated makes the same
math as well. And this at least allows
us to attack a little bit more
aggressively with multiple units. And
then you still have some, you know,
extra resources coming if the Tasty Fay
Folk doesn't make it through. Yeah, an
on guard here from Clyde could be a
pretty big blowout unless ESR has a
trick in response. Just a find your
center going to cycle that one. But the
question is, do I care about this master
Y? Clyde has another Z's hourglass
hidden almost certainly. So, is that
something I want to play here or do I
value say this Y is actually worth less
than these eight bite units?
Seems like we're probably going to end
up flipping it up as the master Y just
still counts as a very large body.
remember taking a lot of the trade here
means this Ye still has a lot of
punching power when going against that
first mate even though ESR gets to
conquer.
>> Yeah, Tasty Fay Folk does get to draw a
card here. ESR really needs cards.
Really running low on resources and
Clyde just having way more numbers in
play means the pressure is on ESR to
find those answers.
>> Going to even keep the Y back at home.
White Flame moving up going up to seven
for Clyde. And now all of a sudden ESR
is in dangerous territory. If there's
anything that's like Oh, wait. Stalwart
Porro. Now I'm so confused. He must be
siding dazzling Auroras and only playing
a couple of low energy units because we
definitely saw dazzling Aurora earlier
today. Yeah, that's an interesting play
pattern that I consider. If you're
playing in these Aurora mirrors, having
your own Aurora is really strong,
potentially boarding those in over these
small units really keeps your opponent
on the toes. If they don't think you're
Aurora in game one, they're probably not
going to board in answers to Aurora in
game two. It's completely changed my
mindset now that I've seen, you know, a
unit like the Star War Pearl come
through because this entire time, you
know, I'm anticipating this Dazzling
Aurora coming down. We knew that there's
going to be a lot of ramp, a lot of
these heavy costed units still coming
through and now it makes me excited for
what the future of this match will look
like and what Clyde decides to take each
of them. But feeling still kind of in
the driver's seat now that the Hone Ye
from ESR is going in and swings through.
That's still going to be game one going
over to Clyde as there's not really much
else for ESR in the tank. Yeah, ESR was
able to find a couple disciplines and
try and make a big play there and take
over that battlefield. But Primal
Strength is the pump spell, the beat all
pump spells, and that means Clyde gets
to hold all the battlefields. Into game
two we go. Of course, Clyde winning that
game one. We've got Grove of the God
Willow coming over from ESR. A tried a,
you know, tried favorite for a lot of
these Master Yi decks because it's very
good at holding points once you get onto
them, but it's going to be highly
contested versus the Obelisk of Power on
the side of Clyde. Turn one, find your
center getting countered by the defy.
One of those things that uh Clyde
obviously not super used to happening
was just going to draw the card.
Normally your finder center just
resolves, but it if you are in ESRC
seat, slowing down Clyde seems like a
prime directive for you. Your defies
maybe not always at their best later,
cash that in now. Really slow down.
You're going to get to score some points
and maybe get to hold that grove of the
godwillow and really get some card
advantage going.
>> Absolutely. So our judges will sort it
out. Of course, you know, they'll take
care of it and everything, but you know,
Obisa Power, when I see that one, it
makes me potentially think that we did
side in the dazzling Auroras, you know,
getting that extra advantage for trying
to make the game, you know, accelerate a
little bit quicker. But my question to
you is what is ESR going to do in combat
if we did side in those dazzling Auroras
and they might be coming because it is
open deck list. That is an option that
ESR is aware of happening.
>> Well, I think this is a type of play
that's really committing to that, right?
It is okay. I'm willing to lose a rune
to make sure you don't get the extra
rune. I am afraid of your late game. You
gave me this extra rune with the
obeliska power so I can play a unit and
have a defa. And that's something I
normally wouldn't get to do in this time
of the game, but I'm willing to give up
that obeliska power. I think I need to
get ahead and this is the way of saying
that. I will say in ESR's hand, looks
like a lot of catalyst of AON to get
some more ramp. Not a lot of payoffs or
action. So, a lot of pressure on topping
top decking. So, more units and things
to play here to get ahead.
>> Looks like our judge is coming back. So,
we're going to get that resolution for
what's going to resolve here, of course.
And just trying to map our way out for
the rest of this game for both of these
players. You know, I do like the defy
on, you know, the catalyst or the find
your center. You know, find your center
to me feels a little better. recognize
that draw. But when I do think about it,
stopping my opponent from channeling one
rune right now for me to have to pay the
power cost on this defy and recycling
one, it's kind of like a similar
exchange. You would think almost.
>> It is a little similar. I'm giving up a
card and a rune stopping you from
getting a card and a rune. There's a
possibility this Defy isn't that
relevant. Clyde has four runes from the
obelisk of power. He's going to get two
each turn. That means on turn three is
going to have eight runes, which is
enough to play all of the units that
aren't dazzling aurora. So, if Clyde
doesn't happen to have that Dazzling
Aurora, it's very reasonable that this
ninth rune isn't that relevant. Maybe
the Defy could have been used to win a
combat later, but how that plays out in
that prediction of Clyde's hand is
something ESR has to make and just
saying, I need to make sure you Aurora
one turn sooner if that's something in
your hand because if you do a quick one
of those, I will not be winning.
>> I love that.
cuz sometimes
when I'm the calm player, I feel like I
never know if I'm making the right
decision on, you know, actually using it
to counter those ramp spells. But seems
we got the resolution that's going to be
going on here from the judges is that
we're going to get a judge shuffle. You
know, we saw the card that was going to
be on top of our deck instead of, you
know, stopping the entire game and
everything. We're just going to be like,
well, you know, let's put it back. You
don't need that card. We know that it is
specifically that one card and we're
going to be shuffling up the deck and
resuming the play. That find your center
getting cancelled here and it looks like
we're going to move on
moving into the grove. First contention
and first point here for ESR and a
catalyst of their own to get an
accelerate into the runes which helps
pay off for the defy that we just paid
for earlier.
>> Yeah, taking this grove of the godwill
as I said before. pit rookie there.
Probably going to try and hold and draw
some cards. Clyde only at six runes. Not
really able to play any of the
accelerated units, even the master E at
the champ zone. Having to cycle a
discipline to find some more action to
do
>> the second one.
>> And again, just, you know, getting
through these loops, trying to find
cards that are things you can play on
the next turn. Going to have eight
runes. Always can play the Master Y, but
if you're at eight, you can't master Y
plus discipline, so you might as well
try and find a more powerful play for
the followup. Yeah, just a cycle drawing
kind of turned there for Clyde, which
means you're going to give the hold
away, which is the extra bonus draw for
ESR. Go to two points and now it's time
for ESR to really kind of solidify a
board state. Yeah, and that draw was
super important. Their hand in the
previous turn was a couple catalysts in
an Ong Guard. Not the most threatening
thing on this board. So really did need
to dig and find some action of what they
could be doing. Now plenty of runes.
They could use the Mastery E and go into
the second battlefield to put a ton of
pressure and start trying to conquer.
potentially quite good against the dead
bloom predator because of the Wuju Blade
Master Legend, meaning that is just a
trade. And we just saw Clyde have to
spend a bunch of their disciplines. So,
the odds of pump spells being able to
break something like a master y-hold
gets harder and harder.
Even bringing home the pit rookie
already got the point. Of course, take
it off. And you really are kind of
expecting something coming out from
Clyde here on this next turn. So, keep
it safe. Probably not going to get away
with that hold anyway. And then, of
course, the Hon going in on this the
Obliska power for the third point. Yeah,
you can see ESR there saying like, okay,
I could try and hold this grove of the
god Willow, but I know you have the
mastery E. I can go in and eat it. And I
think you will probably just go there
anyway cuz the odds of you breaking
through my mastery at the obelisk of
power are so low because I have the
legend bonus for this fight.
>> Absolute respect. I mean, you love it,
right? Cuz ASR kept one up after playing
Clyde's own mastery. It was going to
keep one up. So, if it's answering just
with on guard versus on guard, like
you're still going to lose that
exchange. Um, so it makes 100% sense.
>> Clyde once again hiding this ancient
hourglass. This is the way that going to
get back ahead again. Spending one power
for the equivalent of a six might
ganking unit.
When you are just both on this resource
game and casting these big things,
you're kind of both only getting to play
one a turn. Just one dead loom predator,
one mastery, and be able to break that
serve through ancient hourglass. really
special thing to have in your hand.
>> Yeah. And I mean, you look at the rune
discrepancy, right? Because, you know,
we stop at that. The charm coming in
here is going to be pretty massive
because it also means you have to
immediately react with that zony's
hourglass cuz you're going to lose
control of that battlefield, right? So,
flipping that over. Uh, but the rune
discrepancy I was trying to get at was,
you know, even with this one energy
charm, you know, we have so much more to
play with for ESR. Things like dead
bloom are on the table. White flame
protector are still on the table for
them. Whereas Clyde, we're constantly
having to pay these power costs. Yes,
the zoning hourglass is going to keep
our unit alive, but since it's being
forced out right here and now because of
a charm play, we're just going to lose
it immediately. And now you wish you
kind of had it later. But we don't have
a lot of runes to play with next turn.
Clyde has a defy in hand. There was a
deep thought there in his face of do I
want to counter this charm? I can either
let the hourglass save my E or I can
counter the charm with my defy, but
that's going to cost me a rune. Clyde at
six runes. If you do that defy, you go
down to five and are unable to play
white flame protector, dead bloom,
predator, any of those really big plays
you really want to be making the next
turn, feeling pressured to be like,
"Okay, your charm beats my hourglass.
That's fine. I have to save this defy
for later." Possibly there's going to be
a huge window in a big fight where you
get to counter something really
important. So, not a huge loss. You
can't do it here. But something to be
aware of if you're ESR is that tank from
Clyde thinking about what to do in that
situation. Maybe can sniff that Defy
out.
>> Love the ganking coming in here from the
Hon Yi. Moving over to that God willow
going to five points and then a
Clockwork Keeper. We did pay the
additional cost on it. Going to recycle
that calm room so we can draw a card.
Catalyst of Aons and a Hide of our own.
Going to put that hidden card to protect
our own Master Yi over for ESR. all all
of a sudden all these the the turntables
really have turned in this match because
ESR is going to be able to basically
match the tempo of what that zonas did
for Clyde but on their own foot while
also being up four points. Yeah, having
access to the uh grove of the godwill
here pretty big though. White flame
protector such a massive number that
there's not a lot of recourse from the
SR other than just okay, I'll save my E.
You get it this turn, we'll have a fight
next turn. But now having to get back
over that Wuju blademan legend ability.
So a little bit of a harder combat needs
another trick in hand to get through.
>> Passing it back. Clyde going up to two
points. Really prime opportunity here
for ESR to go to seven and threaten
holding potentially both battlefields
here that Clyde must answer and only
going to really have that white flame
protector assuming this E gets dealt
with
>> Predator. Dead Predator seems to be the
decision on the choice for the eight tra
that we're going to be playing. And then
immediately again with the focus gives
the ong guard when completely tapped out
by Clyde. You know there's not going to
be an answer. Great play to get this
double conquer here and threaten the
hold.
>> Yeah, in these matchups having access
and open uh energy to be able to have
things like on guard and discipline.
Really powerful. So when you don't have
them, ESR gets to make that play with a
ton of confidence knowing going to get
to eat that master just trading it for
an ong guard. A great deal on that side
of the table.
>> Absolutely. I think I spotted a charm in
Clyde's hand, which makes me think that
the only real play here is to move this
white flame up against the clockwork
keeper and then move that dead bloom
predator to fight your white flame being
up in the combat, but it's going to cost
a bit of power because it does have
deflect and for this charm to target it.
>> Yeah, Clyde does have a lot of cards in
hand. Looks like six lot of options
available, but you definitely need to
get ahead on this board, not allow a
hold and not allow ESR to win that game
through that way in the future.
Hopefully you have more big monsters be
able to pressure the other side and
never let this sevenpoint hold happen.
>> No on guard here from ESR. That would
have helped out
>> to at least get the trade. Catalyst
coming through to help replenish some of
these rooms. But Clyde being able to at
least get a hold here means that the
double conquer is going to be a little
more difficult for ESR, but one white
flame protector could do it.
>> One white flame for another is what
happened in game one. I can see the same
thing happening here. And again, Clyde
without much retribution. The only real
thing you can do in those spots is
something like a primal strength, but
only three runes up. Not able to play a
card like that.
>> It's crazy how thin that margin is, too,
because we floated an energy last turn
because we had to pay the deflect cost.
You might as well get the extra. And we
would have had it had we not had to go
around that deflect cost. And here is
the white flame going in. And that is
game two going to be going over to ESR.
But we've got ourselves a match.
>> One white flame for another. A trade for
a trade. That is how these master Y
matchups go. You need the big things to
break through the Y battle Y legend. And
sometimes you just got to be the last
one to do it.
>> A trade as old as time even. We have a
Spears climb though coming out here for
Clyde and then Obiska Power for ESR on
the other side of the table. So
accelerated, but we're playing nine.
Yeah, I will say that Clyde was able to
capitalize the obelisk of power well on
the play. Some decks maybe not the best
at that. But getting able to play a find
your center on the start. Really strong
thing to do when you are already playing
a long game and you have that advantage
through these warm up uh through these
dazzling res. Yeah, and four to play
with here on the side for ESR. We know
cards like Kiana exist in this list. We
saw it earlier in game one. So, you
know, can definitely think about playing
that on turn one going second. Feels
pretty good, but we the name of the name
is we need units. And I'm seeing some
pretty expensive ones here on the side
of ESR. That's not going to help us get
points early on if our opponent is just
playing some of these ramp spells.
>> No, these two white flame protectors
definitely a long game plan. Choosing to
fire off a sabotage early. That's a type
of play compared to playing that Hiana
maybe saying something like I really
don't want you to have ramp, but there
is not ramp in that hand. That is a uh
very uh pump spell forward. I would say
>> these are the craziest triple discipline
primal strength for what I believe to be
two hands for players that are going to
play almost no units in these next two
turns.
>> I mean I believe ESR does have a porro
here going to get a porro in play.
Probably Kon next turn. Probably
thrilled to see this hand. It's like
what are you going to be doing with your
time? Um do you It's a situation of like
do I care about the third discipline?
That's probably the quotes strongest
card of these. Primal strength though
fills a very specific role. But when you
Clyde doesn't have units and is going to
take a while to be able to play them,
primal strength's really hard to leave
up. It just costs so much energy. It's
much better when you're already a little
ahead and you stop your opponent from
breaking. But it is a very unique
effect. So taking it here from the
sabotage saying, "Okay, I know you have
as many two cost plus twos as you want.
I'm going to play around that."
>> I mean, it's basically white flame on a
spell, right? I mean, it costs half as
much essentially at action speed, but
for one less, and you don't get the body
with it. like it makes a lot of sense,
but it's such a unique trick that you
can play in a deck like this. And you
know, because it costs four, you do have
to show it very pretty handedly. But
showing four is no different than
showing up two disciplines.
>> One discipline, two discipline. We'll
see if we get a third discipline out of
Clyde. Just recycling, trying to find a
play for next turn. Really needs
something big.
>> Mmobize instead seems to be the draw
that we got off of that one. So, you
know, just proceeding to get a little
bit more of our runes into play. And it
looks like that first point is obviously
going to be going over to ESR and
hopefully a little bit more presence on
the board or it might just be some more
ramp of our own with a find your center.
>> Find your center. Good. Gets you to that
number. That means next turn you can
play a white flame protector and put a
big body into play. Pretty important. In
addition to that, now you can do
something like a mastery and hold up
something like that defy in hand,
potentially countering a discipline or a
big effect from Clyde,
>> man. and we're gonna play to nine. This
is gonna be a crazy game.
>> Yeah, this is definitely a bit of a slo
for both players. Some not a blistering
start out the gate. Not exactly a slow
one from ESR, but definitely a slower
one from Clyde in some ways. But Clyde
does have that long game potential. This
is the type of battle where the bigger
monsters deck if given enough time can
overcome. However, Clyde needs to find
them and ESR we know has them in hand
already. So, one monster in hand worth
two in the deck.
I love that. No, I'm going to use that.
That's so good. Um I think even showing
restraint here by not moving the porro
up because we know if there's going to
be any sort of play from Clyde here if
it's just I need to play something if my
hand is not necessarily playing the best
cards at this current moment. Playing a
honi makes sense. If you played the
porro, you would have just lost it
immediately. So, we're just going to
hold it off for a little bit.
>> Yeah. And Clyde knows there's this porro
at base has to think about white flame
protector. ESR has a nice little not
bluff unintentionally almost well I
can't go in with this stalwart pu
because you'll probably just kill it
with your ye don't even get it's not
even showing that I'm keeping it so I
could fight with the white flame
protector so it doesn't give Clyde a lot
to read off of but does keep it where he
has to be thinking about that situation
going to be paying the power cost here
for a hidden zon's hourglass
and yeah I can only imagine that that
seems to be the play probably going in
here and it's going to be worth getting
the zonia's hourglass off of the table
But it does mean that Porro will just
end up dying, you know, essentially one
turn later in the same capacity.
>> Well, we do know that Clyde has one last
discipline in hand. So, this is only 10
going into an eight. So, that discipline
can cause a trade and kill that porro.
And the hourglass will of course save
the E. Choosing to keep that discipline
though. Just let the hourglass let the
porro live, saying, I don't think the
porro is worth my discipline. That's
fine. Whatever. It's a two might unit.
>> That's true. We all know that that
discipline's at hand still. as we pass
it back, of course, using everything
that ESR had access to. We're finally
getting onto the table, though. One
point for everybody. Now, we're playing
like a normal game again.
>> Yeah, that master E, no reason
discipline because you're going to get
to go in and eat it for free. You know,
ESR's uh has no runes available. And so,
situations the same either way. You get
to keep that discipline and keep that
trick available.
Finder center. Pretty standard here.
Hey, look, a second one. Uh, so we're
going to be channeling up all these
runes that Clyde's been paying at least
in some power costs and drawing some new
cards, which of course have just really
been these ramp spells, you know, and
remember more cards that ESR draws. The
finer centers were already unknowns that
he didn't know about. And now as we draw
and draw more cards, of course, it's
even more unknowns as now the discipline
coming in on your own master E and then
a charm to bring that white flame up
with no runes available to ESR. It's
just going to knock it off the table.
>> Yeah, this is massive. So now ESR had
more white flame protectors would have
been able to play one on the first one
to get through that E through pretty
much anything, but now has no units in
play at all. This white flame protector
going to need a little bit of support
before it can really take over a
battlefield. And ESR looks like still
has two of them. Found all of them. So
that being a thing that Clyde has turned
off really massive in this situation.
>> Find your center of our own
means that we're not going to be playing
a master yi at all this turn and instead
we just we need to find some units that
we can use to buff up. And I guess
double poro will get the job done. But
we just are going to find oursel in a
similar situation. If Clyde finds, you
know, any sort of like stabilization,
some more zonas hourglass, we're just
going to see a similar situation that we
saw earlier. Yeah, find your center
really showing its power in these games.
Both players ramping quite a bit,
especially Clyde side, but not running
out of things to do. Something like this
catalyst of hands had wait until the end
of the game where your runes are already
out before it can trips you. But in all
of the find your centers just get to
play, just keep to keep the card flow
going.
>> Absolutely. And then we have a tasty
fate folk coming in. We finally found
some units and we get to play them onto
battlefields we already have access to.
Which then means this Yi with ganking
gets to slide over and all of a sudden
the points are going away from ESR as
Clyde goes to four. Yeah, those white
flame protectors are good and they're
going to help break through these
battlefields. Clyde maybe not going to
be playing around the third copy as the
game goes on, but they are energy
intensive. Both players tons of runes in
play, tons of things they can do and
pretty full hands of things the
opponents have to be weary about.
>> Yeah, similar situation. The Ye is going
to get knocked off the table. Porro
going to be winning that battle. And now
I don't know exactly what units Clyde's
going to have access to as now that
champion unit is gone. Going for two
points for ESR. Passing back to Clyde
with the hold going to five.
>> Going back to this first turn of the
game when ESR sabotaged and took Oh,
that is
>> it's back. It's here. I didn't lie. I
promised. I didn't lie. That dazzling
aura really massive. Clyde already with
an advantage. That's definitely going to
give an even more of an advantage. What
I was going to say was how much ESR was
on top of it taking that primal
strength, a card that was going to win
this fair mid-range battle and stop a
white flame protector from breaking
through another white flame protector.
But it turns out that's just not what
the game's about anymore. Suddenly we
have the Aurora and the pressure is on
for ESR.
>> When I'm going to ask you a fun
question. When was the last time you saw
a Dazzling Aurora deck be up in points
before they played their Dazzling
Aurora?
>> You know, that's not super often,
especially that's something the
Misfortune deck in particular is really
weak at. They are not good at scoring
those points. But Clyde and Master E
much better at doing that. Just playing
that champion from the champ zone, able
to get in there, gank over being a six
might unit compared to something like
Misfortune's 5. A huge difference in
getting you those points.
Clyde here probably having or ESR having
to think about, you know, okay, I only
have so many more white flame
protectors. You're about to put a lot of
numbers in these battlefields over the
next couple turns. I have some tasty
faith folks. What are the things you can
hit off this dazzling aurora that give
me an opportunity to still win? What are
the odds you kept in that stalwart pora
from game one? H I would say pretty low,
but you can uh hope that that's the
case.
That is a that is a prayer for sure if
you're looking for something like that.
But I mean even hitting this white flame
protector like I said earlier when you
know theorizing when a dazzling aurora
was eventually going to hit the table in
this match. The white flame doesn't do
anything aside from be an eight might
body when you grab it off of the
dazzling of course. So it's it is still
going to help you obviously win over
these porros but we still have to deal
with you know now a tasty fa folk here
from ESR and their own white flame
that's already still in their base.
Yeah, the tasty fay folk trying to
maximize whatever it can do. Getting to
battle into the other fa folk probably
going to do killing the white flame
protector. Leave that. Not let you draw
the extra card. But that fa folk
threatening a trade with this white
flame protector if Clyde has no tricks
of their own,
>> but I'm not sure it's going to get to
hang out there for very long. Yeah, I
think that's why ESR is even Yep. going
to posture to bring it back to the base
because it's already just going to end
up losing straight to that white flame
and Clyde is already in the lead point.
So, we've got to save as many units as
we can. And remember, cuz you like you
said,
>> BSR has basically all of these white
flames.
>> Yeah, you can see another white flame
from Clyde. One white flame for another.
The story of this match.
>> Uh but also just access to things like
defy to counter ESR if any tricks are
there. But ESR also has a defy. both
players uh ESR knowing about Clyde's
Defy from that early early sabotage. So
having to keep that in mind and play
around it, but no real tricks of ESR
zone to even worry about. I think it's
probably end up with the Defy trading
for a Defy at some point, but White
Flame for White Flame. Big units are
what matters. These little tricks maybe
not even super relevant as we crush into
these battlefields.
>> Swinging in for 16 on top of an eight.
Tasty Faithful going to give a little
bit of value back for ESR, but that's
going to be the sixth point here for
Clyde. And once this dazzling goes off,
there's no unit that's going to give a
dugable conquer here. So, six points is
where we're going to end up landing for
Clyde at the end of the turn, passing
back. So, there's still room for ESR to
catch up because of that battlefield
being left alone. I think using one of
these porros to get that point is a lot
more meaningful than you just probably
losing it right off the get- go.
>> Yeah, I mean, this is a big turn for
ESR. Clyde at six. Not enough to win
with Aspirin's climb, but really needs
to have enough pressure in play because
the amount of might Clyde has in the
base pretty high. Only going to get
higher next turn. Going to play a big
monster from hand, hit a big monster
from the Aurora. Really needs to set up
a situation where you are scoring and
have enough might to crash back in. And
if you can't put that into play this
turn, it is never getting easier than
here.
>> Absolutely. I was going to say we have
yet to see a single dead bloom predator
from either player, but that's not
what's coming out. We got that white
flame protector that we already knew was
going to be here onto the poro into the
white flame of itself only up by two.
But here's where I think we're going to
see the exchange of these spells that we
already kind of know about. The ong
guard ESR did not necessarily anticipate
because he know only knows about the
defy. So it ends up going to be trading
those two
8 10 12
>> that that doesn't seem was there a
master y missed or
>> miss trigger maybe
>> that seems like that porro should have
been a 10 and that dragon should have
been a 12 after the ong guard resolves.
Yeah. Yeah. He was doing some quick math
and I was wait a minute. But it does
still provide the opportunity for this
porro to go in and still get the
conquer. It just means you had to give
up a unit and you will inevitably lose
this porro as well. Passing back to
Clyde. And now it is time for Clyde to
kind of run away with this game
depending on what we can continue to
spend our runes for on our own turn and
still continue to grab large units off
the top with the dazzling.
>> ESR was able to do one thing that is
important. Been talking about how even
numbers matter a lot in the Aspirin's
climb game. Odd numbers matter a lot. If
there's any chance of winning this game,
it is definitely going 579. But that
door is shutting closed here really
quickly as Dead Bloom Predator uh takes
that battlefield in Dead Bloom Predator
fashion.
>> Yeah, straight from the hand. And if
we're all keeping track at home, of
course, ESR is officially out of White
Flame Protectors to play from hand. They
are already in the trash or on the
board. So, getting this extra unit up
here.
And then
I think we've missed our dazzling frog
is what we have done. Unless we get a
tasty back seat.
>> Little little judge conversation to see
what if this was missed. Clyde really
going to hit this to kind of shore up
those battlefields. Choosing to not use
the tasty faith folk to defend saying I
think my two eights are big enough. They
beat your white flame. I only need to
hold one battlefield and I think I'll
probably be able to capture both next
turn with just whatever board I have.
So, not too worried about really trying
to put that extra only plus four might
into one of these because of the Wuju
Bladesman.
>> Absolutely full runes at the disposal
for ESR and a plethora of cards in hand.
Um,
going over still, I think, for the
Dazzling, you know, saying to his
opponent that he passed, you know, still
wanting to try and get all of his end of
turn triggers, of course. Um, but
they're going to talk it over, of
course. And I think here's my question.
Even if we don't get this dazzling, I
don't know what ESR has at their
disposal because if we're going to try
and contest against these literally the
largest units that exist in these master
Y decks, we have to play ones of our
own, but we must then help them and
supplement them with extra cards from
our hand like the disciplines and the on
guards. But to get the second unit to
contest this either one, that's going to
be eight runes out of our disposal,
>> right? I mean ESR's hand has things like
defies ancient hourglass and a catalyst
of Aons and those are just not the tools
you really need here. There is a tasty
fay folk which you can combine with this
dragon to get in there, get a trade,
maybe take one battlefield, but I just
don't see a way to really capture a
second one here unless Clyde decides I'm
going to kill your tasty fay folk and
give you a card. But even in those
worlds, it seems like ESR kind of
drawing dead. In the dream world, maybe
there's some primal strengths in that
hand that let you bash through this
stuff. But you also know Clyde has some
defies of his own ready to fight back in
the counter spell war.
>> Absolutely.
Looks like we're proceeding with the
game state. So ESR
probably going to use this catalyst to
draw a card, but pay four draw one is
not necessarily the greatest um when it
comes to having to use all of our runes
at the most efficiency so that we can
try and contest the support state at
all.
>> Yeah. And if you're Clyde there, you're
like, "Oh, that's how you're spending
your energy." Great. That's that is all
I can hope for. That is exactly what I
want to be seeing.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I think we did end up
drawing a dead bloom predator, but as I
kind of stated, that would be
everything. That's everything left in
the tank, at least when it comes to
energy this turn.
>> Yeah, dead bloom on its own doesn't even
work in the mastery emir due to that.
And there's the handshake game ending.
Big monsters. Love big monsters.
>> If you love playing eight might units
for eight, that's exactly what both of
these decks are about. But that's going
to be the match in game three going over
to Clyde proceeding even further into
this tournament after we've now been
able to showcase him twice.
Aaron,
it's officially my time to leave today.
I've had so much fun sitting on this
desk with everyone across the weekend
and I've seen some of the best rift down
I've seen in my entire life and the
game's only been out not very long.
>> Yeah, really incredible matches, really
incredible play. Got to see some really
cool games of Master E, Kaisa, the known
decks, but also got to watch some fun
stuff yesterday like Jinx and Victor and
Voler Bear today. Uh, you know, awesome
event, awesome stuff. Glad you could be
a part of it.
>> Absolutely glad to be sitting here. But
Aaron's not going to be going anywhere.
It's just me, so you shouldn't go
anywhere either. We're going to cut to a
quick break and then we'll be back right
after this.
We have everything riffbound at the
regional qualifiers, including
cosplayers. I've got a Victor and Jinx
with me here, and I want uh you guys to
be able to introduce yourselves. So, uh
let me know about yourself and uh a
little bit about this prop here.
>> Oh, um my name's Jay Young, or go by
Plum Soulju Online.
>> I go by toxic bunny, Toxic K Bunny.
>> Um this I made this entire Victor staff
by myself. Uh the model itself actually
I found it online and I purchased that
but everything here is 3D printed. Um
you can see here is in different small
parts then assembled together. Inside is
a metal doll I got from nose and stick
them inside and super glued it. And
actually for travel purpose you can
actually see you can take apart here to
fit in a checked bag. But I sanded um
filler it and primed it and painted and
yeah that's how I made everything here.
All right, that is amazing. And Toxic
Bunny, why don't you tell me a little
bit about this uh this powpow here?
>> Yeah, so the pow pow's also 3D printed
with the Bambi Lab A1. I don't know why
I said that. Uh also primed, sanded,
painted, and then these are also same
process. And then we also have a ton of
Hexte crystals to give away. So we'll be
giving away little Heste crystals.
You can also put them into here. But
yeah, it's just similar process to
Victor's prop. Uh I brought this on as a
carry-on. So sometimes if you have a
big, you know, 3D printed prop, you
could bring it on as a carry-on and like
one of those clear bags and you could
get away with it. So
>> all right. Well, thank you all so much.
You look amazing and we're going to send
it right on back to the desk for more
Riftbound.
[Music]
Hallelujah.
Yeah.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
[Music]
Oh
yeah.
Hey
[Music]
Welcome back to the Houston regional
qualifier. I'm Kasanova joined by Aaron
Bareric as we jump towards the top
eight. The matches so far have already
been electric. We've seen some
incredibly close mirrors a couple of
times, right? We had the Kaiser mirrors,
the Ye mirrors, but these players have
been fighting back and forth to continue
to increase their share of this massive
prize pool. Yeah, I mean, we've seen the
best of the best fight each other. Yi
versus Ye, that's a pretty skill
inensive thing. Once you get into these
mirrors, it's about having a really
clean plan and really knowing what's
going on, and that's how you get to make
your story and become part of the top
eight.
>> All right. Well, we've talked about it.
We're going to top eight. Let's take a
look at the bracket to see who makes up
this top eight. What legends have
ascended to the top of the tables? It is
going to be George G on Kai'Sa versus
Zent on Annie. George, the winner of the
Chongqing regional open in China, has
now made it to the top eight in the west
as well. We have Shawn Dollywal going up
against Allen ZQ on the Kai'Sa. Another
Kai'Sa Annie match up. And then on the
other side of the bracket, it's more
Annie, but it's Ye this time. End of the
day, Annie Triumphant standing at the
top of the tables with four copies as we
got Primore versus Clyde and Bur versus
No Veggies. Four Annie, two Kaisa, two
Yi. Look, coming into this, I said four
Kai'Sa, two Annie. I was wrong. I had it
flipped.
>> Yeah, we have a setup here that means we
could have a four Annie top four. This
is a bit of an upset, I think, in
people's minds. People knew Annie works
good going in. Powerful deck, but
Mastery E and Kai'Sa did have the option
this weekend to kind of tech forward and
make decisions to try and make a better
matchup there. But here they are. We're
gonna see if the best players on Kaiso
and the best players on Master E have
found those angles to beat the up
andcoming Annie or if they too are going
to fall to these welltaledented Annie
players.
>> 100%. I mean, this was known, right? We
knew that Annie was starting to make the
surgeons. Players were talking about as
the worstkept secret was that, hey, this
Annie deck is insane coming into the
event and the question did remain, will
the Kaiis and Y be able to deal with it?
I know that some of the Annies felt like
the Yi matchup had become very good for
them when I knew that Chinese events it
was actually Yi that kind of gatekept
Annie from finding those top finishes.
And so a lot of players had questions on
would this deck be able to do enough?
And I think the biggest adaptation is
going up from saying hey maybe we can
fit one two rebukes at max because it's
too expensive to saying no three rebukes
in the board maybe even someone main to
help deal with that Yi matchup. Yeah,
the chaos decks really struggle
sometimes with giant units. You have
fight or flight that's really powerful
to kick them out for a single turn, but
you need a lot of those if you weren't
able to get ahead and get to that really
important important six point threshold
for this Annie deck. So having extraes,
having access to more tools explicitly
for this matchup lets you do those
situations where you set up VI, ride the
win, and sometimes those E decks if they
don't have access to something like a
defy, they don't really have a recourse
against that combo,
>> right? And on the other side of the
table, we've got the Kai'Sa match up
into Yei. And they absolutely have
nothing to deal with the uh the Vide. It
really becomes a six-point matchup for
the Annies. They say, "If we can get to
six, we just have to survive long enough
to find Vyide the Wind and the game is
done because there is nothing that
Kai'Sa can actually do to answer it."
>> Yeah, the Annie players over time have
definitely started to internalize this
is the plan. The deck is built with that
in mind fully. We're all about digging
and digging as much as possible. people
playing things like scrap heap in the
main with ZH Warren's game one because
it just gives you the deepest chance to
find that combo so you can get that
six-point win and it really does impact
the whole way the deck is built now and
I bet all of these players have that in
their head. Six points, six points,
combo win.
>> Yeah. Well, we will have to see as we
start to approach towards these matchups
if the Annies can re supreme. I think
already it has been a pretty successful
time for the Annie players to say you
know what this was the right deck to
bring as we've got such a great
conversion rate from even just day one
to day two with the Annies but even more
so with that top eight conversion and
there's still a battle going on for
these last three legends for that best
of prize and you would think the Kaiso
players are like wait a minute I thought
I have to be fighting more people at
this point top eight maybe I I only have
to get top eight top four to actually
land this instead of having to win the
whole We'll see if George and Allen can
hold it out.
>> Yeah, I think it's going to be really
exciting if they both win and we're able
to watch the Kai'Sa mirror, not only to
make it to the finals, but also to get
that best prize. Similarly on the other
side of the bracket with the Master
Ease, Clyde and Blur, both of them, you
know, you get that situation of, okay,
we both won. Now I get to play the most
serious match I've played all weekend.
This is for a lot, not just this metal
card, this best of, but then I still
have to go play the final even if I win
here.
>> It's actually the craziest thing. If we
do see those mirrors in round of four
where they are playing best of and
finals birth at the same time which is
completely insane this round they have
to get through of course still to try
and take down the Annies as those
players are all like wow wait no that
there's too many Annies here what what's
going on I want I wanted to make sure I
can lock up that best but looking at the
Kaisa list we have seen the main power
of this is how fast it can get on point
cadence and then finish the game with
the insane top end of the thousand
watchers the Darius Trafarian and the
Athenian reigns. Get the little stuff
in, score a bunch, finish it out.
>> Yeah. And there's two different ways
people kind of philosophize about
finishing it out. You have George here
in the top eight, really big on time
warp, playing those, using those to
score and into these games. Other
players in the event this weekend really
leaning in more into being a really low
to the ground deck, topping out with
just those thousand tail watcher and a
caffeine reigns and saying more, I'm not
trying to get to 10 runes. I just want
to be ahead the whole time and use my
removal spells and accelerate units to
do that. two different ways to play the
deck working for some players. George
here in the top eight.
>> And I actually think it's beautiful that
you highlighted that way because you
talked about how some of the other Kais
were more l to the ground. Well, George
has the time warps. He's a little bit
more top end. Allan is maybe the most
low to the ground of really any of the
Kais far as the builds are concerned. I
believe it was either one or zero main
deck rain and no time warp. He's playing
around the smoke screens and the void
seekers in the main deck trying to deal
with some of the faster stuff. playing
around dealing with Kai'Sa survivor was
dealing with the sets and the Dariuses
in ways that players had originally
written off coming into the tournament.
The smoke screens had been out of the
Kaiso list for like a month at this
point, but he brought them back and he's
felt like they've been a really
top-notch card to have in the deck.
>> Yeah, and some of that deck building
variation is part of what makes Kai'Sa
so powerful. If you don't know your
opponent's deck getting, you know,
before this top cut, you just kind of
have to play around all of the things.
There's so many different tricks you can
have with one, two, and three energy
that it's so painful to play against
Kaiso. So much pressure on you to know
of all the things and the accelerate
units and being prepared to not lose to
a time warp when they get to 10 that it
can be really tough to play against. And
the better players are really able to
capitalize on that fear.
>> All right, well the wait is over. Let's
go ahead and kick off our top eight.
It's Allen ZQ versus Shawn Dollywal.
Annie versus Kaisa.
We have just I've seen so much of Allen
this weekend. This is my third time
covering one of his matches. He's just
played absolutely excellently with this
Kai deck. Really understanding his role
in each game, knowing how to capitalize
from going second and get those extra
points and catch up. I'm really excited
to see more of him here. I'm curious to
see if he's stuck going second again.
Looks like this time around Allen does
get the die roll win to go onto Warren
from the Annie and Reaver's Row from
Allen ZQ. We have seen the Warren from
the Annie over and over again. This is
that scrap heap in the main. You side
him out for games two and three, but
your game one is just so potent as the
Annie and Reavers Row for Allen being on
the more low to the ground aggressive
build. This allows him to leverage his
Kaiser Survivor a lot more to get those
draws. And with the smoke screens, he is
able to bluff that Reaver so effectively
by sending in small units and saying,
"Would you like to go home or would you
like to potentially get completely blown
out?" Well, the reaver's row is also
good for Dollywah here in that VI is one
of those units that often times you're
forced to play it early and it can be a
little fragile and getting it into a
battlefield means it's likely to get
crushed. But with the Reaver's row, you
can use it to go in there. They go in
and you run your VI out and protect it.
Even if you don't have access to
something like a flash or a fight or
flight,
>> we do just have these early
developments. Survivor from Allen on the
second turn. Merchant was the first play
from Dalia. Well, this does mean that
Allen is completely tapped out. So, this
is all up to Annie. What do you want to
do? How many cards do you want to be
able to cycle through? Because you can
have the merchant move in to the Warren,
get the conquer, you get two of the
discard then draw triggers and
accelerated Kai'Sa for another draw. So
with Allen not having anything open,
this is exactly the kind of turn that
Shawn wants to have.
>> Yeah, going in with the Kai'Sa first
over the traveling merchant wants to
draw the card from that before deciding
in cards wanting to discard. Get the
most information, know what you need to
do over the next couple of turns. Also,
Kai'Sa and the Zon Warren at least
threatening a trade with the opposing
Kai'Sa instead of the merchant going
there and probably just getting eaten.
>> Yep. And then the merchant instead can
go to reaver's row. And if Allen decides
to run in there, you can get another
trigger from the merchant when it goes
home to try and find the combo pieces
that you need.
>> Yeah, another reaver's row good with Vi
for Naliwa. Also good for traveling
merchant.
>> Go ready up those two runes back over to
Allen. Going up to six on this turn.
Really, it's going to be up to what
removal spells he has access to cuz the
unit combat is not looking too favorable
straight away. But a stupify can help
change that.
>> Yeah, just firing off starting with a
stupify before going in. Might as well
see what cards you're going to draw
before you force yourself into this
combat.
>> Yep. And knowing that Annie on the other
side only on two runes, you don't have
to worry about the void seeker. So
survivor is safe to run in and try and
make something happen. Question can be
is there just a fight or flight from
Shawn that's going to help out in this
spot? Does he want to expend the
resources to do so? Is he still worried
about a Ray just cleaning up his Kai'Sa
afterwards? But is that still a
worthwhile trade?
>> Yeah, this is the type of situation
where if you have the fight or flight
there, there's a lot of things to think
about. Am I kicking out your Kai'Sa? Am
I kicking out my Kai'Sa? Do I think I'll
be able to get in with mine later? What
if I have a flash and a fighter flight?
Now, I have a ton of things to think
about if I want to move out my Kai'Sa.
Two different options there. We're only
on the second turn, but there's already
so many decisions having to go through
their head.
>> Yeah, especially because Shawn has
filtered so many cards. So, he's kind of
helped curate a little bit of this hand
to know exactly, hey, what options do I
have? And he's given himself a lot of
options to consider. It is just going to
be a fight orflight and he will pick his
own Kai'Sa playing around a Ray dealing
with her after the fact.
>> I think the other thing you had to be
afraid of was that Darius. There's
already been a stupify played this turn.
Darius, seven might. If you kick out the
Kai'Sa, but your Kai'Sa gets eaten by
that Darius. That's a devastating start
to your game. You're left against with a
traveling merchant against Kais' and
Darius. Not a fight you're happy to be
having.
>> Yeah. The other big thing to look at for
the Annie decks is they usually like to
keep the survivor alive as much as
possible if they can because of its
ability to draw additional cards.
Unfortunately for Shawn, this is the
worst case scenario is that Allen has
the falling star to follow it up. deals
with the stupified unit and also the
traveling merchant and so the fighter
flight essentially just ends up kind of
going to waste.
>> Yeah, that stupify really getting double
value. First forcing a usage of that
fighter flight kicking out the Kai'Sa
then still being shrunk and letting that
falling star be a two for one. Really,
really powerful combo when you're able
to use those two together.
>> Yeah. And now even the follow-up being
Nox's hopeful means that there's just
eight might on the board for Allen into
nothing from Shawn after that turn
cycle. Now, of course, Allen down to a
single rune. So, at worst, Stupify or
Ray are what we're looking at as the
range, but Shawn still has to find a way
to get back on board and start pushing
the tempo of points. He doesn't want to
fall behind. That's where Kai'Sa can
really excel. If Kai'Sa can be the first
to six, then they don't have to worry
nearly as much about that viide the
wind.
>> Yeah, and Kai'Sa is a deck as well.
Allen lower on uh time warps than
others, but they have a sixpoint combo
in too. Just have both those
battlefields, use that time warp, and
get there that way. uh using a stack
deck here from Shawn possibly leading
into a Darius to take out this Kai'Sa
doesn't have to be too afraid of
something like a stupify, but a hex tech
could cause a trade.
>> Yeah, and we've seen this a couple of
times where that is such a scary spot
and for the Kai'Sa is generally worth it
to just expend that ray, let that two
for one happen, but you deny the points,
you deny a big threat, really the
biggest threat that exists within the
Annie deck outside of Vi, and that's
more of the the combo later that you're
worried about. So those Dariuses are
kind of the main thing that you have to
deal with that prevents you from finding
the hold. So if you can get through
those copies without losing too many
points, you can find a lot of space. And
it is going to be the Darius. We'll see
if that one rune is a Ray. Allen also
wouldn't be excited to expend a Ray
because he's already used Daughter of
the Void. So he will be dramping in
order to cast a hack ray. However, in
this Annie matchup, the point total is
just so critical. And we actually see
Shawn not even wanting to chance it and
moving towards the reaver's row instead.
>> Yeah, this Darius is a big threat. It is
a lot of pressure on Allen to be like,
"Okay, you better not leave any units in
this zone warren cuz I can always back
it out, ready it again, and go and fight
whatever you leave here." And there's a
lot of pressure to just make sure Allen
can't be threatening points in the same
way and keeping up with you. Because if
you can't comp accomplish a VI ride the
wind, Allen will eventually overtake you
and beat these battlefields with things
like thousand tail watcher.
>> Yeah, we are going to see Allen awaken.
And now it is look at the Reaver's row.
But second falling star critical piece
of the matchup to keep this board clear
is just going to make way for the
hopeful to take the Reaver's row and
leave Allen catching up in points. Still
a little behind Shawn. and he's not
quite on the full cadence, but just one
step behind and now so far ahead on
board as he establishes a powdery pora.
>> Yeah, I mean the double falling star is
really tough for the Annie deck there.
This game we got to remove two units
with it then take out a Darius for a
massive energy gain. Just getting to be
really efficient with those plays where
Annie normally a deck that gets to be
efficient itself by readying those runes
at the end of a turn but hasn't been
able to really capitalize on those. The
one fighter flight that got played
pretty much got countered by a falling
star.
>> Yeah. No, I mean the the fighter flight
did nothing. I mean, of course, Shawn is
playing around a range of cards at that
spot when he casts it. Unfortunately,
the worst one was the one that was in
hand for Allen at that time. And yeah,
as you said, there's just not been any
value out of the Annie legend in this
game when we've seen throughout the
tournament so much value acrewed from it
over and over again, which is shown why
we have four Annies in our top eight.
But Sean in a certainly tough spot as
now we have a total of 10 might on the
side of Allen. He still has runes
available, enough runes for a void
seeker to even be the potential case
here, which is threatening to some of
the normal uh uh things that Annie is
trying to do. They're trying to play out
survivor, accelerated, push it in.
Seeker deals with it.
>> I want to point out something Allan did
here that was really on top of mind.
That Kai'Sa stayed in the Zong Warren.
It didn't run away. That's normally a
unit you go in with and leave. And if
you go back in, you would get two
conquer triggers, the Kai'Sa and the
Warren. But Allan is super aware of
sneaky deck hand, a unit that's going to
come in if there is an open battlefield.
And Allen's just like, "Nope, I'm not
giving you that opportunity. I'm
blocking these off."
>> Yeah. He says, "No sneakys at all. No
sneaky points." He says, "If you want to
score, you're going to do it the hard
way." And it is going to start with Vi.
And now we see Shawn thumbming through
the trash, deciding, hey, how much of
this can I expend? Am I going to viide
the win now to actually just get some
points and start getting towards six?
>> Yeah, this can't be a spot that he's
really happy about. It's something
sometimes you're forced to do, do the
early vi, ride the wind, but it does
mean the ability of the later one is
much weaker. Going only up to five
points with the Vive, ride the wind in
this situation and not even being able
to kill both units because the reaver's
row going to be able to run out of the
Nox is hopeful. However, on the other
side, that means when the VI ride the
win happens, the Vibe will be at the
Reaver's Row. It has its own opportunity
to run away.
>> Yeah, I think this is super heads up and
great that you caught this as well,
right? So because of the viide the win
ending in the reavers row unless Allen
has a spell that's going to hit back row
or has a spell immediately he can't deal
with the VI with unit combat. And so at
least Sean while he has to expend the
combo early he's giving himself the out
to make Allen have specific answers to
deal with the VI instead of just
completely sacrificing it.
>> Yeah. And another thing you get to think
about here is that I've already seen two
falling stars. That's normally what
really threatens these vies that you
play and have to leave in your back row.
There's a lot less pressure this game to
just run it in and do the combo instead
of just playing. Maybe there's room for
a fair game here. Maybe one of Cathy and
Rain, one Falling Star left in Allen's
deck. And that's not a ton of answers to
this base ridden VI.
>> Now he's just considering the math. I
mean, as he's already committed to the
trash, I imagine that this is always
getting cast and now he's just trying to
determine exactly how this turn always
plays out into the three runes. One of
the big things for Shawn, we had that
interview with him earlier. He started
playing the game like two weeks ago. He
really just picked it up. He is a big
TCG veteran. He's been playing forever.
He's top aed at Fab Worlds. He's
incredibly strong player, but this is a
new game for him. He's really excited
about it and he's learning and diving
in, but he's trying to take his time.
He's trying to learn everything he can
about the game.
>> Yeah, and I said this before the match
started, but playing against the Kaised
is so hard. There is three energy up and
the possible combinations of spells
Allen can have here are pretty deep.
Smoke screens, stupify, a hex tech ray,
void seeker. A lot of things to think
about all at once in some combination of
those could be enough to kill this VI in
one of these combats.
>> Yep. And here we go. One of the
explanations as well as staying there.
You get to deny the sneaky. And if
you've got the retreat, it's no risk.
You're happy to play that retreat, get
the extra rune, save the Kai'Sa, and now
you can reacelerate later if you want
because of these runes that you've been
able to buy over time.
There's an interesting decision here it
seems for Sean considering discarding
the sneaky duck hand. Knows it's not
that good left in this game. Who cares?
But now it's do I back this up to my
base or go to the reaver's row. Deciding
the reaver's row. Think it's worth the
point. But if you are scared of a void
seeker on Allen's turn and you don't
have access to a flash, it's possible
you just go back to your base. You're
already at four points. The even numbers
matter way more. So going to five maybe
not the most important thing.
>> Yeah. but decides to go to five. I'm
curious if it is exactly that flash that
you called out as maybe being in hand.
So, you're not worried about the uh the
play from Allen with a Ray or a Void
Seeker. And you don't have to worry
about unit combat as we established
earlier. The Reverse Row actually kind
of hurting Allen in this spot as that Vi
might have a chance to just go home
safely. There's the Ray. Is the flash in
response or will this land?
>> I think I saw it. Yeah, there it is. So,
bringing back the Vi. Not a huge trash.
Four cards though. pretty good enough to
fight through most things, especially
Allen's current board where there's only
six mate.
>> Yeah, and this keeps Shawn in the lead
on points.
And Allen, yes, he can conquer both
sides, go up to five, but he's not
actually gaining much traction this
time. And Shawn, because of the Warren's
game, even though he spent six cards
from his trash, already has four more
there ready to go to pump this VI up to
at least seven going into the next turn.
Yeah, I mean the Zon Warren's game for
the Annie deck is so powerful. A lot of
your deck is about getting the right
combinations of cards at the right time.
Cards like Flash and Ride the Wind,
there are situations where they do
pretty much nothing. And having access
to an easy, repeatable way to loot past
those and find other things that you do
need in those situations in addition to
making those vis.
Looks like they're just maybe asking for
clarity on some kind of ruling here as
both players are kind of waiting. So,
we'll see as that gets established.
Nothing in the current board state is
very clear on what they would be asking.
So, it may have something to do with
something in the hand or a rules
question or even just oracle text on a
card that maybe they were curious about
thinking that may be in their opponent's
hand and they wanted to know exactly
what that card says.
>> Yeah. Never be afraid to call a judge
and ask about some cards you may not
know. Knowing what's going on, that is
the most important thing to do. The
worst way is to lose because you didn't
know what a card said.
>> Exactly. So, as we take a look just at
the the game state, Allen 32, Shawn's
five, has the two units on board, but
the VI on the other side. Ray expended,
so not going to be available to try and
deal with a sneaky deck hand or deal
with the VI's total might level going
into these next few turns. Allen, we
assume, will go up to five on this turn.
He's got two units back. He can easily
move them in. Void Seeker, a potential
answer, but with so many runes
available, it's possible that Allen
still has some additional game. We know
at the bare minimum, he can accelerate
the Kaisa survivor that was retreated on
the previous turn. And so from there,
the question becomes, how does Shawn
leverage this five all the way to a win?
I think six is not going to be
difficult, but the VI has already been
spent. The ride, the win can be grabbed
from Annie Stubborn, but if this VI can
be taken down, how does Shawn find those
last two points? Yeah, I mean Allen is
in a really tight position because of
that ability to threaten this VI. If
there is no
tricks about Allen, multiple damage
based removal spells, that VI can
probably take that reaver's row, no
trouble whatsoever, and then can still
threaten to be ran away again. Allen
used a lot of damage based removal this
game. Even if he doesn't have any, it's
possibly a position where he's forced to
bluff it, leave up this energy,
threaten. Hey, I have Void Seeker. Hey,
I have hex tech raid. Maybe a smoke
screen. just so that Shawn doesn't have
the free reign of being able to run over
these battlefields because cleaves and
other tricks from Annie gives a lot of
power there to be able to do that.
>> And in the hand, we talked about how
Allen was lower on time warp. I thought
he didn't have it in the main deck. I
think he might have added it uh last
minute before registering for the
tournament cuz he didn't play him in the
skirmish. So slightly different list
than his skirmish list that I was
thinking about. He's got a warp in hand.
So, this may be able to change the math
and he can find a way to circumvent this
because he's been able to ramp the runes
pretty well this game considering he's
played two falling stars.
>> Yeah, it's uh the great thing about
Kai'Sa is you play a really powerful
card like Falling Star and somehow still
the Annie deck has less runes than you.
>> Yeah, exactly. Yes.
>> All right, move both in as expected.
Sean just lets it happen.
Back row can be filled. Darius being
held by Allen currently. I see a Raven
Bloom as well considering what he can
develop back row.
>> The Darius you play and then have to
leave in your base. Not always the most
thrilling action. And also definitely
having to consider that how much energy
do I leave up? What can I pretend I
have? What can I convince Shawn is still
going on?
>> I think I'm counting nine runes here. So
Darius can be played and still have
enough runes for time warp on the next
turn. If you play Darius Raven Bloom if
you think that that is enough to push on
to the battlefields and then cast warp,
it can work. And I think that's what
Allan is looking at. He's looking at how
can I set up for a time warp victory
because I am behind by a single turn
here as far as points go. Playing that
Raven Bloom student into the Zworns is
so interesting into the face of this VI.
There are four cards in the trash. The
VI is at least a seven. That's only six
might in play. However, six energy up. A
lot of potential to play some spells.
This is a situation where it could be
Allen is really hoping that this is some
amount of bait. You go in with the VI,
you take this battlefield. I have the
Darius to kill the VI after. And maybe I
don't have to be as afraid of a VI ride
the win. But I imagine if Shawn is aware
of that, nose really only needs six
points. Might just end up going to the
Reavers row. Kick the Porro out. It's a
tough situation. You do have to be
considering I need to make sure I don't
lose to time ward.
>> Yeah, I don't know how much of this is
bait from Allen and how much he actually
has in this hand to juice up the Raven
Bloom soon and deal with the aggression.
I also know, you know, he's on nine
runes. He only really wants to expend
one more here to keep the warp up. So,
how much action does he have that's not
going to dramp him out of the warp range
in trying to deal with this? So, lot of
questions to be answered on this turn
from Allen, but he's asking so many
questions of Shawn to say, "What do you
want to play around? What do you want to
try and deal with here?"
>> Yeah, I'm sure Allen is also pretty
thrilled if Shawn ends up having to
recycle that ride the wind. It's one of
the four cards in the trash. The Annie
can pick it back up. There's some good
things in that trash and if they get
used in this way, Allen doesn't have to
worry about them as much. However, I do
think I saw another ride the wind in
Shawn's hand. So not as worried about
using that one out of the trash, but
Allen doesn't know about that.
>> All right, big decision for Shawn
if he did find that red the wind. If if
we've spotted that in hand, it is such a
big difference. It may be one might, but
one might can be the difference on
winning and losing the game in this spot
with so many tricks available.
Playing Annie is always so tough. You
see flipping from trash to hand, trash
to hand. This is also my hand despite it
being my trash. Oh, if I use the Annie
this turn, I'm down four energy. What
even can I accomplish after that? Really
needs to get to six this turn. If you
can't get to six here, you're giving
Allen an extra turn. And that is way too
much in this situation.
>> Four into the VI.
Deciding the order now. But we saw him
grab the trash, pointed at his VI, he
said plus four. Yeah, the, you know,
fixing the order probably not going to
matter in this game with two whole turns
at most, but
>> you always want to be on top of those
things.
>> Yep. Vi the only card currently in the
game, I believe, where you can just
individually order those big stacks
because it is one by one that you're
actually doing it. Most players, if not
all players, do kind of shortcut it at
the end and just kind of make the stack
and put it at the bottom because that
makes a lot of sense, save you a lot of
time. But it is going to be seven might
into the porro. Allan just says that one
can come home.
>> Yeah, I mean this is a pretty loud thing
that Allan must be like okay you
definitely have another ride the wind
otherwise you would not pump your thing
and then go into this reaver's row in
the same way.
>> Looking at the runes Shawn can go Darius
send it in ride the wind the VI if he
wants to try and brute force through
this setup from Allen.
It does seem like Shan is potentially
really playing around a void seeker or a
smoke screen here. That seven value
against the porro does mean those don't
remove it. Darius also another seven
though if that is going to the zod
wards. If Allen does have access to one
of those spells, it definitely will be
that Darius pass.
Ry the runes ride the wind still
available. I mean Shawn did what needs
to be done. Got to six points. This is
the situation on the board. Allen can't
kick the VI out with the pouty porro and
then play time warp. That is not an
option. So something else needs to be
done and Shawn will get at least one
more turn unless there's a big
accelerate unit to come kick this.
>> What Allen can do though is he can
retreat those units back and then warp.
And also because he was at nine runes
and he didn't expend one on the last
turn. He has enough to go for the ray
enter with the porro and then warp.
>> 11 runes definitely different than the
10 that I was counting thinking of that
Darius we had spoken of last turn. My
brain shortcut that he had used it but
yes having that 10 here huge. I imagine
this is going to be a uh pretty swift
end giving Shawn a chance to think if he
wants to do anything fight or flight
this poor out but that's not really
going to matter in this situation in the
face of the time warp. Yeah, the
question really becomes, do you ride the
wind here and push your Darius in,
reconquer, go to seven, send the Porro
home, and hope that it's enough,
>> but he has to think about is time warp
in a range of something that he's
willing to play around. I think he would
have been more aggressive last turn if
he wanted time warp to be in his range.
And now I'm wondering if he sees the
writing on the wall that this may just
be a warp in game. Yeah, trying to think
of, you know, I certainly can't beat
your perfect hand. So, what of your
hands can I beat? Well, if it's time
warp, I think I have to do the ride the
win. If it's not time warp and it is a
pile of accelerate units or more
removal, what is the best way to try and
fight through those? This Darius really
important with that vine in the trash,
but it seems we let it happen. And
there's the
>> shows it. Allen reveals the warp and he
gets game one here in our first match in
the top eight. Very tight play from both
players because Shawn is just one turn
away from an easy ride the win victory
with that VI having to leverage it early
though because of Allen's pressure via
all the falling stars.
>> Yeah, I mean the double falling star
start against the Annie deck. Really
tough. Shawn never really able to
capture a bit of that board presence
doing exactly what Allen wants. Can't
stop from getting a few points as the
Annie deck. You're going to sneak some
of those in. You still get to put that
pressure but never letting them come
easy. always needing to expend those
resources, forcing that early VI, eating
the trash, a lot of things that really
important in those games. And Allen
doing a great job to never let sneaky
deck hands get free points.
>> Yeah, and this time, I mean, it was
Kai'Sa on the play. This is a very
aggressive matchup. The fact that Shawn
was even able to turn around the point
uh advantage being on the draw. We'll
see going into the play for the next uh
game with Annie, very likely. I'm gonna
expect Arena's greatest on the play for
Annie, which is a very tough matchup for
anyone else going against that deck.
It's why this deck has had so much
success. You've got your game one warren
which is hard for anybody to deal with
and then you've also got an on the play
arena's greatest which can be just a
nightmare.
>> Yeah, the great news you only have to
win best two out of three in a match.
Unfortunately for Shawn did not win the
Z war game. Those scrap heaps probably
going to get taken out. Going to bring
in some other tools to help fight
against the Kai'Sa deck. Uh we will see
if that is enough.
>> My guess is this game on the play
definitely favors the deck.
>> All right. Well, we should jump into
this getting a game two of this top
eight matchup to see if Shawn is able to
turn things around or if Allen is able
to actually continue on this win streak
get the free or the the quick 2 with the
Kai'Sa. I I am wondering what needs to
be done from the Kai'Sa side when it is
Annie on the play uh on the arena's
greatest. We are going to expect really
the falling stars being the critical
piece yet again,
>> right? Falling star is super duper
important in those games. I will say in
game one, Allen got to finish the game
with a time warp. I tend to think those
are a little bit of a liability when
you're going second. Having those
effects in your hand instead of more
removal or instead of more cheap units
that you can play to not allow the Annie
deck to get too far ahead, big deal. Any
game where you're you mulligan and one
of your four cards ends up being a time
warp, you're pretty much just down a
card and you really are instead looking
for those early plays or accelerate
units to just not let that board get
captured.
>> Yeah, it's it's cool you bring this up
because you think about it. You look at
this game and you're like, "Okay, Allan
does not win this game unless he has a
time warp cuz he finds this time warp at
the end and that seals the deal." And
yet siding out those warps might
actually just be the correct thing to do
going into game two.
>> Yeah. And the difference in game one and
game two. Game one, you don't know who's
on the play or draw. If you think it's
really good when you're on the play,
great. You do know you're going second
in game two and you know there's an
arena gray is coming for you. So that
pressure is on really, really early and
those expensive cards do become bit of a
liability. I don't know how far Allen
goes with it. I could see things even
like Thousand Tail Watcher, if you have
three copies in your deck, drawing two
of those early is really, really bad.
Possibly trimming on those, bringing
more of those cheap spells, any type of
thing that messes with combat,
especially because if you're able to
have something like a smokec screen and
a void seeker in your hand and hold
those up, you're maybe just barely able
to beat through a VI ride the wind. And
if you can do that at any point, that
will really give you a huge advantage in
those games. So, there's so much
opportunity to be had by just being more
efficient.
>> All right. Well, we're going to get that
game to soon enough, but before we do,
we're going to check in with some of our
best of winners from throughout the
weekend. We're sending it over to talk
to Tabo, who won the best of Garen.
All right, I'm here with Tibo, winner of
the best of Garen.
T, I know you're a TCG grinder. How did
How did we end up on G? How did this
happen?
>> Uh, my teammate TK has been working with
me on building a a sick Annie deck. And
I decided the night before the event
that I didn't want to do it. I couldn't
do it to myself. It wasn't as fun to
play as like what I like to do in card
games. I like to do goofy stuff. So, I
wanted to do something goofy. And of
course, we went with Garen. It's a lot
of fun.
>> This is maybe the goofiest thing that
you could have done is play the Garen,
but I don't know how goofy it ends up
when you go six and three and win the
card. So, tell me a little bit about the
run. How were you able to find six wins?
>> Uh, the deck is actually like way better
than people give it credit for. Everyone
was like, "Don't play Garen. Don't play
Garen." I have to prove the haters
wrong. I played against a slew of
different heroes. I beat a Kai'Sa. I
beat uh a bunch of leins, Teemo. Uh I
played against a Yasu around one on
camera. He uh he got me, but it was
close. So the the deck is like very
powerful. It it comes down in my build
to if you find Aurora or not. So if you
find Aurora, you're doing very powerful
things. And if not, you're still like a
a good big dude's deck. So
>> all right. Well, for the Garen and
Joyers at home, do you have any tips for
them in their games at their nexus
knights going forward?
>> Uh, the mulligan is really important.
You have to keep uh ramp and Aurora. And
if you find those things, it's very
good. Do that. Find draw Aurora.
>> All right. Thanks, T so much. Well,
hopefully we'll see you in the future
at, you know, either Bolognia, Vegas,
anywhere else in the Ripbound world,
maybe playing some other goofy decks.
So, thanks so much, T. Congratulations
on the best of card. We'll send it back
to the broadcast.
>> Wow. Thanks me and T. We are back here
getting ready to jump into the second
game of our first top eight match. And
uh you know T being a teammate of Shawn
Doll, a whole group of them prep this
Annie list. We saw Ter Patel also make
it into the top 64 on the Annie and T
decided yeah no uh we did all this work
on a really incredible Annie list that
people are going to succeed. I'm going
to play Garen instead. And uh well he
did come away with the best of prize.
>> Yeah. I mean that is kind of the the
genius of best ofves and what that
brings to the table is people you may
think you have the best deck but if you
don't think you're going to win the
tournament you can go and try and
achieve something else and get this
really cool prize. That's really really
sweet.
>> Yeah. Well and did succeed on doing so.
And we'll see if his teammate can
succeed in the top eight as Shawn Dolly
back against the wall. Annie on the play
on Arena's greatest against Allen's EQ
who has gone for Candleit Sanctum as the
second battlefield. I know Allen likes
to find a neutral battlefield that's not
going to ever really hurt him against
his opponent that he can have whenever
he knows he'll be on the draw.
>> Yeah, getting in here with the pouty
poro as the first play. Much less
fragile to that falling star in the
first game. Traveling merchant getting
cleaned up really easily. Definitely
something that is nice to have for
Shawn. Yep. Double pouties on the board,
one for each player. Now up to four
runes for Shawn. But this is always
where you can kind of look for that
sneaky deck hand to gain value. Get a
conquer with your two and then deck hand
up to those three points already. And
Candleit Sanctum. I mean Shawn, this is
going to be nice for him as well. You
are playing a deck that is combo
oriented and you are still looking for
those pieces. And while you don't have
the filtering of warren, Sanctum allows
you to filter in a similar way.
>> Yeah, I could believe that the Candlelet
Sanctum is actually stronger for the
Annie deck than the Kaisa deck. You're
looking for such specific cards. Part of
what makes the Ann deck uh the Kaisa
deck so good is all of your cards are
pretty equally powerful.
>> And it is just going to be that sneaky
deck hand for Shawn. He goes up to three
straight out the gates and it's up to
Allen to start to answer back and claw
back some of these points. He's not
behind in point cadence yet, but seeing
as how the sneaky deck hand is that
quick accelerate, get the points. Uh,
usually you're going to fall behind in
these spots.
>> Yeah, I think you can get a good read on
Allen's hand here. Did not have a hex
tech ray. Very likely to have played it
there. And I think that means that Shawn
knows, okay, I don't have to worry about
that one for at least a little bit until
you get some more cards in your hand.
>> All right, Allan pushes the poros as
pass offers the trade. Shawn happy to
oblige.
potential opportunity for an accelerated
Kai'Sa to go in, but a Void Seeker here
could be really good from the other
side.
>> Yeah, devastating even if it comes out
from Shawn. It's not the Void Seeker.
Just a flash to bring back the deck
hand, but can allow it to pivot over to
the Sanctum again. Score again, get
another sanctum trigger for Shawn. So, I
think he's relatively happy with how
this turn played out, even though Allen
will get a score in a draw. Allen had
the option to do this fight in the other
direction. Send the porro into the deck
hand, then try and send the Kai'Sa into
the porro. However, if that had
happened, this cleave on the deckhand
would have gotten a candle at Sanctum
Trigger. Instead, that doesn't happen.
And I think Allan knew this was a
possibility. All right. And here is one
of the sideboard pieces from Annie. I'm
surprised this one came in. I actually
didn't realize they were liking the
Draven in the Kai'Sa matchup. Just
trying to have a big guy. And the fact
that they've scored four points already
means Shawn does have this Draven
Showboat at seven.
>> Yeah, the game you're on the play, you
get to have that arena's greatest. It's
so likely the Draven gets to be above a
size that Falling Star is going to kill
very easily. You get to keep it in your
base. You get to use it when you're
ready. And it's kind of another unit you
can do some ride the wind tricks with.
It's very large. If you're able to sneak
it in on their turn when they move in
off your ride the win, you can get a
nice extra point that they were not
expecting.
>> Yeah. And it it makes this awkward for
Allen, right? He plays out the Darius if
he wanted to send in Darius to the
sneaky deck hand. He's just feeding it
to Draven. So he just plays it and
passes to keep it back to help maybe
deal with the Draven later. But that
just means Shawn is just going to six
here and this game is very likely just a
blowout. It is just Annie on the play.
Arena's greatest found the deck hand. It
is hard to beat this as any deck.
>> The tough part about having to concede
these points is that the Draven does
just get bigger. Not only are you more
likely to lose, but if you couldn't
answer the Draven before, it's not like
it got better for you.
>> Yeah, just showcasing why this is the
premier aggro deck in the format with
Annie. It's always fun in Riftbound to
think about these TCG terms of the
different styles of decks because just
due to the battlefields and scoring two
points a turn, they don't all they don't
fall into those categories so easily.
But I would say I can comfortably call
Annie an aggro deck. Yeah, it's pretty
hard to be an aggro deck in a game where
you can't really score more than two
points, but cards like Sneaky Deck can
give you that extra point early and
things like Ride the Wind can allow you
to score points on your opponent's turn,
letting you break that two-point rule in
ways that most decks can't.
>> Yeah, exactly. As we do move forward, it
is just going to be shoving the Draven
into the candle at Sanctum to go to six.
And I think for Shawn, it's now all
right. Well, I'm getting more candle at
Sanctum triggers. I just need to look
for that ride the wind and the VI. If he
has zero pieces, then this game still
kind of has some legs to it. There's
still some interaction that Al can Allen
can do, but he has to be able to not
only get the points himself, but deny
the two points from anything else that
Annie does. It's not just VI ride the
wind that is good at scoring points.
There are Dariuses in this deck. You can
have the cleave setups. You can still
just push something with fight or flight
and then run onto the point.
>> Yeah, I just really want to say how
genius Darius feels in this matchup
right here. Or a Draven. I mean, Darius
needs some cards to fight through it.
It's a nine. Darius only a seven. Has to
commit something like a cleave or a
smoke screen or whatever to attack
through the Draven, but the ant's so
good at just sneaking its unit out. You
You have to spend a spell. You have to
go in, but then okay, I have a flash.
I'll run away and then run back in and
kill your Darius or fight or flight my
thing out. Getting to There you go. Pick
up that flash.
>> Protect that Draven. So, even if Darius
plus something is on the table, this
Draven is not getting removed here
outside of something like a caffeine
man. So, and the beauty of this, you
call out how good the flash is with the
Draven. The beauty of Annie's stubborn
grabbing flash is he says, "Hey, Allan,
look at this flash. Now, if you would
like to send your Darius in, you do have
to buff it over my Draven or I'll just
stay. And if you don't buff it over,
then I just get to deal with your
Darius. And if you do buff it over,
here's the flash."
>> Right. And because Shawn is now
threatening both these battlefields, if
Allen commits many resources to even
make that attack into the Draven good in
the first place, that just gives so much
less power to fight back on the return
attack either battlefield. I mean,
Draven's a nine. Send one unit into the
arena's greatest, it's going to be a 10,
and that's going to be a giant monster.
>> Yeah. And you call out the Athenian
rain. Now, we're just beyond it. You
know, nine and three on the Annie. These
are awkward break points for that
Athenian rain to come through. 49. You
have to put five of the six uses of the
Athenian rain to get in there. Last
turn, it would have just been the four,
which would allow you to kind of sweep
up some of the other units. But even at
this point, your biggest removal tool is
not really enough to help deal with
this. You need unit combat to beat the
Draven. And Shawn just picked up a flash
from his trash.
>> Yeah, Allan really in the squeeze of I
feel like I have to leave up spells to,
you know, posture that I'm not going to
lose when you get to move your stuff in,
but I'm also behind on board. I need to
play these units. I need to grow my own
situation.
And you get into one of these places
where you're looking at your hand, you
have so many cards, seven cards in hand.
You feel like you have all the options,
but there just maybe isn't a way to play
them all fast enough. And there is the
cleave on to Darius. So, as we talked
about having to commit early, you will
need to still play a second card to push
the Darius uh to a high enough might to
push over the Draven as currently it
would just be an eight into nine. What
Allen can do is send it in and then cast
a spell to rery it after the move so he
can move the D the Darius back after.
The problem is is that Shawn is at six.
So that doesn't actually end up helping
you when normally that would be a really
nice play that you can make. Shawn has
just been way too fast.
>> Yeah, this Darius is going to need to
hold. That's not one of its strong
suits. Normally is a much better card on
the offensive, but just because there
are these extra units in the base and
this Draven's going to get sent back to
the base. You got to be able to stop
some of these and you don't have a lot
of energy to do it otherwise if you're
not including this five might body.
>> Yeah, he sends the Darius in. Looks like
Allen not even bothering to show the
ready Darius cuz it's just going to stay
in that candle at Sanctum and attempt to
hold. He knows the flash is coming
though. Shawn just going to respond
there. Stupify gets to resolve. Allen
and draw a card.
>> And Sanctum trigger to see if he can
find anything else.
>> Probably not a huge deal. Sean does need
to pay for said flash.
>> Oh yes. Yeah, that that is true. I don't
know that that's going to come up, but
they will notice if it does.
>> Just a moment of both players knowing
exactly what spell was going to be cast
and that it was everything. It was going
to happen there.
>> You know, they're shortcutting a lot of
stuff. Everyone knows what's going to
happen and sometimes just what happens
when you know who you're playing
against.
>> Now Allan considering can he move the
Darius anywhere? I mean, the answer is
really no. It's just there there's no
way that moving it back I I just don't
feel like you're going to be able to
stop Shawn from double conquering
without attempting a full hold. There
was a world where if Allen has a hex
tech rate and a void seeker, you can
move the Darius back.
Let Shawn conquer with the Draven and
then remove the other two units and not
allow. that doesn't work against Ride
the Wind or another sneaky deck hand or
even something like a gust on the sneaky
deck hand to return it to hand and
replay it. A lot of things that would
make that just a play that doesn't
really work out. But, you know, Allen's
in a rough spot. It is one of those
situations where you see your opponent
has three cards in hand and you kind of
have to create for yourself a okay, if
it's what three cards could it be that I
could maybe beat, I have to pretend it's
those three. That's how I'm going to
play this game.
>> Yeah. And well, now it can be anything
cuz it's a stacked deck and so Annie is
going to be taking the pick of the top
three cards of the deck to see which one
is best. Shawn picking very swiftly.
Have to imagine it is a piece that he
has been looking for in this game or at
least one that can make this conquer
relatively trivial as he does still look
through. I mean this is nine might
Draven so it's up to 14 total might on
board realistically. The deck hand just
tries to walk into arena's greatest to
see what's going on there. See if Allen
is going to expend any spells.
>> Yeah, you can assume you're going to be
able to get that first point. Bring that
Draven up one point higher into a 10.
And then you have to go through those
permutations of what could Allen had
have that could blow me out. Okay, three
energy. I think the two best things
possible are a stupify and a smoke
screen. That's minus five on the Draven.
Brings the Darius up to a seven.
Maybe too hard to get through, but if
Shawn has something like a fight or
flight, it's going to be really hard for
Allen to beat through that in anyway.
>> And I have to think off the stack deck,
ride the wind, fight or flight. These
are the the cards that I'm expecting
were found.
He has to go on just kind of a, you
know, a little factf finding mission.
Got to send in the sneaky deck hand, see
what spells, see if there will be a
flinch. This is another way you can send
in a sneaky deck hand is play it from
hand. Yeah, it's kind of like your first
one in play. It's like you play it
accelerated to your base instead of to
the battlefield.
>> Yeah. Allan just going to scoop it up
after that recognizing, okay, well, with
the Draven getting an additional point
there, it's going to be far too much.
>> Yeah. I mean, that was a game we saw the
Annie thing doing exactly what it's
supposed to do. Get the extra point to
start, have a sneaky deck hand with two
drops, score both battlefields, have a
big finisher like a Draven, not a V ride
the win. But in a match up like Heisa, a
9 10 might unit, it's really tough for
them to answer that.
>> Yeah. And I mean, look, we were before
we went even went into this match and we
started talking about, hey, Annie on the
play arena's greatest can be really
scary. And we saw exactly why that can
be because the sneaky deck hand comes
out. You end up getting to three points
right out the gates, which yes, that's
not on point cadence, but it is just so
far ahead. And the Draven tech, I think
that was very impressive in this game. I
I knew that they had it in the deck. I
knew it was brought in for some of the
big matchups cuz sometimes you just have
to go tall into these like Aurora decks
to get that last point, but into Kaiisa,
yeah, Falling Star didn't hit it. Even
we got to the point where Kathy and Rain
looked pitiful into this Draven and
there's just no good answers.
>> Yeah, the best answer is probably
something like a thousand tail watch
here. But if you're committing to
accelerating that in, you're sliding
yourself up to get blown out by a ride
the wind or a flash. Maybe the Annie
deck doesn't have those. But if a Draven
is at seven points, you're still only
getting a trade. The situations where
you get a huge blowout, not that high.
>> Well, Allen did earn himself the right
to go on the play for the last game by
winning on the Z warren. And so that can
have a lot of implications when we have
a tempo deck versus an aggro deck is
being able to have the play, get the
start, and get those early points is so
important for Kaisen in dealing with
Annie. You don't win when Annie makes it
to six, but if you're the first to six,
you do have that turn to finish. And
Annie is not very good at holding.
>> Yeah, we were talking going into game
two when Allen was going second that
maybe you're cutting some cards like
Time Warp or the Thousand Tale Watcher.
Now that you're back on the play and you
have the arena's greatest, you get a
little more flexibility in using your
runes how you want. You're under a
little less pressure. Maybe some of
those could be more powerful. You bring
those back in. you just don't have the
same need to always be deploying things,
always be answering things on the
opponent's turn. And it really lets you
breathe a sigh of relief and use your
cards the way you really want to for
maximum value.
>> All right. Well, before we jump into the
final game of this first top eight
match, we are going to go check in with
Floren Christian Logan who did win the
Volibear best of prize card to hear a
little bit about his run.
[Music]
All
right, I'm here with Floren Christian
Logan, winner of the best of Voly Bear
on the weekend. Floren, what what
possessed you to bring the bear to this
event?
>> So, I wanted to try something that was
basically a little bit off meta and
Volibear is kind of in this spot where
you can kind of compete. I mean, you're
not favored, but you can still compete.
So, yeah, that was basically the idea
behind it.
>> And how did it feel to make the top 64?
I'm sure this might have been pushed
past the expectations that you had
coming in.
>> Yeah. So, obviously my goal has if
you're playing, let's say, a bit of an
off meta, you're kind of hoping to get
the price card. Uh, but yeah, of top 64
was, let's say, beyond expectations. Um,
but yeah, I had some good matchups. Uh,
I didn't face I faced only one Annie.
That was the game that I lost actually.
Um, but yeah, that's how Yeah, very
glad, very happy to be honest. And for
the aspiring Volibear players out there,
what are the the like good matchups?
What are the things that you were
looking for that you had a good time
with as you were playing through the
event?
>> Yeah, so I think like uh Aurora matchups
are playable. You have I think you have
good game into them. Of course, it has
some intricacies. You need to take care
of that. Uh I think it's very
serviceable into Kaisa. Um you basically
have game like a broad game. You can
basically play every game because you
have more interaction. So you're not a
Aurora or nothing kind of deck. So you
can play without Aurora. Obviously it's
a bit of a struggle, but uh yeah, that's
basically you have game into almost all
matchups.
>> Well, speaking of that, was there any
like MVP cards from the Volibear deck
this weekend that really helped you find
the the big wins?
>> Uh yeah. Uh match one it was on Cam. Uh
hitting that Predator off the top. Uh I
mean I play I that was my only out. I
just Anivvia in and then hitting the
Predator. So, I guess predator is the is
the card to hit. Yeah.
>> All right. Fair enough. Thank you so
much for talking with us, Lauren. And uh
you know, good luck in the future of
Ripbound if you decide to play the bear
again or find some other pet deck going
forward.
>> Thanks. Send it back to the broadcast.
Wow, that interviewer sure is annoying.
But we are going to be getting back into
the games in just a second with the
final match of our first top eight
series. Allan ZQ versus Shawn Daliawal.
Aaron, this matchup is incredibly
exciting. I want to send us right into
the match and we're going to start
talking about this last battlefield
selection as we do have the final game.
It's their last battlefields, but on the
play arena's greatest this time for
Kai'Sa and the Dreaming Tree is the last
one remaining for Annie. Both of these
decks do love the Dreaming Tree.
>> Yeah, both these decks do love both
battlefields. I mean, Annie is a deck
that is about getting that six points
and achieving that combo. And normally
when you're on the play with a deck like
Kaiso, you're like, "Yeah, this point is
really good for me." But this is a
situation where maybe I'm giving them
that one. If they have a good start with
a sneaky deck hand and start getting
points on the board, I might be in
trouble. Dreaming
>> also good for Allen. Stupify draw two
cards. Really powerful thing to do. Both
decks cleave decks. Interesting
situation where fighting over what these
battlefields do to the game is going to
be really important to who wins. Yeah,
the retreat can be very valuable because
it actually draws a card even though
it's something that you're not as happy
with usually as Kai'Sa in this match up,
but now it gains some additional value
and I wonder if Allen brings them back
in. I think I saw one in his hand, but
it looks like he is going to ship it
back. And I think he just needs to mold
two cuz I did not see a two drop for
Allen. This can be disaster if Kaisen
misses the two going in and especially
if a deckhand is found. It can be
salvaged a little bit if you do have the
ray to answer the deck hand. So, at
least you're not you don't have the two,
but you have the response. And we'll see
what gets found. But to kick things off,
it looks like a smoke screen drawn.
>> I I saw the pass.
>> I saw Allen peel his top card with the
face of someone who knows they need
something good. And it was just a smoke
screen. It immediately washed over his
face of I am in a little bit of trouble.
>> Yeah. Pass to kick things off. Three
runes for Shawn. Is there the deck hand?
And is the Ray there to answer it if it
is? But it looks like just two runes
being held by Shawn right now. Might
just be something like a porro to kick
things off. Once again,
>> started by saying that Arena's greatest,
you know, maybe potentially a little
stronger for Annie than for Kai'Sa. It
definitely risk doing that if you fail
to play something on your first turn as
the Kai'Sa player.
>> We do have stack deck
just going to draw. Maybe Shawn also
missing a turn one play. We'll see if
that was just kind of digging for
something deeper. That is going to be a
merchant.
>> I'm sure if you're Allen here, you're
like, "Oh, I'm so glad it's just a
merchant, not a sneaky deck hand, not a
Noxis hopeful, not something that's
harder to answer."
>> Second smoke screen pulled off the top
from Allen. And it is going to be just
Kai'Sa played having to hope that this
can do enough early on, but that is
going to be seeding a lot of pressure
over to Sha's Annie. likely doesn't need
them immediately, but Allen did has
failed to find any mind runes. If we end
up getting into a situation where we
need to cast both smoke screens, there's
maybe a world where we're unable to do
that. Not likely, but something Allen
does have to be thinking about while
he's sitting there.
Heavily considering on this turn can
always start with a merchant move to dig
for more, but a lot of options in hand.
see the Darius, some of the bigger
threats ready to go. But the Darius is
something that at least Allen will have
that answer to with the smoke screen. It
can help a lot in this matchup. It is
just going to be an accelerated Kai'Sa
into the Dreaming Tree. He's got the
flash that can help draw a ton of cards
as he starts out with a draw from the
Kai'Sa. We saw this game one with Shawn
choosing to accelerate the Kai'Sa before
moving in with the traveling merchant.
really valuing maximum information of
cards in hand before having to decide on
a discard to that effect.
>> Is going to be two more runes, only one
blue
with the double smoke screen in hand.
Something to look out for. Will have
more coming up, but on this turn, if it
is a card that he wants to deploy, using
the Kai'Sa ability is one way. That is
going to be a cleave
on the Dreaming Tree. get a draw, try
and push over the top.
>> This is a pretty good setup for Allen.
If we see the a flash or fighter flight
here, moving out that Kai'Sa, I believe
Allen has a Darius that can be played
and just run into the other battlefield
to take out this traveling merchant. And
now we are out of runes on Shaai.
>> Yep. Fighter Flight just to save
Survivor. See this time and time again.
This also has the additional text when
saving Survivor this time of drawing a
card being on the Dreaming Tree.
>> Yeah, this is a game both players going
to have a ton of resources. Kises on
both sides, dreaming tree going on. Got
the traveling merchant making sure the
card flow is going real really well for
Daliawa.
That is something that really
incentivizes and pushes for the person
who is using all of their energy and
playing all of their cards every turn,
which is where Allen struggled to stay.
Just as it's not on the screen yet, the
point should be three-2 as of now. Shawn
in the lead. Darius going to come in
ready. Called out. This could be the
easy response if Kaisa had been pushed
back, but this is also just allowing an
easy cleanup of the merchant and for
Allen to push up to three as well.
>> We do have Allen at two. It is very
possible the arena greatest trigger was
missed and Allen didn't get his own
point in his uh bit of sadness of not
having a two drop. That would be an
extra brutal layer to this whole thing.
>> Would be a nightmare. We'll see if we
get confirmation on that going forward.
It's back over to Shawn with Allen.
Shields down.
A cleave for Shawn here would be really
great. Allow you to move in with your
Kai'Sa, draw a card off the Dreaming
Tree, conquer over the other Kai'Sa,
draw another card. really push that
advantage of not only am I up on points,
I'm up on cards and battlefield
presence. Without something like that,
maybe a bit of a tougher combat. Maybe
you have to trade Kaiser for Kai'Sa. Not
the most thrilling thing, but if you
can't get over the top of these other
units, you certainly don't want Allen
being able to bully you around with
keeping them and getting points.
>> Sean considering pushing in. I see a
couple of Dar I think I see two copies
of Darius in hand. It's one or two.
>> I think there are Dariuses, but no
cleaves or stack decks. Can't get them
accelerated this turn. A bit of a clunky
hand despite having a lot of filtering
and card draw going on.
>> Yeah, it felt like nothing really ties
it all together. Can just develop a
merchant. There's a VI looks like as
well. Sneaky deck hand. Some of these uh
small units really unhelpful against the
board of Allen.
>> I do see August, which is a one cost
play, but you can't play it on this
board. Unfortunately for the Darius. So
so close to being able to make a really
strong play with Darius here, but just a
little bit away.
>> Yeah. And for Shawn, he just says,
"Okay, well, I have these sneakys. I
have to do something. So I'm just going
to trade Kais so that I can get the
sneaky deck hand into the Dreaming
Tree." And it will just overall be a
development turn likely to drop maybe
just a two drop to follow up. And the
Darius will stick around for Allen.
Now it does have the Gust. So if the
Darius, you know, moves back to base,
two spells, tries to go into the
dreaming tree, can always gust your own
sneaky deck hand back to threaten the
other battlefield that is maybe left
open.
>> The gusted back end draw a card very
valuable in these spots. Often used
against your opponent as a tempo piece
in these Andy decks, but always have to
remember there is the ability to use it
on your own units. We often see that
through Annie Stubborn to actually get
another spell off of that card.
Also just yet another way to keep those
ever valuable vis useful and safe when
you have to send them to the
battlefields early
>> 100% as we do have Raven Bloom student
going to be committed to the arena's
greatest
Darius going to come home second card
will ready it and it may be exactly what
we expected to see. Darius
is going to be increased to 10 might
there moves into the deck hand. Shawn
has to decide if August is worthwhile to
trade it for another card.
>> I think if you're Shawn, you can have a
pretty good guess that Allen doesn't
have another card to play this turn
because Allen just cleaved before going
to the Dreaming Tree. Had to do it to
ready up that Darius. But if there was
another play coming, absolutely would
have chosen to do that first, move in
and be able to draw that card.
>> Yeah, and this is where the smoke
screens start to come into play. We
talked about how maybe Shawn's hand is
Darius heavy and so setting up for the
Darius turns where he tries to send in
and conquer over Allen's Darius Trafaren
and Allen student. Those smoke screens
are massive at dealing with Trafaren as
a threat.
>> Yeah, I mean minus four might a huge
amount of might. A Raven Bloom versus a
Darius with a single smoke screen is a
trade. You're don't even need anything
else to be going on. And that's a trade
I'm sure Allen is really happy to be
making now. let alone if there's a
second spell like a stupifier or
something that is cheap and easy and
cost you very little.
>> Allen scores the dreaming tree up to
four behind cadence of Shawn, but this
time he gets to keep up four runes with
action holding both battlefields and the
smoke screens drawn back to back early
on in this game. This is their time to
shine to try and show why they're in the
deck.
A lot of energy and a lot of options
here for Shawn. Do you play that Darius?
Do you take an action to get in there?
Are you afraid? Allen left up four
energy. That is a lot of tricks
possible. Again, thinking a void seeker,
hex tech, smokec screen, stupifies.
Darius on Allen's side could become a
seven. Raven Bloom student might be a
three, a four, or even a five if Allen's
hand is really low high on cheap spells.
I love this from Shawn. You send the
merchant first and say, "Allan, show me
a spell." Because this student won't get
stronger unless you show me the spell
now. And it can leave room for that
empty battlefield to be reconquered by
something like a sneaky deckhand that
was bounced back. And Allan, we know
there's the smoke screens. You kind of
want to hold that off. If there was a
ray, you'd maybe expend it and keep up
one smoke. But in this spot, you can't
afford to flinch and use a smoke screen
to try and defend that student.
>> Yeah, I feel like that attack gave Valer
a lot of knowledge about Allen's hand.
If this was a stupify, Allen probably
just plays it. It's so cheap, so easy to
do. And if you win that combat and your
Raven Bloom lives, great. You really are
able to block the sneaky deck hand, you
know, is in the hand.
So, since you know Allen knows, you have
the sneaky deck hand. Anything that
would keep you from being able to play
some of that battlefield really massive.
>> All right, Darius going to get played.
Vi going to get played.
Only one rune left. Just going to go
into arena's greatest. Not even going to
bother with Allen's interaction. Says,
"You know what? You've got four runes.
I'll respect it. I'm just going to try
and score this and call it good."
>> Yeah. I mean, my Darius is a seven. You
might have a smoke screen. That would be
really bad. You might even just have a
void seeker, but that would give you a
trade and allow you to use these runes
in your daughter of the void in a way
that I've now forced you to just not
spend your energy. Leave those cards in
your hand. Let me get back to being
ahead at five points. Not the magic six
number, but every point does matter.
This is the scary thing though for
Allen. I think he's happy anyway with
how that turn played out because he goes
to five with Darius on board. play two
cards and you can pivot over towards the
arena's greatest and try and deal with
Shawn's Darius. Now Shawn does still
have the three runes up. We saw a
fighter flight in hand that can be used
defensively in a spot like this to try
and prevent Kai'Sa from going to that
magic six points. This game, this
matchup is a race to six. No matter how
you slice it, usually Annie can't stop
Kai'Sa if she gets to six first and
Kai'Sa definitely can't stop Annie if
Annie gets to six first.
Yeah, a fight or flight here. Definitely
a huge deal. There's not an easy way for
Allen to really play around that outside
of the second Darius. Starting with one
cleave. Let's draw my card before I move
out of here. Might as well get it right
now. Then gets to back out and then play
that second card. Letting that Darius go
and now is a 10. Really forcing some
type of fight or flight or flash to
protect from Shan side.
>> Darius going to go home. What is the
second card? Eath rain.
This will deal with everything on the
board.
>> Yeah, I mean Annie is a deck that
doesn't really have a ton of recourse
against a Cathy and Rain. You can move
your units from battlefields, but you
can't even gusto if it's in your base,
even though it is a reaction. It only
hits battlefields. This is a spot that
is exactly how Allen wanted to set all
of this up. Scoring going to six,
threatening the wind next turn. Can do
the same Darius trick again.
>> And this is where Shawn says, you know
what? No, I can't let you get there. I
have to expend this fighter flight just
to buy myself time because Rain has
completely wiped out his board. His VI
is gone. He's lost his Darius, but he
still has a decent group of cards and
now he might still be able to push to
six before Allen can if he's got the
sneaky deck hand.
Really smart usage of the fighter
flight. Really aware of how the game is
going. You know, it is often a card you
are using to protect your units, but
also the game is about the points.
Sometimes you just have to use it to
say, "I need to protect one. This is the
one that matters. You don't go to six.
I'm gonna go to six. We both know I have
the sneaky deck hand from this Gust
earlier." And now the pressure is back
on Allen.
>> Yeah. And looking at the hand, I thought
I saw another sneaky deck hand as well.
There might just be the opportunity for
Shawn to get double sneakys out and keep
the flash available to move them back.
Try and keep some more pressure on the
board or even just play out Annie. go
for something like a fighter flight and
see if you can win off a hold if Allen
misses on the removal. It's going to
start with Annie. We'll see what card he
grabs. I feel like fighterflight is an
easy
>> putting that consider Annie into the
battlefield definitely makes me think
fighter flight is a likely choice. Just
getting a stack deck though possibly as
something else here to help protect. You
have two units there that's not going to
beat the Darius in combat, but that's
claiming, okay, I'm going to answer your
Darius, so you need two removal spells
to get these out of here.
holds the stack deck. Not going to cast
it on that turn. Keeping three runes up.
Threaten void seeker. Threaten more
at the magic six, but no Vi in hand, no
Darius in hand, none of the big units
that Shawn would need to actually finish
the game. So, as much as the race to six
has been won, the game is certainly not
over yet.
Not being able to find enough draws off
the Dreaming Tree so far to get there
and assemble the combo. But there's a
flash in hand and two units there.
That's going to net another card.
>> Could also see something potentially if
there's a ride the wind in hand. If
Darius is forced to go into that
dreaming tree, you're maybe able to
sneak that seventh point by moving over
and forcing Allen to have an answer to
that battlefields or you don't hold for
the win.
>> Yeah, and the way the game has gone, the
smoke screens, complete bricks, not able
to actually find any purchase. They can
be great into the Darius, but Shawn has
played around them beautifully. Never
going into combat with Allen when there
are runes up.
>> Yeah, really playing this with full
knowledge of the game plan. I want to
get the points. I'm not about beating
you in combat and destroying your
Darius. I don't care about your Darius.
I care about points and I'm going to
play to those and never let your cards
be maximum value.
Now Allan taking his time looking
through the trash for Shawn
trying to see what cards could be
available at this three rune total. What
does he have to play around? How can he
still hold on to win this game?
>> We've seen a little bit of a lot of the
tricks here. We saw a fight or flight.
We did see a flash. You know that Shawn
chose not to pick either of those up.
So, you got to imagine there's some
piece of another one of those in hand
because if there wasn't a fight or
flight in hand, there's such a high
likelihood Shawn would have just picked
that up with the Annie. Instead, it's
like, "No, I think I have most of the
pieces. I just need to find stack decks
to make sure I can close this out."
>> All right, falling star that can deal
with both of the threats currently on
the board. Flash won't matter, but it
will give Shawn a card.
Flash is no longer a useful card for
him. Drawing something on the top much
more valuable.
>> Up to six for Allen with the Darius into
Dreaming Tree. Stack deck just going to
be played on the showdown being rune
efficient.
>> Got to cash that in while you can. You
gain a lot of information. You know your
units are dead. You know, I probably
have to win this turn. Allen's going to
six and I can't stop him.
>> And now we talked about how those smoke
screens have been dead for much of this
game, but going into this final turn
that is representing minus 8 to whatever
tries to go into the Darius plus the
ability to send Darius up to seven by
playing two cards on the turn. So it
opens up a possibility where depending
on how big this trash is, which is
rather large, that you can actually
still deal with a VI ride the wind.
>> That trash looked to me be about 12
cards. That's only a 15 on the VI.
That's a really close number. If there's
a couple more cards there,
>> tie a double smoke screen.
>> And we talked so much about how
important how they how Kai'Sa can't beat
a VI ride the win with a big enough VI.
And Allen might be setting up to beat
exactly that.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I don't feel bad about
saying you can't beat it, but there's
just some exact combinations of cards
that get there in so many different
spots. This Kaiso deck so resilient
against even decks that are designed to
handle it, to beat it.
>> I really want to call out Allen here and
the resilience of this game. Started off
with a hand that was not that good. Did
not make a play on turn one while going
first while bringing your own arena's
greatest. and Shawn had the sneaky deck
hand. But this game is now six and six
with Allen threatening the win if Shawn
can't figure out how to answer this
Darius or put a win of his own on the
table. And that's despite everything
showing a V ride the win. And Allan,
yeah, show me.
>> Allan says, "Do it.
>> Let's uh let's go through the motions."
>> Yeah. Allan said, "Play it. Show make it
happen."
We might see Shawn have his heart broken
here. He definitely thinks he had the
game one in that moment. Or maybe just
wanted to see what could happen. That
looks like
>> Yeah. Allan said, "Show me." Allan said,
"Do it." Sean's like, "Are you are you
sure? Is this game not okay?"
>> All right.
>> You know,
>> and it's top eight. Even if you don't
have it, Allan, you make him do it.
>> I I got seven runes.
>> Seven runes. I can play so many things.
Let's, you know, three smoke screens.
>> There's the first one. Allan says, "You
know what? That's fine." Hey, you can
have the first one.
>> There we go. Plus
>> first one's free.
>> I imagine we're going to see this ride
the wind eaten as well to make it plus
13 or 15.
>> The two smoke screens is eight, but he's
still got runes on top of that,
>> right? Another three runes. A void
seeker is enough while not to beat the
VI, but to cause a trade, stopping Shawn
from winning the game here.
And Sean considering if he can actually
play any more cards.
>> Yeah. What are the possibility? How many
cards are in your hand? A lot of things
to go through. What are the pure
mutations that can beat this? There's
not a ton of them, but we we do know
Allen has two of those smoke screens,
and that is what you need to get started
on this math.
>> Start with Void Seeker
on to Darius.
It's going to draw an extra card.
>> One more into the trash. Plus one more
to that VI.
>> Vi goes in. We say this is it. All
right. Plus 16. She's a 19. Two smoke
screens in a Darius. That's going to be
15. Need another four. And for Shawn not
to have a cleave or anything like a
fight or flight.
See how it starts. This is top eight.
This is advancing to top four on the
line. So much money at each increase
from here on out. Fighting for 2 days.
Long grueling days of Riftbound. Allen,
a Legends of Rune Terra world champion,
trying to show his stuff in another Riot
TCG, whereas Shawn, the TCG mercenary,
coming to a new game that he's so
excited for to see if he can do it here
as well on the Annie deck that he and
his team cooked up over the last two
weeks that they believe is the best in
the format against the Kaisa that's
proven to be the best across Origin so
far.
Allan just has to do the math so many
times. Has to make sure this is the
situation. There's the first smoke
>> minus four. Take it away
smoke
minus 4.
Ready the Darius up to seven.
Currently 11
on this VI.
Four more might difference to make up
smokes
>> number three and that will reduce the VI
to sevens even and I saw a stupify in
the hand of Allen ZQ. The question is is
there action from Sha Dollywal? Two
runes remaining. It's not over yet as he
allows the trade to come through or he
pass action. Focus can come back to
Allen.
This is absolutely wild. Allen played
those smoke screens so close to his
chest this whole game. Had them from the
start and we said it right at the
beginning. Maybe this situation comes
up. Found the third smoke screen. That's
the only way this breaks down here. And
Allen lets the trade go through even
with the stupify in hand. I'm not sure
the rest of the cards, but just a porro
from Shawn. Allen afraid there of a
cleave. If he cleaves, if believe Shawn
has a cleave, he needs to bluff the hex
tech ray. Can't use the stupify to try
and blow out. Now he's found the ray. So
if Porro just tries to run in and end
the game, he at least has an answer. But
is there a unit for Allen to now try and
win? There's a Darius. That's one of the
best ones. It's hard to have something
bigger than that. That plus the ray on
this poor means it's really tough for
Shawn to win here even with an
accelerated unit of his own.
>> Stupify plus Ray in Allen's hand to deal
with this. We still have some rift bound
to play. Vide
out does not get it done into the Kaisa
that has historically been unable to
answer that combo.
>> Sean thought the same thing. He flashed
the VI, ride the wind, said, "Hey, are
you dead? Can we move on? Can I go to
top four?" And that is not what happened
here. And you can see he can't believe
that this game is still being played.
And the Ray will answer the poros
straight away. Shawn, no answer. Very
few cards remaining and card for card.
Annie lot less power than on the other
side, but it will be a deck hand.
>> Dehand meaning needed that hex tech ray
to not lose here. A Darius
>> going in
>> and Sean Dollywal
even after the V ride the wind is
answered.
>> The call of Darius from the top of the
deck he's able to take Annie to the top
four.
>> What an incredible match. You saw the
relief on Shawn's face after the game.
He slumped back so close to winning.
Thought he had it. Allen with triple
smoke screen. saw it slipping away, was
able to find that Darius to score the
last point. Absolutely incredible game
on both sides. Both players absolutely
knew what they needed to do to win. I am
at an absolute loss for words on this
one. I cannot believe that not only did
Allen overcome that big of a VI on the
ride, what was it? 19 something like
that. Minus 12. Yeah, 19 on the VI as a
Kaiseda deck with the three smoke screen
able to push through. I've got no more
words for it. So, let's hear from Shawn
himself after the win here in top eight.
Moving on to top four.
I'm standing by live. I cannot believe
the game I just watched featuring Dewali
on Annie.
Please explain to me how you're feeling
right now in this moment. Like uh I was
I was sitting there thinking like, okay,
I'm going to make my VI as big as
possible. 19. And before I went for it,
I was thinking, okay, if he has like
double smoke screen and like uh the hex
tech ray, I'm still okay. If he has
triple smoke screen or like double
smokec screen, stupify and a bolt or
something, then then I could lose. I'm
like, it's possible because of how he's
played, but it's like still pretty
unlikely. And then he had it and I
thought okay I lose the game you know uh
I played my little porro out. I'm like
whatever you know I have my Darius so
I'm thinking okay you know if I draw
like a ride the wind I have my Darius
maybe I can do something. I top deck
sneaky deck hand and I'm like I think as
soon as I drew it I'm like I think I win
because I don't think he has a bolt like
a second bolt. So I move my por he bolts
it. I play my sneaky deck hand and as
soon as he said yes I'm like okay Darius
let it in. And you know that game I only
won because he forgot the arena's
greatest trigger. Um and I had presented
that arena um in the in the second game
and I told him, "Do you want to just
both start at one, right? Like so we
don't have to remember." He's like, "No,
no, no. Let's let's remember." I'm like,
"Okay." So then in game three when he
presented it, he forgot his own trigger.
And he even mentioned in the game, he's
like, "The reason I like doing that is
because I I like punishing myself or my
opponent like, you know, if my opponent
missed it, it is." But he's like, "I I
like to if I forget, it's on me, you
know, and and that's one on me the
game." And it's just crazy. Like it's so
many things that game were just insane.
Yeah, I can't imagine how you're feeling
in this exact moment. You are competing.
You're in a top four now for the first
ever English Riftbound regional
qualifier. And you're not alone still
sporting Annie. You have more to go
through. You're still playing for best
of prizing here, Dewali. And the only
thing I really have to ask is obviously
you're very well known across card game
strategy in general. Is this just
another day at work for you or is are
you also feeling this tension?
>> Uh I I was kind of chill. Um, I'd say
like Friday and Saturday because I
showed up with like kind of like no
expectations. I played like two Nexus
nights and then like I started playing
Annie on Sunday and like my friends
trying to like you know show me the
deck. I had some judge calls game uh day
one because I just didn't know how the
game worked. Like I'm reading cards
asking what color certain cards are to
the judges cuz I don't know if they have
it or not. And like you know that's my
day and then somehow I'm in top four.
You know I'm just trying to play tight
keep you know hopefully drawing well. I
drew really well that game. So, you
know,
>> speaking of playing tight, I know you
have more to go through in the rest of
the tournament. Congratulations on your
top four right now, but we're going to
send it back and we have more Riftbound
to get through.
>> Shawn is such an incredible player and
competitor. I've had the privilege of,
you know, hanging out with him, playing
card games with him for for a very long
time as well. The whole PCG Invasion
team came out here, they built this
Annie deck. They told me, "Hey, we think
this is the best deck." I said, "Hey,
you guys really need to practice with
some top Kai'Sa players." And guess who
I got for them to practice with? It was
Allen ZQ. They got to test with him a
little bit coming in. And the fact that
they have to beat him in the top eight
to make that top four is insane. But we
still have more top eight action to go.
Aaron, we're going to be jumping into
game two of one of our other top eight
matches as it is Blard versus No
Veggies. Ye versus Annie. This time
around, we already have one Annie making
our way into the top four. There was an
opportunity for the four Annie top four.
Let's see if Blard can stop that from
happening.
>> Game two loading up to kick things off.
It looks like Yei found the first win.
Now we're going into game two. Oblisk
and Z Warren. And what's cool about this
is when the battlefields were flipped
and Nove saw Obisk, they said, "You know
what? Uh, yeah, I will still stay on the
play. I'll let you have your four runes
and I will have my sneaky deckhand to
score on that first turn.
>> Yeah, and a deck like master, you can't
really stop that sneaky deck hand from
holding without a board already. So,
that's almost a guaranteed two points
when you are Annie going first here.
>> Yeah, and Zon Warren's game two is also
an interesting adaptation from Nove.
Usually, we've just seen this as the
game one battlefield every single time
out of Annie Darkchild every just
because they're playing the scrap heaps
and then they board them out. But for
this one, Nove actually having the
warrants as the second game, so still
being able to potentially have those
scrap heaps works. Or I'm curious, maybe
it's a no scrap heap build. We are not
even sure exactly what Nove has brought.
>> This has definitely given me an option
of something I hadn't considered before,
which is if you think you're going to
play a lot of Annie Mirrors. It's
possible you're supposed to have your
scrap heaps in the board, board them in
game two with your own zon to have that
advantage.
>> Yeah, that's totally possible that we
could see something like that from Nove,
but they have made it all the way to the
top eight. going to start with the stack
deck. It looked like they grabbed the
reby to just do it again. We'll see if
that ends up being the case as it is
that nice early start of the two points
from the sneaky deck hand and just going
to be able to play out the Annie. But
this version of Yei not going to be the
Aurora that we've seen out of Clyde. It
is just going to be the low to the
ground early game. But I would imagine
there's a good bit of ramp into the dead
blooms and the white flames here for
Blur.
>> Yeah, playing that Annie picking up that
stack deck gives you a nice option here.
you send I have five might if you want
to come in you need a trick and then I
probably have a way to get you out uh
fight or flight or flash to save my
things but if you end up going just the
other battlefield I can just play this
stack deck if I don't think you're going
to be able to break into the zon warren
there it is just a push onto the obelisk
veggie
I think considering any action here
>> yeah there is a downside to the stack
deck which is then you don't have two up
and your opponent knows you don't have
the fight or flight and blar can double
trick up this clockwork keeper and break
into the zon which would be pretty
disastrous of a start.
>> Some runes turned by blur. Makes me feel
that they've already passed both and is
the case. A couple more two drops
deployed for Yi. Two keepers in the back
as Za's coming down a little bit flooded
on the early plays. Not exactly what you
want to see as a master Y. However, if
you can get them onto battlefields, they
are really annoying for Annie. She
doesn't do a great job at trading into
the fours and fives that you are getting
the value of from these twos. Yeah,
having something like a dead bloom
predator possibly next turn. A really
huge thing on this board. Maybe forces
Noveis to move out so it can't just be
played there directly. Though the
clockwork keepers still allow that if
you take the battlefield. The dead bloom
plus the hourglass means you need a lot
of tricks to keep pushing it out because
it's really hard for the Annie deck to
remove it through damage twice.
>> Yeah. And I mean, this was the matchup
in China that kept Annie away from the
top tables even though a lot of the
players were spouting how good they felt
Annie was. They knew this deck was
strong, but they couldn't get past the
Master Yi players. And Blur trying to
show that that is true. Whereas the
Annies, no veggies included, trying to
prove that false and show that they can
make it even further in this tournament.
But this board state is actually proving
to be quite tricky for Nove to navigate.
As you said, move away, prevent the dead
bloom. Now, these clockworks are fours,
and that's not easy to just push through
every time as Annie when most of your
units are very small and you're reliant
on just pushes and instead going to
stack up to equal the eight of the dead
bloom with some action available with
four runes at the end of the turn.
>> Yeah, people always say the any deck's
really strong, and it is. And part of
that is such high access to card
selection, things like these stack decks
and flowing through and and getting to
uh discard cards and draw new cards and
find things and build this combo. And
people will look up down on a deck like
Master Ease sometimes. Just kind of big
monsters and combat tricks. Really
simple, but sometimes really simple and
really powerful is all you need. And
that's how you get situations like this
one.
>> Yeah. And the dead bloom is eight, which
was played around beautifully here. But
this is 10 with the white flame coming
through on the clockwork keeper.
wondering what the action is for no
veggies. I see a rebuke, a flash, and a
ride the wind as options, but re
rebuking a Clockwork Keeper is not a
very exciting notion, even if it does
save you for now. Curious if it's just a
flash and sacrifice your sneaky deck
hand for this turn, but that looks like
a ride the wind potentially being
deployed as we did have one purple go to
the bottom. ride the wind the VI
that doesn't currently win against the
porro that's hanging out on the obelisk.
>> Yeah, this speaks of I have a cleave or
something else. I want to get this
point. Uh really highly valuing the VI
knows that is the way in the long run to
beat through this battlefield. If you
are able to cleave here and kill that
porro, you're probably pretty happy to
use make them use the hourglass on this
small unit rather than on something big
like that white flame protector.
>> Yeah. So we'll see as that conquer comes
through. The pending showdown will go
next, but Stalwart Porho in Master E is
a two for five, so it must be the
cleave. And you called it perfectly.
Cleave on Vi pushes to six. And Ye
playing the white flame this turn is
going to be completely tapped out. That
is just going to be a conquer and some
extra points on your opponent's turn.
And when your opponent is ramping, that
is exactly what you want to see for
Annie.
>> Yeah. So, we're going to see Annie go to
four points from this conquer, up to
five points from the hold. Gets to go
over and beat this Clockwork Keeper in
combat really easily with this VI. Get
to six without much trouble. And then
Blur's under the gun. Lots of pressure.
Fear of another VI if the first one
doesn't get removed.
This is a really tough spot. This is not
exactly how Blard wanted this turn to
play out.
>> Actually, you know, you you called this
perfectly and we see in the hand a flash
as well. So really this is set up
beautifully. You've got the assault
here. You score as you said go to four.
Now we get to go to five on the hold.
Use bare minimum from the trash to push
over the keeper because there's no
resources available for Yi. Now whenever
Yi tries to take it back, the flash is
there and the trash is still huge to
send the Vi again. So unless there's
something like what we see there in the
trash, a charm being able to be used to
deal with the Vi, she's safe. She's
protected and able to just push through.
>> Yeah. Even if there is a charm, that
doesn't work too well against the Annie
deck. Flash and fighter flight. I mean,
they can be a liability. Sometimes you
charm a unit into your battlefield and
you get kicked out by fight orflight and
they conquer. That is such a nightmare
scenario for BL. And I can believe
that's why this charm went to the trash.
>> Yeah, it has to be it would have to be
charm plus defy. And if you're missing
the defy, then the charm, as you said,
is maybe just fully a liability. You
cannot trust it. And that looks like
just a small judge call just dealing
with exactly how everything goes. But
this should just resolve as we talked
about Vi going over the top of this
Porro and setting Noveggies up for a
beautiful endgame.
>> Yeah, it all really depends on what the
remaining cards are in the hand. We've
seen a lot of stack decks from Nove, a
lot of ability to kind of really sculpt
the game plan. I would guess the tools
necessary are there but there's no
guarantee at this time. Also little low
on runes gonna have six. Can't play too
many things in any given turn. So there
is some hope from BL as well as the
potential to have things like defy in
hand in the future. The White Flame
Protector is large and if you're able to
counter a really important spell from
Nove
from the BL side what cards can actually
bail him out of this scenario as we know
most of Noveggi's hand having the flash
to answer any stubborn's already been
deployed So unless there's another ride
the wind, not going to be able to just
get that for free. So Vi is not ready to
immediately win from six.
>> Yeah, it feels like defy is the big
thing that has to be found.
>> The other thing BL could have is the
white fame protector at a battlefield
with the Wu Blade Master Legend. That's
going to be 10 might. Primal strength is
a trick that could exist. Plus seven,
really large. I mean, no veggies has a
pretty big trash. is gonna probably
spend a couple cards this turn to get
that VI over into the Z wards which will
put another card in the trash. But there
is a combination of enough tricks from
the Y decks that you can beat a thing
that large. We talked about Allen being
unable to beat Vide.
We didn't think he could do it. I don't
think Bard can do it either, but there
is a combination of cards that lets you.
>> No, you're right. And I think in in
green orange are actually way better
colors than blue red at actually dealing
with it. And if Allen can get rid of a
19 might vi coming through on the ride
the win, then I think Blard can do so
too. I think primal strength is is
definitely the big call. And also just
looking at this trash, this is not not
19. This VI is not nearly as big as we
saw earlier. So won't need quite the
crazy amount of tricks to actually
overcome the potential that can come
through on this VI.
>> No. And you can you're getting a lot of
value this game. We saw no veggies. I
think we saw stack deck for stack deck.
Just loading up that trash, putting
extra cards in there. It doesn't feel
like you're doing a lot. You're kind of
spinning your wheels, but you are every
time doing that, giving that future VI
plus one more might. And every single
might can matter against this E deck.
>> All right, looks like that is just going
to be a pass from Yi. Nothing left to
do. The hold up to five. Exactly as we
thought it would play out. And now Nove
just has to consider this next draw.
what it can add to the situation.
Just trying to get to six this turn
considering just going for three pushing
the VI up to six which is higher than it
needs to go.
>> Right.
>> Feel like you can do exacties with no
runes available. Are there any there's
no cards in yellow and or sorry green
and orange here uh common body that can
actually blow you out. So think this is
maybe some unnecessary safety and that
extra might may end up coming to haunt
Noveis later on as you only needed to
pump to five not six.
>> Yeah, possibly thinking that's a
stalwart for the two drops maybe getting
a little confused there seeing the
shield. I can't think of a reason you
would need to make this might extra
large this turn. uh
>> as that is going to be a flash put in
the bin
and a traveling merchant placed onto the
Z warrants going to bank on the other
pushes and potentially just look for a
hold rebuke and fighter flight in the
hand.
>> Yeah, I mean if you have a fighter
flight or rebuke for the protector,
there's only four might in play. Besides
that, that's not enough to beat the VI
and the traveling merchant. So you need
another trick or another large unit like
that mastery in the champ zone. But if
that gets played, there's only one
energy left for Blard saying maybe you
need an onguarding combination, but that
one just doesn't work super well cuz
these units are pretty stuck together.
>> All right, first thing is just going to
be stalwart going in scoring. Nothing
from Nove for that. Just looking to hold
on to the warrants.
Even if Nove is able to keep the hold,
if that Vi is removed, Blara is probably
pretty happy. Going to seven but not
having that unit that can gank over to
score that point. You're putting
pressure on Nove. Hey, do you have a
Darius? Do you have a Kai'Sa? Maybe you
can score that extra point. Maybe you
can't.
I can see a world where this combat ends
with we fight or flight our own vi and
try and save that so we can make another
big power play the following turn.
>> It's a hard puzzle for Yi, but a certain
point you just have to ask the Annie if
they have it. The answer currently is
yes. Fight or flight going to send the
white flame back home. Is there a defy?
Is there an answer? Warway to ready
units can also help in this spot
>> I think.
>> No veggies. Yeah, sending that white
flame back.
>> Big advantage towards Annie in this
spot. Not sure how Yi pushes over
through an additional rebuke that we
know is in hand. The normal answer here
is just to deploy yehoned and that looks
like it will be the play from Bl. Send
that in six into five.
>> This is the downside of sending in that
stalwart porro first. If you had that at
base with your clockwork keeper, you can
at least send both of those into this VI
removing it leaving the traveling
merchant, but you're not guaranteed to
lose on board like you are currently.
>> Yeah, currently just dead on board. One
rune left. Is there something like an
ong guard that can allow you to do the
same which is deal with the five but
leave the merchant or we just headed
towards a game three between blar and no
veggies
considering
if there's anything left for him to do
a charm here actually accomplishes
similar you can move the clockwork
keeper into that obelisk of power then
charm over the vi pretty good you don't
actually use the keeper almost forgot
the blade master for a second But I feel
like everyone does. That's a common
thing this whole weekend. Um but if
you're in that situation, I feel like
you are
>> even if you have the option to on guard
instead, you really are forced to use
something like that charm. You got to
get this vi off the table. Even if
there's a chance you get blown out and
you let your opponent conquer here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, if you have it, you have
to use it. I mean, there's no you you
lose if you pass the turn. And there is
a charm. Good call. The VI gets to head
over to the Obelisk of Power. And if
there is no cards for no veggies, which
there are not. Vi is gone. Trade the
keeper. So there's no material left for
Annie.
>> Doesn't even get the hold after all of
that work. Actually, BL ended up having
that turn go really, really well despite
the two effects, the rebuke and the
fighter flight making both big monsters
not really do anything.
>> Yeah, the charm was actually the perfect
answer. We talked about how you can get
blown out from it, but not this time as
it is going to be the sneaky deck hand
going in to the Z warren. One more draw
coming through.
Ride the wind cleave does not even get
there as this porro is all the way at a
five. And there are those scrap heaps
post. That's the opposite of most antex
flame must have it in the sideboard and
brought it in. But having to play the
sad scrap heap, you know, no veggies
just drew it. Just triggered the zon.
Pitched the porro. Sees the scrap heap.
Sigh. Yep. Plays it. Make sure he can
find some action for this next turn as
now there's the white flame. The Yei in
hand so it can come in ready again. And
now that window of opportunity to beat
the Yi may have been missed because of
the fact that that charm was there to
answer Gust to just try and bring back
the sneaky deck hand bling to allow that
to go through. I'm curious. I mean, I
guess really you have to keep the sneaky
at this point, but Gust onto Porro can
be quite valuable. It does seem though
we're at the point where Blar is just
playing big guys and pushing the Porro
back is not going to do enough.
>> Yeah, I mean Blar is now threatening the
win. We are at six. I have both
battlefields. I have a lot of might.
Really hard for Nove to score both
battlefields this turn outside of Vi
Ride the Wind. Putting a lot of pressure
on that. But Blair just passing with all
this energy. Highly suspect there's some
type of trick in here.
>> Yeah, at this point Yei is in a very
comfortable position. It is going to be
an answer to one of the big units with
the fading memories, but the Fi is there
and Nove has no further answers. And
Blur is going to push a Master Yi into
the top four.
>> No for Annie top four for us. Master Yi
enjoyers rejoice. I'm very excited to
see some of these more matches. I mean,
you were talking about how people did
think Annie had a bad Master E matchup
in that game. It did look like Annie was
really in control so much of that time
and then there was just that one turn.
had a rebuke, had a fighter flight,
still not enough to take over that turn
and blur able to remove all of the units
and then set up for a quick win after.
>> You can hit this point in the matchup as
Annie where there's nothing that you can
do about the holds and even just the
porro can be way too much. Five might is
more than your Kaiser survivor that you
love to accelerate over the small drops
in the early game and that can cause so
many issues. Yes, the rebukes, the
fighter flights, they allow you to take
this tempo game plan. This was very
close to Annie just winning immediately,
but the second the game is stabilized.
Ye becomes unstoppable for the Annie.
Yeah, I mean Annie, red and purple, you
have some things that answer big
monsters for a little bit of time.
You're not very good at removing them
permanently and eventually he's going to
keep playing them. You can only score so
many points. Eventually, these pouty
porros, these sneaky deck hands, all
these little units fall off really hard
in the game. And despite all your
filtering, despite all your card draw,
your cards just can't come together to
tackle such big creatures.
>> Yeah, I mean, it's crazy to see. And now
this top eight is looking real nice for
BL as he makes it into the top four. He
knows there's at least one Annie on the
other side of the bracket, but every
single matchup had an Annie in it. So,
if he can just keep playing Annies for
the rest of the day, that might be
exactly what he's looking for. and
especially because he knows if he won
this and the other Yi lost then he has
locked up the Yi card. So, we'll have to
see that soon enough. But we are going
to go to a break when we come back. We
will have that top four coming up here
at the Houston Regional Qualifier.
[Music]
That was sick. I'm really [__] bummed
that Allan Lawson.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Welcome back to the Houston Regional
Qualifier. I'm Kasanova joined by
Patrick Sullivan as we move towards the
top four. It has been crazy. The the the
Kai'Sa Annie game absolutely immaculate
moving forward. The Annie's still trying
to hold on and prove that they may be
the best deck in the room. And I just
can't wait to keep pushing on these
matches.
>> That was the biggest trade I've ever
seen. That that uh that Darius Vi with a
lot going on on the chain there. That
might be the single biggest clean
one-on-one trade I've ever seen in the
rift bound.
>> Yeah, incredible. And now we get to take
a look at the bracket to see where the
chips have fallen for this top four.
George falling to Annie. Three Annies
escape the top eight and we will not
have Kaisa as the winner of the Houston
regional qualifier. It will either be
Annie or Ye as Zent, Dewali, Primore,
and Blur have advanced to the top four.
>> Yeah. So, we have three copies of the
most uh aggressive low to the ground
really trying to even evade combat, I
would say. And then about as big as you
can get with Master Y.
>> Yeah. And realistically, when we talk
about history in China, Master Yi was
the blocker for Annie. The players there
said that the matchup could not be
solved for Annie and it was what kept
them from being able to find those top
placements on the Annie list. It's been
proven slightly otherwise when we come
here with three Annies in the top, but
Blur looks to prove that as close to
correct as possible by taking out the
remaining Annies and trying to become
the champion here.
>> So an inflection point for this
particular matchup is Darius. The builds
of Annie that don't include Darius, I
think, are at a major disadvantage
against Master Yi. Darius is the one
card that is still part of your core
game plan. It's about getting into
battlefields, scoring as many points as
possible, avoiding getting clipped on
the way back by retreating things. But
it's also something with enough size to
actually brawl with some of the stuff
that Master Y brings to the table. You
can see the Annie deck when things start
to fall apart, it's just because they
don't have enough size. there's not
enough mites on their units and once
those battlefields start getting locked
down, they don't really have a way to
get back in uh in excluding pushing
things out with a couple movement spells
here and there. Darius is actually
something that can go toe-to-toe with
some of the bigger units. So, that's a
card to keep an eye out for here.
>> Being able to get that seven, we got his
brother Draven in the sideboard for
Shawn Dollywal that we did see against
Allen's EQ. And that can even push
higher to get you the biggest possible
numbers. Imagine we'll push over some of
that 10ens that we get to see holding
from Master Yi. But our first matchup
will be Master Yi versus Annie in the
top four as we get to see if Blard can
continue this tear with the Wuju
Bladesman and try and face off against
all of these children in the top four.
>> Well, congratulations here to Blog. Uh,
as we mentioned before, one copy of
Master Y, three copies of Annie, meaning
>> that's the best. We have our master Yi
master of the weekend. And
>> there it is to kick things off. Players
jumping into action. Zon Warren's game
one for Annie as we are used to seeing.
Aspirin's climb. So we're playing den to
nine for this game and immobilize to
start as BL is on the play.
So important here for Primor to get off
to a fast start.
It's not a sneaky, but this is another
way that you can score on the first
turn. We didn't see a lot of Legion rear
guards in the annulus so far, but a
little bit of spice for Primor.
something different, having the access
to another accelerator or at least an an
actual accelerator where a sneaky deck
hand just kind of sneaks its way in uh
to start off this game at one point.
>> And you know, usually not ideal to be
accelerating this early and to be
recycling rooms this early, but I think
that Primer has a sense in the matchup
here that the long game does not favor
him. And the notion that a small
accelerate unit could be part of some
profitable combat down the road is very
unlikely. You're not going to do a whole
lot better than the opportunity to score
and to hold the following turn.
>> Yeah, it's two early points that you
wouldn't get any other way. And you're
on aspirin's climb. You have the full
nine points that you've got to get over.
and being on point cadence now by doing
this play with the sneaky deck hand
being found going up to three, you're
ready to go the 3579 that you need to do
to deal with Blur's Master Yi.
>> Yeah, it's nice to get presence at both
battlefields. So, these sort of bridge
turns that you're going to see from the
Master Yi deck trying to stabilize their
position, a lot of it is going to
involve being able to get into one
battlefield, not necessarily both. So
being able to hold here, that's a key
part of trying to get from three to that
critical range of seven where then
you're actually threatening be able to
win the game.
>> Once again, looking at the stack deck to
see what Primor can find. Fighter Flight
probably the most important card that
can be found at this moment. It's likely
that Blard can play one thing. We see
five runes. Master Yi honed is probably
the most likely play to happen from
Master Yi on this next turn. And if you
can push it back and go up to five,
you're buying yourself a lot of space.
>> Yeah, you want to be a Master Yi is so
important in the spot because you want
to threaten both battlefields, you you
know, but doing it one a turn and
allowing Primer to hold the entire time.
Not what you want to be doing. So even
if this does eat uh some sort of retreat
effect, at least you're forcing the
issue here and there's only so many
copies in the Annie list.
>> Yeah. And that is going to be exactly
what we see. And immediately Primar
reaches for the runes. It is flash. So
he does not have the best case scenario
for himself to deal with the Master Yi
and buy some more points. Just going to
move the rear guard back. But now Master
Yihoned is in position as essentially an
eight might defender with a Za's
hourglass to back it up.
>> And the critical thing there is, you
know, even if uh there you were able to,
you know, move your unit back to the
base there. It's only one point on the
hold this turn. That is critical for
breaking up that rhythm of the threat to
get to seven and then threatening nine.
>> Now another stack deck to try and find
the best answer. But now the rebuke or
fight or flight a little bit less
valuable. still nearly equal, right?
Because it's effectively the same
situation. You just had to expend a
flash as well to make it happen. And
you've let your opponent gain a point.
But realistically, Master Yi's points
almost don't matter in this matchup
because by the time that Master Yi can
score to try and win, you've probably
lost control of the game to way too far
gone of a degree. as we do have Darius
though and you were talking about how
this can potentially answer and go over
the top of the Master Yi. We do have
nine points of might on the back here
for Annie going up against just the
eight on the hold if he wants to try and
offer the trade.
>> Yeah, I mean that um this is not going
to be uh you know a clean trade exactly.
This is still better than the
alternative. You're scoring a point
here, but this is simply going to cause
the Yei to retreat or recall be recalled
to base.
>> Yeah. So, going to be recalled, but now
you get to rumage once more with the Z
warren. Look for the fighter flight, and
then we're back into that rhythm of,
hey, I'm holding both battlefields. You
try and send something in, and now I've
got the push.
>> I I do think that was a really good call
out that you made about the point total
not really mastering mattering that much
from the master Y side. It is that is
basically mopping up after you have won
effectively won the game by locking out
the battlefields.
>> Let's see what Blur has to offer now.
The master Yi on seven runes means that
now you have eight available. So a dead
bloom can come out after this push if
that's what you've got. So either a defy
or a dead bloom can be absolutely
devastating for Primor as he is going to
offer the fight or flight to try and
stop Hon
getting him off the point as he can go
to seven if there is no big unit to come
out. White flames don't do enough
against Annie. It is the dead bloom
predators that you need to find.
>> Yeah, that's a huge one here that would
really start establishing some sort of
defensive posture on one of the
battlefields. It would prevent a whole
point. You'd kill a unit for your
trouble. That's really the play you
would want here.
It is going to be another unit that can
be accelerated. Tasty Fay Folk does
work. Going to spend all eight runes.
But now that Annie is completely running
on empty, you can establish another hold
of eight might. It is very difficult for
Annie to get above that. We already saw
Adarius having to be sacrificed to the
grinder to get there.
>> Yeah, the sleeper hold is starting
starting to be cinched in here.
Uh primer needs to be able to try to
make progress on both battlefields. Uh
the master u deck is so dominant from
this position. ton of energy to work
with two huge units and all of that sort
of hopping around from battlefield to
battlefield retreating to base. It's
doesn't work once you get to this point
where you can't engage at all and primer
is at risk of that happening starting
next turn.
>> Yeah, and only three cards in hand. Not
finding any of the scrap heaps to kind
of build the card advantage on this on
Warren just yet. I think another thing
to think about for this turn for Primor
and why he's immediately going into the
tank is if there's a way for him to go
to seven, he must uh because VI ride the
wind even though there is counterplay on
the side of Master Y with defy or even
you know as Aaron was bringing up in the
last round the ability to just pump
something over the Vi with something
like a primal strength that is your win
condition from here on the aspirin
climb. need to find a way to get to
seven so that you even have an out as we
get later into the game.
>> Exactly. And we've got, you know, one
battlefield here that's uncontested
right now. Primer wants to move in, can
take it. And that's great.
Unfortunately, that only moves to six.
If you want to get to that seventh point
that you're you're talking about this
turn, you are going to have to get the
contested battlefield as well. And then
at that point, you have ride the win
plus five. its potential to go over the
top of almost any sort of defensive
position that uh Blair can muster here,
but it's all predicated on getting to
that seventh point in the first place.
>> All right, it's just going to be sneaky
deck hand onto the aspirin's climb and
that means just six, not seven for this
turn.
And now Primor is behind.
>> Really speaks to how important
battlefield selection is in this game.
This is a very very different looking
game playing to eight. Nine is asking a
lot here out of Primmore.
>> It is just going to be a stacked deck in
response to the master Yhon coming in to
deal with the sneaky deck hand. Rhymore
happy to sacrifice a sneaky deck hand
for a point but not happy with the
situation of the game now. Eight might
going to be on both sides for Blar to
hold and so many runes to work with.
Blur reasonably doesn't even have to
play another card this turn. Could just
sit on two eight might units and a grip
of whatever tricks could possibly be
there.
>> Yeah, at this point the spells are
actually more valuable than the units.
You have a dominating presence. It is
just trying to break up any sort of VI
combos.
The uh the stuff on the margins here,
it's great. Add a unit if it if you're
still able to leave whatever trick up
that you have here. But from this point
on, BL really just wants to find spells.
That's the key thing here. Going to be
really impossible for for Primer to
break up what's going on if Blard can
play back against any sort of movement
effect or reading effect.
>> Yeah. And actually I I want to call it I
think it is this is the turn to play
this dead bloom because after this if
primer has the ability to push some of
these units back and go up to eight now
you have even more value on the next
turn where primer actually can look to
end the game to keep up as many runes
for spells as possible to never let that
actually happen and you wouldn't have
maybe another time where this dead bloom
can actually hit the board. Yeah, you
want to get basically you want to get in
a spot here where where Primer is, but
it will require additional help to be
able to conquer either battlefield as it
stands right now.
>> If something gets left over on Primer's
side, be it because you push something
out with a movement effect or you have
enough pump spells to go way over the
top of wherever you're going to, you
want to have that attacker back to be
able to clear that out. And if primer
has another movement effect, whatever.
That's not really that big of a deal.
You're gonna at at a certain point
primer is just going to run out of cards
in hand. A lot of things are being
demanded. This is a huge stress test.
Both having uh the requisite number of
units, the ability to get through big
stuff, the movement effects in case one
battlefield effectively gets locked out.
>> Yeah, this is a a crazy spot that
Primary is in when you are pushing your
Annie to a battlefield just to gust it.
uh because you need to find anything
else and you've been missing the spells
you want even in this bin. I mean, fight
orflight is the one I'd expect or it's
just another stack deck to keep digging
through.
Now, keep in mind here again, we're
playing in nine while Blur has both
Battlefield held up here. Primer may be
able to go over the top and Blur is also
now a turn back ostensibly from being
able to win the game because he's
holding to six and then holding the
eight. Under normal circumstances,
that's game over. But playing to nine
here, Blog actually needs to hold off
for another turn. The aspirin's climb is
certainly better for Blog on the
balance, but it does cut both ways here.
And BL's going to have to be able to
play defense for an additional turn that
he otherwise wouldn't have to.
>> And this was big. I mean, Blard
recognizing just how much pain Primer is
in right now, trying to play the Annie,
bounce it back with the Gust, get the
fighter flight, and Bl says, "You know
what? I just have this defy. I'll wait
until you show me what spell you want.
I'll wait for you to use it, and then
I'm just going to get rid of it." Defies
the push and gives another turn where
Primer is not able to go to seven and
start threatening the win. And that
might be enough time to try and seal
things up.
>> Really powerful heristic here from Blur.
Any spell that you cast that is
effectively worth a point that I will
counter. Anything that isn't about that,
you can have it.
>> I think that makes a lot of sense as he
does now swap in the dead bloom predator
for the tasty fay folk. Valuing the
might instead of the trigger. He says
we're past the point where a tasty folk
death nail trigger is something I even
am thinking about or care about. It is
now just the most might and the most
annoyance on the board as Vi is found
for primer. The bin is pretty large, but
is there a ride the wind to go straight
away? I'm going to imagine so with him
already counting what is in the trash.
>> Seems very unlikely that you would
deploy VI unless you were already ready
to go.
>> Yeah. And the thing is is this might not
even be enough might to deal with all
the energy that is available.
>> Yeah. Clarifying, you don't actually
have to shuffle here because you can
just trigger the VI one at a time in
whatever order you want to. Very rarely
matters regardless. We're not going to
be playing long enough for to get back
to the bottom of the deck, but
going to be playing a cleave onto the
VI.
This is a lot of commitment already.
And the ride the wind can just get
defied if Blur has it, which would
probably just say the game is
immediately over. But even if this all
resolves and Primer can clear both
units,
it still might not lead to a win because
this will only go to eight. And Blard
does have a Za's hourglass and a Tasty
Fay Folk at home to try and retake.
>> Yeah, even if you're able to get all of
this to happen successfully, it's hard
to imagine being able to fire a second
time. And rune prison is immediately an
answer to the VI to prevent this from
happening for Primor. And this is the
main board for Master Y having the Rune
Prison ready to go. Often a sideboard
tech to deal with the mirror to deal
with set brawler and other orange decks,
but also works beautifully in a meta
that is evolving to have so much Annie.
Rune Prison adds to the amount of
answers this deck has. Defy already
deals with it. Rune Prison now deals
with it. And sometimes you just have the
amount of pumps you need to get over it.
>> It's maybe not as strong in an overall
sense as cards like Falling Star or
Singularity. However, there is a place
and a time where this is the most
efficient interaction that the game has
to offer. And Vyide the Win is at the
top of that list. Great metacame call
for this weekend. You got to be really
thrilled getting to this point seeing
three copies of Annie throughout the the
remainder of the top four and knowing
that your metag game call here has paid
off.
>> Yeah, he's beautifully teched for it in
a matchup that historically has been
good for his deck
in a top four with only this matchup
remaining and a masterass to kick things
off. Primar once again starting off fast
though at the two points out the gates
and now we don't play to nine anymore.
So it does open the door a little bit as
this is an accelerated Kai'Sa to get
more cards rolling and another point
going for Primer
not really caring too much about the
cards being drawn here again just trying
to go so far over the top not really
about incremental exchanges trying to
just set up locked up battlefields
just to find your center. Lots of ramp
in this version. We've talked about
different versions of Yei. There's
Aurora, there's more of the mid-range,
and then there's what was lovingly
called out of China Plant Ye, which was
named after the Tasty Fay folk, and it
was playing around the Find Your
Centers. It would maybe have catalyst,
but it would definitely have the Fay
folks and the Find Your Centers. But
we've seen mobilize out of Blur. We've
seen I believe catalyst out of Blur and
maybe that may have been a different Y.
I might be going crazy, but at least
find your center mobilize and Tasty Fay
folk in this match that we've seen. So,
a lot of ramp coming out from Var. And I
would I would call this eggplant ye.
>> Yeah, it's interesting to cuz to me the
ramp spells are, you know, the obviously
there's a wide array that all have their
pros and cons. An interesting dimension
to me is
>> I think the first copy of any of them is
better than the second copy of any of
them. So you do want to kind of have a a
bit of a spread.
>> Yeah, for sure. It's possible that those
ratios could be really spread out as
well. And the thing the strength of this
version of Yi versus the others is you
get to maintain the two drops and the
power that you get out of things like
stalwart porro being a five versus the
Aurora deck that has to cut these in
favor of only having the top end. But
you still get the strength of playing
the dead bloom predators and the white
flames that you see out of the Aurora
deck.
>> And speaking of uh Predator here, you're
going to see a retreat here from Primer.
It's painful to do, but if you don't
have any way of engaging with it, you
just got to pull everything back cuz
you're just going to lose you're going
to be down uh a point and a unit as a
result.
>> Yet another way to answer via Ride the
Wind in this deck, Sabotage. You can
find the Ride the Wind, send it to the
bottom of the deck. Sabotage uniquely
recycles, not discards. So Annie
stubborn can't even grab it back later.
>> Yeah, it's nice to have the recycle
there for the the Annie consideration as
you're mentioning. It does kind of put
BL under a burden to get the game over
with. This is obviously this is great
for picking apart that combo, but you
still can't stop the top of the deck and
primer's playing with stack decks to
boot. So you are going to want to pair
things like discard along with getting
the game over with trying to shrink down
the number of draws your opponent has to
find backup copies.
>> Yeah, easy choice for BL to get rid of
the fighter flight with the sabotage.
Really the key cards in the matchup when
you're trying to get through Annie are
going to be the fighter flights, the
ride the winds, the rebukes, anything
that is pushing your units away since
you have such a massive might advantage.
and Stalwart Porro going to take up
residence in the dreaming tree. Try and
set for Blur to be able to draw more
cards later. But it is also going to be
a commitment of Master Yhoned. So
valuing getting on both boards and just
presenting the most amount of might for
Primer to have to deal with.
Ah, see they I think didn't really open
the showdown and resolve it properly. So
just allowing Primer his window that he
should have been given. Uh happens
sometimes with the game when you're
shortcutting a lot when both players
kind of know what's happening and
>> just making sure that Primer does have a
chance to actually respond, not blowing
past it.
So the good news from premer side is
uncontested threatening the magic
number. Any unit he wants, he can sneak
over to the the dreaming tree, pick up
point number six. The downside here is
we are pretty far away from Vi plus ride
the whip. We saw the hand, none of the
pieces. And in fact, the the trash isn't
even that stocked right now. So, even if
you were to assemble the combo, it's not
clear it would be able to push through
Blur's defenses should we get to the
next turn.
But
Blark does need to catch up to the
uncontested battlefield here or I guess
now the one that's controlled by Primer.
>> And this is the big positive of Master
Yihon having that ganking always being
able to threaten over to the other side
when necessary. As for now, Primer just
developing as much might as possible and
is going to be able to send nine might
into Master Yihon to try and deal with
it. The trade's going to happen.
>> Huge for Primer going to seven. Master
Yi does not do well at conquering both
battlefields from hand to try and
prevent a hold. really good fork for
Primer to set up to try and take this
game two and bring us to a final game in
this series.
>> And you just saw why Darius shifts
around the dynamics of this match up
quite a bit. A lot of the Annie builds
that don't have Darius, they just can't
get out of a unit that large without
moving it back to base. Primer actually
just won a combat straight up. And as
you mentioned, this deck from an empty
board is not very good at contesting
both battlefields at the same time. And
primer only needs the one
>> thinking through the options. But when I
think about this version of Master Y,
the way you're able to get on board
at in a single turn is dead bloom
predator. It's Tasty Fay Folk
Accelerated and it's Master Yihon from
the champ zone.
>> There's really
nothing else that quickly goes in. Some
of these builds had first mates, but
those are more the mid-range ones
playing around Kiana and not so heavy
leaning into the ramp. And we've seen a
significant amount of ramp from Blar
that leads me to believe that first
mates and some of these kind of
mid-range units are not going to be
included.
Dead Bloom, Dead Bloom charm would work.
>> Yes.
>> Rebuke though to respond. There's
nothing that can answer that. He's going
to clean it up. We're going to a game
three.
>> Very nice stuff there from Primer. Uh
Rebuke out of the sideboard. Obviously
huge in this matchup. Um
able to get off to a fast start. Uh
Borg, I think really the inflection
point for me in that game was the find
your center as opposed to a play that
impacted the board. Not to say that he
had anything in hand. I'm sure he was
making the best of it, but that was
really where uh he fell behind and never
got close to catching up.
>> Yeah. And now for our third and final
game, Arena's greatest not on the play
for Primer, but it can work really well
with a sneaky deck hand as Blur is going
to take us to Vom's layer, which is
really great tech for purple deck. So
once again, showing the respect towards
Annie as when you get your unit in, it
can't be fighter flighted away back to
base. Var's reading, you cannot move
from here to base,
>> right? and and vile moder is an ideal
battlefield for Blor to simply dominate
that as so much of primer's counterplay
does not work against that. So we'll see
if that is enough in this final game as
of course the arena's greatest is a
scary thing to have to deal with anyways
as the Annie is going to get that one
early point while you're still trying to
ramp up. But I have to say getting that
catalyst and I guess we do see the
catalyst. See, one piece of each ramp so
far for Blur means that he is one turn
away from just dropping a dead bloom on
Primer's head.
>> During the uh developer Nexus night, I
played Annie, you know, deck someone
made for me. My opponent bust out Vols
and uh it was not pretty. I was not
really well suited to engage with that
battlefield, let's say.
>> Yeah, it can be very difficult. You
can't push them out. You can't flash
away. You can't even just retreat the
oldfashioned way to get out of there.
You truly are stuck in the spider's web
as we are going to see one copy of Vi
thrown away. Not good enough in the
early stages. The cleave will push over
the clockwork. Not quite as good as the
porro, just a four, not a five. And it
is just going to be Kai'Sa played at
home. Two runes ready for the dark child
ability. And we're pushing back over to
the 8 rune break point for BL, which is
often just master Y, so you can go to
nine runes on the next turn. Nine is
that magic number where you can play a
dead bloom and keep up a defy or an ong
guard or a charm or any kind of
interaction at that one cost.
>> And Vom's Lair is is so good with the
Predator, too, because you saw in one of
the earlier games, Primer says, "Okay,
this turn I have a lot of exposure. I'm
going to just pull everything back so it
I don't get hit by this, you know, proxy
accelerate unit. Can't do that with vile
mausair. Anything that gets committed
there is then stuck and uh the predator
is a very very dominating card at that
battlefield.
>> Yeah, and I mean we talk about how the
point total often doesn't matter for
Master Yi, but we're at two for Annie,
four for Yi. This kind of a spread means
that primer actually starts to run out
of time and becomes pressured to find a
way to deal with the board. And that is
not a good spot to be as Annie because
usually you have time. You have all the
time in the world to put together one
final push to beat the board. Now it's
you have to scrap together a push and
even after that you still have to find a
way to score the points.
>> Yeah. And I think BL is playing this
really well in so far as just saying
like look, if you want to go into Vom's
layer, be my guest. I'm going to
absolutely dominate you there because I
have so many accelerate units, so many
large units, and your tricks just don't
work. Everything that is kind of on the
margins here that Blog is going to do is
going to be about controlling the other
battlefield. Val's layer to a certain
extent is going to take care of itself.
that that is so advantageous for BL that
he's going to invest kind of the the
ancillary resources just to the other
battlefield.
>> Yeah. And there's Darius to follow up
the stack deck. This will be able to
push over Master Yihoned with the
Kai'Sa.
One rune left. I haven't seen an ong
guard yet. It's mostly been the Defies
and the charms that come from here. And
Blar has been relatively happy to just
trade the Yei with the Darius when this
happens.
Yeah, I mean at this point BL's probably
working with uh
enough resources such that the
compulsion to spend a resource this turn
just for the sake of it being efficient
is probably not that big of a deal. I
would assume that Blogger is just trying
to set up a dominating spot where
eventually whatever trick is in hand
results in a one combat or a prevention
of a point being scored.
We see Kai'Sa being picked instead of
Darius to clear to prevent the draw.
Dead Bloom Predator going to hit the
table. It beats five and four the same.
But the question is does Primer have the
rebuke once again to buy time? This time
though, not enough points for Rebuke to
end the game. So, it is a costly spell.
Minus three runes when used on a dead
bloom predator due to that deflect.
>> At the same time, it doesn't really seem
tenable to just let this happen. At what
point, you know, your your rebuke is at
its best. The more that you are on the
front foot, you allow this combat to
resolve as it stands. You might not get
on the front foot again. So, I agree
with you. It's a It is an iron price to
pay, but I do believe if there if Rebuke
is available, you you are not likely to
get a window better than this one.
>> Yeah, I completely agree. It looks like
in the hand I see a rebuke and a ride
the wind. So, that may be the
consideration is do I ride the wind my
Darius over to Viles? Because then you
can't move the Darius back again. It it
gets trapped in the layer and the ride
the wind would usually be your way to
get it out. I I think that uh Primer is
as much as possible reticent to move any
premium unit into Von's layer. If you're
talking about sneaky attack hands to
score a point here or there, that's a
different that's a whole different
kettle of fish. Go ahead and do that.
When you commit something like Darius
over there, that thing is not coming out
and it's unlikely to hold. That is a
huge investment. So, normally in this
circumstance, ride the wind over onto
the open battlefield. That's a great
play. You score the point, everyone's
happy.
>> It is going to be the ride the wind is
the choice. I think I'm with you where I
like the Rebuke more here, but Primer
has had so much success through this
game. Not able to get it through. And
this is the other reason the Rebuke can
be better. The Defy is deployed and
deals with the Ride the Wind. Rebuke is
undefiable due to the two power cost.
Yeah, I'm I'm sure you know, Primer's
been playing this deck to great success
all weekend. So, I'm not here to be
critical of the play necessarily. I'm
sure he weighed the variables of of
trying to rebuke versus ride the win
there, but that was going to be a kind
of a a tricky spot regardless. It's
either going to have to recycle three
runes and stave off the inevitable for
maybe a turn or uh in the best case
scenario move a premium unit into vile
mos layer and at the worst walk into a a
defy
and this time having deploy any stubborn
for a stack deck once more. We've seen
it time and time again this series. If
you're in a good spot, you're wanting
this to be grabbing rebuke back to
finish the game or fighter flight to
finish the game. Grabbing stack deck
just means you are in a world of
trouble.
>> Looking for help and maybe trying to set
up a combination of of vi plus ride the
wind. But you know only have three
points here. So you have so much work to
do before we can even talk about that
being a sequence that can win the game.
and Blair getting to have the dead bloom
stick untap with eight once again to
continue to either develop the board or
keep up tricks. But we've seen time and
time again this becomes a spot for
development. So many one costs being
able to be used. The charms, the defies,
the eggplant could come out just to
develop some board presence.
You know, you would like to accelerate
the clock a little bit here. You would
also like to establish some sort of
position in the Vile Mos layer if you're
on BL side because, you know, uh, Primer
is reticent to engage with it for the
obvious reasons. But the more time
pressure that you put him under by
threatening to hold into the wind, at a
certain point, something's got to give.
He's got to get in there and and you
know try to actually win a combat have
something left over at which point your
follow-ups on the way back are going to
be very hard to overcome.
>> Yeah. And once again, Blar in the spot
where he's got kind of this point lead.
He's not afraid of losing. And so I I
like develop it when you when you're not
going to immediately lose to your
opponent just dropping one spell and
pushing in. you have this space to kind
of create that bigger board and then
you're able to beat more of these
different outcomes that the Annie can
create with her slew of spells put in
the deck to beat you. This was a matchup
that was on the forefront of many
Annie's minds coming into the event
knowing that this was a tough one that
they needed to be able to overcome.
>> And you have so much cushion right now
in Blark spot. you know, one primer
doesn't really even get anything going
in reality until they're at six and now
that from there the sequences start
opening up here. It's, you know, to make
any sort of inroads at all, Primary is
either going to have to invest a lot
into combat to conquer the very
contested one or start throwing things
into Vaw's layer, which is so easy for
Blard to clear up on the way back. And
and honestly, I mean, Blur's probably
happy to just move into Vabon's layer
with something large to say, "Okay, now
I'm threatening to hold. You want to
come back in here? Even if you win the
combat, you're so unlikely to hold the
following turn cuz your tricks don't
work." So, just squeezed from a bunch of
different dimensions here.
>> And we see in this spot, Primer actually
dumps a rebuke. He's got a second one in
hand, so I can kind of understand the
redundancy, but I also think is double
rebuke actually the way that you can
maybe find a win in this game. Do you
need all of those pushes? Because it
feels like the only thing effective into
these massive boards is fighterflight
can buy the space to at least score once
more if primer wants to try and push in
with the Annie. And I I assume that has
to be the case or else there's no reason
to have casted this. I I would assume
that part of it is there's not really a
m a material difference between uh
pushing back to base and bouncing
specifically the predator because if you
bounce it goes okay I'll put it all
layer that's contested right now you're
not really getting that far and you are
expending a lot of resources. Now, it's
an interesting question of like how is
that the worst card in his hand given
how you have to assume that's part of
the sequence to be able to squeeze this
out? Just involves a lot of bouncing and
pushing back to base. So, what is left
over in hand?
>> Yeah, I want to see how this sequence
comes together, right? Three cards left
for Primer. He is down on points. He
doesn't have the six to try and push in
and end the game. Blur is going to be
putting him on lethal on this last turn.
So he needs to put together a combo that
clears the board and gets him control of
the battlefields in a way that Blard
can't just immediately come in and end.
And that seems really hardressed to do.
But we know it starts with one rebuke in
hand. And what is the rest? Is Vi ride
the wind something that he's been able
to put together and can try and use to
finish this off as the dead bloom
predator is just going to run into
Annie. This one you probably have to let
go and save the rebuke for the white
flame protector.
So ride the wind into the predator.
This is hoping Blur cannot interact with
you. I like the idea. This is the only
way that you can get into a winning
position for the next turn by scoring to
six. So if you ride the wind and bounce
the predator, you're at least at six to
find exactly why I ride the wind to end.
>> It's a very very uh uh unorthodox play
here. But again, as you're you're
talking about primer is not going to win
this game going conventional blow
forblow. You got to try find a way to
sneak a point here and at least threaten
the ability to win the following turn
because you're not going to be able
you're not going to be able to win this
game by saying I hold to eight. It is
going to involve conquering both
battlefields in the same turn.
>> Also, Primer would get a for whatever
it's worth a discard and draw for his
trouble. So, if you're missing a piece
>> or the worst card in your hand is not
that helpful, it's at least something.
>> Yeah, I mean this is rebuke plus one. So
assuming that the line is to ride the
wind, well it must be to the
battlefield. It can't be to base from
Vile Mos,
>> then this is ditch the other card to try
and dig towards the combo. Rebuke the
dead bloom. And then you've got one more
move on the next turn after a
theoretical hold to continue from there.
But actually there wouldn't be a hold
cuz dead bloom gets to be played back on
to your traveling merchant. So really
it's one dig here and then one draw and
hope that that is V ride the wind as
your wind con as you're out
>> and remember this is all happening with
Bark sitting on five or six cards and
any any sort of stun any sort of
movement effect that's probably going to
be too much
>> but primer is you know just playing to
his outs like you got to if you can only
win by AB C and D happening then you
just play like that's the top of your
deck and those are the cards in your
opponent's hand.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, I think this is a cool
puzzle that Primer has solved as, hey,
I'm losing. This is how I can win and
now it's just how the chips fall and
Blur has to think about the best way to
disrupt this because maybe there's just
a defy here and you can just defy. But
the other option is if you see through
the line and you see a rebuke coming,
you know, you can just replay the dead
bloom. So, there's the move.
There's the discard.
We don't see the draw. We won't know if
he's found what he wants just yet. The
score from the white flame
is now a stacked deck will be played.
Make sure we're stacking the right deck.
>> We'll move over to the rune pile.
>> Another stack deck. Mhm.
>> I mean, if you're trying to find the
pieces of the puzzle, stack deck is a
way that you can kind of get there, but
primer's not looking too happy with
these draws.
>> And keep in mind, this is going to be
two cards in hand plus draw steps. So,
it's a very specific sequence of things
that is needed. And
this even assumes that Primer is somehow
winning this combat, which is not
looking likely.
>> Yeah, cuz it has to be the rebuke. So
it's it's exactly the one card off of
stack deck and then the draw step that
has to be vi ride the wind. And so
unless that's what he saw off of that
second stack deck, that final stack
deck,
then he's not going to have the juice to
to push this through.
>> We still got a draw step. We got one in
hand and one on top with if we need
exactly two cards, it's possible. Again,
this gets blown up by pretty much
anything, but give Primer credit seeing
the line. Even if it's low odds, this is
the best shot at being able to steal
this one.
>> Yeah, I mean, and Blark is just
thinking, okay, well, if you conquer
here, you do go to six. He's probably
considering yes, Vyide the Wind is the
thing that beats me here. Unless does my
hand beat Vyide the Wind through this
amount of cards which we saw the rune
prison rune prison just answers just
answers.
>> And remember that primer is going to be
on exactly two cards in hand. So even if
he has it, there's no way that he has
something to play back against
interaction.
>> And I guess to be fair, that means dead
bloom would not be able to be just
played down if he wanted to keep
interaction. So, Dead Bloom reging this.
He already scored that Battlefield. I
don't think that's how it works. Am I
wrong?
>> Well, we're back here in the booth.
Hello. How you doing? That was
semi-final number one. Congratulations.
>> Yeah, cuz you scored that on the hold,
right? So, that should not be
>> I don't think
>> whatever Whatever it is is whatever it
is. The the the blessings of live
television. We'll be heading down to our
uh second semi-final match here. Just a
moment.
>> Yeah. But good stuff there. Pretty fun.
had a good time watching it. Not
entirely sure what happened at the end
there, but you know, we got another
match coming.
>> Yeah, I mean, I guess I I I suppose uh
they thought he scored on that conquer
and he won the game. No correction.
That's
>> doesn't matter. Doesn't matter. That's
>> Mark is moving on to the grand finals
with Master Ye slays an Annie. One more
to go for him cuz our other match ups an
Annie Mirror. So, if we get that Annie,
I don't know if that's ready. We'll tell
they'll tell us when it's ready, but we
can I mean we can talk a little bit
about the antimir. We'll move on. We'll
go to the antimeir. We'll talk about
that.
>> Okay,
>> that feels it's just a race.
>> Yes,
>> it is just a race. But the cool thing
about the matchup is that there is
interaction for the viride to win. So,
it's not just get to six and then
there's no way to stop it, right? There
is a way to kind of play back and forth,
but it is absolutely a points race. It
is an arms race and it is a matter of
denying points when you can and scoring
them as fast as possible which is a very
distilled way to just even talk about
riftbound but it just comes to a head in
an Annie mirror.
>> Well, it's interesting because you know
there's so much scrutiny and emphasis
put on viide the win and partially
because that combination of cards is so
good against Kai'Sa. They really can't
hold Battlefields very well. Leather
interaction doesn't work against it.
Video the win is also kind of you're out
so to speak when uh the battlefield gets
so mucked up that there's no way to win
in a conventional manner anymore. You're
just going over the top. Neither of
those things are really applicable here.
It's not a matchup that's about breaking
up some stalemated battlefield. There's
a a race to score as you mentioned.
Going first is a very substantial
advantage. And from there, you're just
trying to prevent your opponent from
ever uh winning a very profitable
exchange or conquering both battlefields
in the same turn. So, this is actually a
matchup that for all the uh power that
we've seen over the course of this
weekend from Vive Ride the Wind, it's
not really so much about that here.
>> Yeah, for sure. And it is going to be
Shawn Dolly on the play with Z Warren
start. The scrap peeps in Zent starts
Dreaming Tree. So there is a
consideration once again on do you keep
the scrap peeps in for a potential
future Warren's play as we get further
throughout this series. Little bit of
mind game on the battlefields that can
come out in this matchup.
>> Yeah, there it's interesting because if
you think your opponent's going to be
sideboarding accordingly,
>> you know when you're bringing in and
they do not. Yep.
>> So you there is a little bit of a
cat-and- mouse game that you can play.
>> Yeah, as it is just going to be Shawn
with the sneaky deck hand on this second
turn to try and immediately jump up to
point cadence. And I saw a flash in his
hand, which is really nice for this
early setup. Get both your units in,
score, and if Zent presents more than
you can handle, flash them both back,
get the draw from the Dreaming Tree, and
just a really clean early setup.
>> But Zen already behind the eightball in
a major way that as we've seen over the
course of this weekend, this Annie deck
is so good at just basically moving into
uncontested battlefields and scoring
points. So even if you are playing
catch-up here and you're able to clear
out these battlefields, this probably
involves trading cards, it's unlikely
you have something left over after the
fact and then every accelerate unit in
every sneaky deck can. It's a it's a
tough the math is very tough here.
dropping the fight or flight. We went
from a match up where that is the most
valuable card to one where it loses
quite a bit of action as it is just
going to be a cleave to push this
traveling merchant over the top of the
deck hand.
Dewali
with the flash.
Considering if he wants to target both,
he will
thinking if the Porro has any chance of
sticking around,
we target both and get the Dreaming Heat
draw. So, as expected,
>> yeah, I I like that uh play from Dwali a
lot cuz it you don't know for sure if
that poro is going to hold or not, but
the spots where it can hold select for
Zen's hand is so bad that it kind of
doesn't matter. And if Zen has an
average hand or an above average hand,
that porro is not getting your next
turn. So, it's not like it's 0% chance
that the Porro is going to hold, but if
that's happening, whatever the texture
is of Zen's hand, you're a huge favorite
anyway. This is a good way of playing
around the the more powerful ranges of
hands that Zen can have from here.
>> I also think in the spots where this
Porro is holding, you probably just get
the chance to push it back onto Warren
anyway.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> You're going to get another Warren's
trigger. So, uh, does feel very heads up
to be able to just go for that as we are
going to have Zent continue this turn.
Four runes up often. This wants to be
Kai'Sa, but Kai'Sa accelerated is
actually a lot of value in the match up
to be able to clean up some of the
smaller stuff. And it is just going to
be a VI being deployed early. And the
nice thing about Vi is that it is able
to just contend with all the small
stuff. It's already a three baseline,
but you can also just use maybe one or
two pieces from the trash throughout the
game to get a lot of value.
>> The problem is the ride the wind stuff
is, you know, for all the reasons is
good for you, it's also good for your
opponent. That ability to push things
off of combat and uh prevent five from
going crazy. There's also potential, you
know, falling star considerations. Part
of the reason that in the in the Fury
match up specifically, you kind of want
to wait a little bit is because this
gets just cleared out a good percentage
of the time.
>> Don't see much of the hand from Shawn
yet, but I'm seeing looks like a fight
or flight, ride the wind, some of the
movement abilities. Not seeing a lot of
abilities that increase the uh the might
here. No cleaves.
>> Yep.
goes for the trade
accepted by Zent.
Four runes available for Zent to try and
answer whatever the Pouty Porro wants to
ask if it goes to Dreaming Tree or the
Zon Warren. Couple options for Shawn.
Porro to dreaming tree then ride the
wind over. We'll net you a card as well.
going to be Warren's first
like a ride the wind from Zent can be a
response to push the VI in try and stop
Shawn
>> very that feels very high risk low
reward to Yeah,
that ride the wind is going to go into
the bin
for Dewali.
He's going to dig for something better.
Stack deck.
ahead three to one. Five runes to four
for this turn.
Shawn really wants to be able to score
this Dreaming Tree. Keep up the speed of
this match, but he does have a lead. Zen
being at one gives him a little safety
to slow down if he needs to.
>> Kai'Sa
No, Accelerate does not want to run into
a Void Seeker from those four runes
available by Zent. I like the patience
here.
>> Yeah, heads up play there. It's It's so
bad if you get hit by Void Seeker in
that spot and you are ahead on the race
a little bit here. Three points to one.
Uh your position's quite strong and I
just don't think there's any reason to
risk it. The other thing about it is is
I mean Vi is super threatening the
following turn also. You kind of don't
want to leave a a premium sort of
midsize unit just sort of lingering at a
battlefield against a buy.
>> Big hope for Shawn will be that Zent
goes below three runes in the future.
But for Annie with the dark child
ability, that means she would have to
completely tap out on the turn to be
just at two.
We're looking for that safety on the
Kaiser or at least looking for a big
enough board. We're forcing through the
void seeker. Feels good enough.
Recycle two for Vi. Five might ready to
be sent in. Gets above Void Seeker for
the three runes on the side of Shawn
Dollywal.
Darius the followup. This will push Zent
below three for this next turn. So Shawn
doesn't have to worry about Void Seeker
next time. But right now that is seven
might going into the porro
and five might sitting on the other
battlefield. Not a lot of great ways
around this, but we'll see what Shawn
has up with this three runes.
>> Yeah, remember Void Seeker doesn't get
it done here. Darius is going up to
seven from the uh second card trigger.
So, even in that scenario, Dwali is is
showing six against seven.
Sean says fighter flight is good enough
here.
Going to push the Darius. Keep his porro
alive. guarantee that he can score one
side
and should be able to push in and score
the other now that the void seeker is
tapped out of.
>> Yeah, critical there. I mean, that's a
two-point swing right there. That went
from from Darius conquering to the poor
holding.
And when you're talking about a a
matchup that is not really about board
position as such, it's a lot about just
that race to eight, a two-point swing is
huge.
also
just ahead on runes for Shawn. Uh we see
a VI and a Darius in play. There's had
to be these recycles for Zent whereas
Dewali on the other side
>> played the Kai'Sa naturally no
Accelerate played the Porro early on not
a lot of resource expenditure is going
to allow for some bigger turns as we
continue onwards. and he's good low
econ, but she can be even better when
you actually have the ability to still
play around that.
>> There's a, you know, the the the the
champion Annie herself, that's something
where you can really feel the someone
having an advantage in run in runes,
having the that level of optionality
given how much the game comes down to
specific spells is huge. It is a little
bit of an investment getting it down in
the first place, but if you have a lot
of runes going around, you can do
everything in one turn.
>> I I love this Gust. This gust is like a
mana burn. I It's the the flash went
down to try and move back the Vi, but if
Zen wants to replay Vi, that's yet
another rune that is continuing to be
reduced from the side, and it's just a
tempo loss cuz the VI actually has to be
replayed then ready on the next turn.
So, this Gus just kind of does a lot of
work in response to the flash.
>> Yeah, that is a huge swing.
Now Dewali even considering going for
the hold against Darius.
He's holding his own Darius Trafarian in
hand. So he would go up to nine might at
the Dreaming Tree which could be hard to
push over for an Annie deck.
>> Keep in mind that uh
Oh yeah, we're holding up here. I was
going to say that Darius is it's going
to take a lot to get the the two cards
to be played profitably before combat
anyway because a lot of the kind of the
movement stuff is is predicated on
things resolving after the fact. Not
impossible and you can just have two
units here, but it it's going to take a
lot to be able to break this up.
>> This is even better considering Dwali's
got the flash. So in worst case
scenarios, he just brings him home. He
draws his card for Dreaming Tree, but he
can bluff so many different options with
the three runes available. Stack deck
plus Void Seeker is going to buff up the
Darius to seven and still deal four
damage to whatever you're bringing in.
There's just even fighter flight on one
unit if you send the Darius plus
something else. You push the seven might
back and you still have two runes
available. There's a lot of things now
that Zent has to consider
when trying to attack into this dreaming
tree.
>> And that was a that was a really nice
play, too. I think of of setting the PO
back to base. Basically saying if you
want to engage is going to be over here
where I have a lot going on. The porro
is the leaving the parro out of the
battlefield is really letting Zen off
the hook. That's easy attack to make and
you try to set up something for the next
turn where you actually get in that
battlefield here. It's you know if you
move into the uncontested battlefield
that's great. You're still really behind
the race and then my porro is available
to fire back with all of my pump spells
and various things. But if you if you
really want to if you want to brawl this
turn, if you want to spend some
resources using pump spells or whatever,
it's going to have to be in the
battlefield where I have a huge
presence. And you are right. There's an
implication here that Dewali has quite a
bit more than nine implied at that
battlefield. Any two cards now it's
another plus two. And a lot of the cards
he can have have here modify combat as
well.
Vi getting replayed to base
now. Darius Zent trying to decide where
it's going to go. It will go to the
Dreaming Tree. Currently just five, but
of course there is going to be something
played to start. It is Cleave. This does
push Darius to 10, which will put it
above Dolly Wall's nine that he is using
to hold currently.
Draw from the Dreaming Tree still on the
stack.
10 verse 9. Flash always the option that
Dollywall can take, but also he did have
the ride the wind I believe in hand.
There's a few purple cards
hanging out back there.
>> Mhm.
>> Ride the wind does set you up to
potentially win on the next turn, but it
is risky into four open runes from Zend.
>> Yeah. I mean, if you ride the win here
and Zent has his own ride the win,
that's a full clear out.
>> So,
I'm guessing with the race at 5 to2
right now, it behooves to Wall-E just to
not take any huge risks.
Just move back. It's it, you know,
you're probably going to be able to win
combats a lot easier against Darius on
your turn certainly than right now. And
you have a point to give right now.
You're not risking really anything down
a huge externality of giving up a point
here. So, I like airing on the side of
caution using one of your cards. It's
sometimes hard to use profitably in the
matchup and not taking any any needless
risks.
>> Yeah, I mean, and it's just that bonus
if you were holding on Dreaming Tree. So
flash is giving that card draw um and
being able to continue to look for more
of the big units. And it looks like
another Darius was found for the hand
for Dewali. And that just allows him to
push over these last few points a lot
easier by being able to have that kind
of accelerate from hand ready to go.
And Zen will have to spend more if he
wants to stay on point cadence and go up
to four points here. See two runes ride
the wind going to send towards the Z
warrants
and that means that tool is gone for the
turn of Dewali but he also does still
have two runes up to potentially
interact with this.
probably nothing at reaction speed can
be done.
So, we're going to see that showdown
start over on the Warren,
but it seems like Dewali has something
he wants to say about this.
I mean, now this might be a window where
you want to ride the win into the into
the open battlefield.
He's got it. There would be
consideration there. It looks like right
at the win. Is that a rebuke? I think
there is one main board for this team's
annual to help with the E match up. One
main board to side. And it's possible
that that could find a spot, but maybe
not here. I like the ride the wind into
the open battlefield as you mentioned,
banking on there not being another ride
the wind from Zent.
Darius Conquer going to come through.
Two runes still left. We're going to
have the Z Warren's trigger happen and
then the pending showdown at the
Dreaming Tree as Shawn tries to set up
to win on the next turn.
Another
ride the wind looks like it's in the
hand of Zent,
>> but the Rebuke is such a powerful
option to have on your own turn that I
like trying to save it for as long as
possible. Use the ride the wind to scoop
up a point. It's probably not going to
get any better than that.
There's Zent is going to be able to
defend with that additional Ride the
Wind. But now not going to have a lot of
options to protect Darius. So just going
to run it home as it is ready from the
Ride the Wind
and just going to have to kind of let
Dewali go up to seven. Be one point away
from victory
and look to find a way to clear the
board and then set up some kind of hold.
Poro into Warren's likely first
just to dig deeper. Cleave. Darius
Rebuke is not the worst hand already
though. So going to have to see what he
ditches. I feel like it might just be
the rebuke cuz Darius Cleave is so
potent. But with enough runes, dipping
the cleave and keeping Darius Rebuke as
a way that you can kind of go for that
next turn, double conquer win, that
seems like it makes a lot of sense to
me.
>> It It's so much coverage against the
best range of Zen's hand. The cleave is
if you get cleared out, if just stuff
dies, there's no guarantee that you're
going to be able to uh to use that
profitably. the rebuke at this stage.
It's It's hard for it to not be
spectacular.
>> We're going to see
what Dollywall plays out. Finally going
to be Annie.
What spell in the bin is the most
exciting to him.
I wonder what it would be if it's just
ride the win to say, "Hey, I have this.
You have to respect this the entire
turn.
But instead, Darius will be the play.
>> Yeah. I think what what's interesting is
about that is uh Dewali paused and said,
"Okay,
the best thing that I for for me to
likely be able to get back is a rebuke,
which I have not played yet." So,
there's an argument for just saying,
"Okay, I I I sort of want to wait until
I can have the option at least of using
this twice." And so it's not super
valuable to get any other random card
out of my uh trash.
>> That rebuke, you know, usually you would
think in a matchup this fast it wouldn't
find that much value, but you need
answers to the big VI. You need answers
to Darius, and this is a way to just
say, I don't want to deal with you
anymore. Yeah, I think the I mean one
copy feels like how wrong can that go?
Especially when you have uh the the the
Warren's game one of just the spots
where it's not good, you can get rid of
it. And I think just one of generally
are pretty appealing once you are
playing Annie Stubborn as your champion.
Yeah,
>> cuz
uh you effectively get two looks at it a
lot of the times in the games where it's
good and you're not drawing a ton of
copies of it in the games where you
don't want it. and we'll see if it pays
dividends as we approach kind of the
final turns of this game. Zent trying to
set up a board that beats the two
Dariuses sitting at the base of Dewali
in this game one seems very unlikely
and a quick start to this mirror match
showing how explosive it can be
if you can just find that little early
edge. You just have to keep pushing.
Top four
of the Houston regional qualifiers. Both
of them still fighting for the best of
Annie. And in fact, this will decide the
best of Annie. Yeah,
>> as we saw on the other side of the
bracket, Master Y getting the job done,
leaving these two the final Annies
remaining. So, not only do you get a
birth in the finals of the first ever
regional qualifier here in the West, you
also win the best of Annie prize by
winning this matchup.
>> Yeah, a lot on the line here. It's the
tournament semi-finals and the
antifinals.
Master Yi waiting on the other side of
the bracket.
>> Start send just sends in the Darius. Now
has to consider what happens next.
Can push to six. If he can survive one
more turn afterwards, he can try and
look to win right afterwards.
But I look at this hand.
doesn't feel like it's getting there. I
see a flash. I see a sneaky deck hand.
Neither of these cards helpful when your
opponent's at seventh.
>> Yeah. And not cards that are good at
playing defense. And we already know
that Wallally has the rebuke ready to go
the following turn. It's going to be
very, very challenging for Zent to hold
both battlefields, which is probably
what's required here to be able to win
the game.
the stack deck can help look for more,
but also considering how much energy
he's got. Can the stack deck even find
anything helpful
into this? Long time in the tank for
Zen.
>> Yeah, I couldn't see a conversation. It
looked like maybe something going on
between Dewali and the table spotter.
Maybe a uh a question about pace of
play.
>> Untimed rounds here in top eight, but
still got to keep it up. But it does
look like there is some kind of
conversation coming on as Zent has set
down his card. So
see what the consideration may be.
As I'm looking at the hand, I see I mean
really it feels like the stack deck will
be the next thing deployed. So it feels
like Z's waiting for something.
more I look at the spot, the more I am
convinced
that Zent is running out of options. I'm
trying to kind of like think through all
the different cards in this deck and is
there a permutation where you beat
double Darius even kind of on board with
almost any cards in hand that allows you
to play two and get the readies go up to
seven.
And it's
kind of has to be something like
maybe multiple fighter flights, maybe a
rebuke of his own. There's got to be
like a way where you consistently try
and send these back and kind of prevent
Shawn from even getting onto board. I
guess you only have to prevent one side,
not both. So stacking maybe more might
on one side while you continue to look
for these pushes, but the hand currently
one stack deck. You don't even have
another draw
feels very far off.
>> Yeah.
It looks like players are resuming now.
The VI does go into the dreaming tree.
Dewali is just going to let that go.
And he's stubborn. Going to be deployed.
Can grab any spell which will help quite
a bit. But that means Zent will be down
to four total runes to try and stave off
the assault
from Shawn Dollywall
being outsized on the table to say
nothing of whatever wall he has in hand.
>> Considering where to put the Annie now.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you stack with the Darius go up to
eight? Six on the other side feels very
soft,
>> right? I mean it I don't think it's it's
tenable to go to six against an opposing
Darius. All of this is unlikely to work
regardless, but you at least have to get
plausible deniability in the numbers
game before we can talk about anything
else.
>> Yeah, and that is just a ride the wind
picked up off of Stubborn in order to
say, hey, respect this at least. Uh but
you know, we saw the rebuke. We know
there's stubborn available to just be
played out and grab whatever spell that
Dewali wants.
And double Darius already on board
representing 14 as long as you can play
two cards. And Annie Stubborn is two
cards on board. Yes. Reason.
>> So you're all these are always seven.
You have the deck hand at two. So, it's
16 might going up against a total of of
an eight and a three.
Dewali here just trying to consider what
are the ranger tricks that are even
possible at this point.
what order does he want to do it in?
Because remember that the the first
conquer here results in a card drawn.
So in some ways you want to do whatever
the most obvious the most implied action
is first before you draw the card and
see if that changes anything that you
want to do on the second attack.
>> Four runes. The range is still wide for
Annie, but Shawn multiple times in the
interviews mentioned how new he is to
this game, how he's learning
interactions as we go. He's learning the
different decks, what they could have,
constantly asking questions, learning
from every single match. But now he
plays against the deck he's piloted all
weekend. He's familiar with what could
be in the hand, what the range of
options available for Zent are. as we
are going to see the rebuke and you
mentioned you might see the the stubborn
want to grab rebuke and this is the way
to do it. You cast it now stubborn and
then reby it with your three remaining
runes to cast it again.
>> Yeah. And I think that's why uh again
why Dewali on the previous turn kind of
thought about playing Annie and decided
against was he was going to have enough
energy this turn to go rebuke play Annie
pick up rebuke still have enough. And
that's such a powerful sequence for
finishing off the game this turn.
>> And now he grabs it starts with deck
cannon says okay show me that red the
wind that you grabbed from your
stubborn. I'll just send your unit back
to hand.
>> Right.
>> And this gets around the potential of
fighter flight on the other side because
if the ride the wind isn't used now and
then responded to, it cannot uh later
grab the deck hand when you attempt to
send in the Dariuses to conquer the Zon
Warren.
If it's not used now, you get to save
this rebuke to guarantee your conquer.
Expertly navigated by Dewali
as the ride the wind will be deployed to
send the Darius over to the Dreaming
Tree.
Clearly the rebuke, the known
information, the last two chaos runes
>> for Dewali going to send the Darius back
home.
And now this is on board. Even if you
had another way to get over with the
Annie,
you would sweep up both battlefields
against a tapped out opponent.
>> Sneaky Deckan gets there. One more draw.
Double Darius 14 might push through on
two runes. There's no way to answer it.
Dewali going to grab game one. And now
we have the reverse streaming tree from
Dewali. Zon Warren for Zent. And the
consideration is did Dewali keep in the
scrap heaps predicting the Warren or did
he expect Arena's greatest with Zent on
the play and took them out?
Merchants on each side.
So I'm going to start with his three
runes for DeWali.
Let's it go.
the deck hand this time in favor of
Zent.
>> Yes,
>> on the play scoring to two on the very
first turn.
>> And I assume that Dewali would have done
it on his first turn had he had one
rather than the traveling merchant. So,
sort of a reverse of the game that we
just watched. Zent on the play.
Up two zero. And now Dewali having to
play catchup.
>> Going into the Warren with the merchant.
Going to offer the trade. First the
trigger, second merchant get the draw.
This leads me to believe there's no
cleave though because you would go to
Dreaming Tree if you wanted to try and
play for that.
passes priority.
>> Gust in hand for Zent if they want to
try and increase the pace quite a bit.
>> Well, I don't know about that. You are I
think you're probably right that it
means no cleave. There could be a
certain level of I would not want to use
cleave here and my opponent also might
target their sneaky deck hand with
something that pulls back to base.
>> That's true. So because you know Zen is
is sitting there with uh you know three
runes up. It's not a bad spot to play
some of the more marginal tricks and
Dewali might you know if you had let's
say you already have Darius in hand you
know for sure you're playing this turn
with all five of the runes then you
probably just want to stay out of the
dreaming tree altogether.
>> So Gust comes through now it is Kaisa
survivor accelerated into the Warren
once again. Still two runes remaining,
but he has evaded
>> the void seeker.
>> Yeah,
>> his flash will target both to get the
draw from the dreaming tree and to keep
the merchant safe. Couple of triggers,
draw from the dreaming tree and then
there will be the move trigger from the
merchant.
So now the draw from the conquer on
survivor then the discard draw from zon
warrants.
>> Passing it back. It does look like the
inverse of our first game in this final
bout for best of Annie in this
tournament and a spot in the finals.
Dollywall dominant first game, but Zent
starting out swinging here in game two.
Although uh wallally not nearly behind
to the same extent that Zent was in game
number one already picked up a point has
currently control of one of the
battlefields.
So Dewali when when he was on the play
game one Zent really never was
threatening at some points maybe looked
like could stabilize but was never
really threatening to turn it around
here. Dewalant off to a much better
start relatively speaking.
>> Yeah, he's got a gust of his own. Try
and slow things down just a little bit.
There still is the sneaky deck hand to
follow up back into the dreaming tree if
Zent wants. I think for Dewali this turn
if he can keep Zent off four, he'll see
as a success.
>> Yes.
Decan comes through. That's going to be
the third point.
Void seeker to try and clean up the
Kaiser Survivor.
If there's another deck hand in hand,
that's maybe the worst case for Dewali.
>> One was thrown away already from the
traveling merchant. You see the other
>> hand number three.
>> Yep. That's that fourth point for Zen.
It's key in Dewali recognizing it going
to expend the gust says you know what
yes that may come back later but for now
I keep you off of this 2 4 6 8 game
plan.
>> Exactly.
>> All the points matter but the point
holes where you're moving from odds to
evens have a a different implication.
Kaiser number two.
>> So had to force through one void seeker.
Only two runes from Zent though, so not
worried about a second for this
acceleration.
Fighter flight deployed for Zen
targeting
>> his own deck end.
>> Nice.
So
>> the wall just to uh pick up the point
there, but Zent saves a unit has
something that can move into Warren's
next turn.
Dwalli just getting back to the even
scores being at one not needing to go to
three was able to prevent Zent from four
which was impactful
here. forward, of course, trying to
continue to keep up with these break
points. He knows there's a deck hand
that could come to the Warren, the one
from base or the one from hand. Either
way, starting with the stack deck is
Zent. There's another void seeker found
if he wants it to try and clean up
Survivor.
Looks like that's the pick.
[Music]
>> Deck hand into the warrants.
>> Deal says go.
>> Yeah. Motioning saying, "Yep, no
responses there. You conquer."
Seeker once again.
>> Two Kaisers, two seekers,
two draws a piece.
>> Second deck hand from hand. This time
going to five.
Dewali still says no thank you. Void
Seeker of his own.
>> Not nearly as good as how good Zent Void
seekers have been this game, but again,
you just got to put a premium on
fighting over the points.
Just showing how important being on the
play can be in this Annie mirror.
Huge advantages in each early game. able
to be eaked out by the player going
first.
Just trying to find your way to claw
back in when you're on the draw.
Dewali
Darius is the option. It may just have
to be Darius pass though with only one
rune left. Not a lot of action you can
make unless it's a stack deck and that
is the case.
Wonder
[Music]
how
So much on the line for these two
players.
Two full days of riftbound. Nine Swiss
rounds cut to the top 64. We've made it
all the way this semifinal
one match. the best of any card, a seat
at the final table.
>> Just imagine already just the the sheer
volume of winning to get to this point,
right? You couldn't have done really any
worse in 71 and1 the first day. You had
to win four in a row just to get to this
spot. The winner of this is still not
done with the tournament. And it's just
incredible to think of the person who,
you know, who loses in this match. It's
like I did nothing but win for two
straight days and I was still not the
winning Annie player.
>> Not the best one.
>> So many talented Annie players showing
up here in Houston showing why this deck
may actually be the best one or at least
was the best one for the tournament with
the conversion rate to that top eight.
>> Yeah.
may still not be the deck that wins the
day as we've got a Yi waiting in the
grand finals, but certainly a
performance
that goes to show how strong this deck
is.
Fighter Flight deployed by Zent this
time picking Dewali's Darius just
wanting to hold on to material and
points from here on out with this
massive lead looking to extend
I saw the banner just
>> you just want to get it over. I
understand. I understand.
>> Well, initially this looked like Dewali
had a lot more action than Zent in the
previous game.
>> This lead has quickly ballooned.
I mean it, you know, the key thing for
me is in this game, Dewali has not
really gotten to take good advantage
of Darkchild and a lot of this comes
down to are you able to take multiple
game actions? Like on your own turn, can
you advance things? And then on the
opposing turn, can you play some level
of defense or at least complicate
things? And I think some of it is a
function of it's just hard to do that on
the back foot generally.
Um but Dewali has just not really had
the right trick at the right time to
break up the leverage that Zen's been
able to create going first.
>> Yeah. And we've seen really a a tale of
two Void Seekers in this game, right?
The uh Kaiser survivors Dewali
desperately trying to play around Void
Seeker and finding success. He got a
conquer and a draw off of each. But
still, even after that, the fact that it
is such a clean answer that replaces
itself in this matchup, it provides so
much value for Zent throughout this
game. Having so many of these cheap
units to kind of pair with that
efficient removal, almost doing kind of
a Kai'Sa cosplay in this matchup.
All
right, let's start complaining.
tools to continue to push
>> from Zen
on six already. Dewali going to try and
contend
the sneaky deck hand. At this point,
even just seeing more of the sideboard
can help, but this is the same deck
you're running. Yeah,
>> you know the information.
>> Dewali may some of the time too to think
about third and final game.
>> Double arena's greatest is what we've
got in store for us if Zent is able to
take this home.
>> Both players starting at two points
>> in a explosive aggressive mirror.
>> Everyone's been playing for two days.
Everyone's got flights to catch. Let's
just make it a make it a gentleman six
this time.
Wall-ally not completely out of it yet
though. No material on board for Zent.
>> Wall-ally finding a little purchase here
to catch up with that ride the wind.
>> Still four runes available.
>> Thinking hard on this on Warren's
trigger.
Cleave gets dropped. New card found.
Points can come out of thin air in these
purple matchups. Yeah, I mean we're
we're hitting the point here where that
cleave is
it's not exactly a dead card, but uh
needing to
break up a battlefield implies that Zent
has already conquered it and Dewali
cannot win against many more conquerors.
So, it's a uh it's a solution in search
of a problem here and I think it's wise
to pitch the cleave at this point. Try
to find something else.
Vi deployed for Zent is ride the wind to
follow. Fighterflight is in the hand of
Dewali to buy space. Just going to be
the Darius followup for now.
Trigger for Darius.
Was it the third card played though? No.
Second vi then. Yeah, I Yeah, there's no
>> top card of the trash is a unit.
>> Yeah. So,
>> and so
>> Vendarius
can crash that in
the four runes of the wall. I mean,
really, there's no spells that get to
clear your Tfaren. It's just pushes to
worry about.
>> And if you can't answer a push, you
can't answer a push.
>> You can try and go to seven, go to
Dreaming Tree and hold, but holding into
Annie is not a very profitable strategy.
It's setting up this double conquer
while you have the two-point lead.
>> Time to spare.
second five potentially
>> and a pass.
>> Yep.
>> Just a setup. Look for the payoff after
three units. Does get through a single
push.
Can Dewali put something together to
hold into two vise and a Darius
going into the next turn?
as he can get himself to six, but we saw
the same situation with Zent in the
previous game.
>> Dewali took a turn to set up. Zent gets
to six and then the game ends.
>> And it's such a tough spot here for
Dewali, too, because you often when you
have this sort of vi ride the wind
setup, it is kind of allin, you kind of
you you expend all of your resources
doing it. Let's say that Patty Porro
ends up over the dreaming tree. Zen can
start the turn just by sending a VI in
there. There is no need to because
there's a second VI and so many cards in
hand. There's no need to commit to
everything ahead of time. you have a
little bit of ability to sort of probe
it out a little bit, see where it goes,
and maybe tease out a trick that could
could blow up the combo. But that Dewali
is priced into committing to break up uh
one of your less explosive attacks.
>> Looking through the trash
concludes, it's a lot.
Yeah,
>> the vise will be able to be far too big
to deal with, but rebuke and fighter
flight in hand can deal with two of the
three threats on the board potentially.
Over a thousand players
came to Houston to fight it out in this
regional qualifier with only four
remaining.
Two Annies standing tall.
Zent looking to take us to a third game
of this mirror. The double arena's
greatest bout
showing the speed of this deck like no
other can.
as we go to six.
Seven runes left back at home.
Enough to play every card in the hand.
The flash not going to find much use,
but the rebuke and the fighter flight
certainly can into double vias.
>> Yeah, I mean Dewali kind of needs to set
up something where
it at least forces the VI to commit some
amount of resources.
And then you have the rebuke as
potential counterplay. And it's not you
rarely see Vi put in a position to hold.
Not exactly the strongest suit. But
again, Dwali aware that anything any way
to sort of weasle your way out of this
set of circumstances involves Zent
having enough rope to hang himself with.
And that only happens when you put
enough might in the battlefield where
there's even a sequencing error that's
possible in the first place.
>> Yep. Just needing to put the eight to
beat the Darius and then hope that you
can deal with both vys,
>> right?
>> Or that the trash is mismanaged and
there's not enough might for both vys to
be able to get over the top of this.
Zen questioning into the large stack of
runes for Wall-E.
I just want to take a moment to
appreciate
how Riftbound has brought so many
incredible players from all across the
TCG world together.
>> So I I by my own count and I this is not
even exhaustive. Magic the Gathering,
Flesh and Blood,
Hearthstone
One Piece, Pokemon, Yu-Gi-Oh, actual
just League of Legends players.
>> I in terms of we have this new game and
who are the people coming, what are
their gaming backgrounds in this,
>> I've really never seen anything like
this tournament. It's it's people from
every
trading card game, video game, Riot
product, you name it. It's from
everywhere. It's from all around the
world. We have competitors from multiple
continents. We have 1,300,400
people in the main event. A bunch of
people spectating who I was gunslinging
against them. No interest in playing the
main event. Just want to hang out, look
at stuff, play inside events, talk to
the vendors. It's really a fascinating.
I was wondering coming into this of like
what's going to be the shape of the
crowd. And I would not have been able to
guess because it's so uh diverse and so
idiosyncratic to its own thing which has
been very cool. Very very cool.
>> It's it's been kind of beautiful. And I
think that on the competitive side we
get this amazing
thing where this top 64 may have been
the most stacked TCG tournament in
history when it comes to number of top
eights or final finishes. when you
account for all of the different games
that these players had come from and had
those accolades in.
>> Yes.
Now, keep in mind here, Zen still has
access to Annie, too. So, you're going
to see some recycling here to pump a VI.
This is a combination of units that
can't be recurred anyway. Uh, leaving
himself with an a wide array of spells
depending on how combat goes.
Going to start with eight onto the first
VI.
Still considering
when the next swing will come in. Darius
took the dreaming tree, but now
Dewali looking to just hold on the
Warren. Fighter Flight is the first
deployed,
but as you said, Annie Stubborn
available to grab one of these spells
remaining. And there's a Ride the Wind
to try and push this further. Ride the
Wind going to send that VI back in.
Dewali now will have to expend the
Rebuke and I think that leaves him out
of gas.
So, the trash is still plenty big.
>> Yeah. to finish this out
>> and send us to that promised double
arena's greatest
final game
over an hour in.
And I bet if you asked both players,
I think they'd be happy to say what
whoever wins get it over fast.
It's just a level of, you know, mental
fatigue at this point, especially in
this matchup where everything is, it is
very, very hard to play. There's a
combination of just the strategy of
managing the points race, meaning the
tactics of well, you have a lot of
tricks in your deck that play both
sides. They help preserve your units.
They can push your opponent off. They
can prevent them from scoring a point.
They can help you win a combat exchange
offense or defense. And so when you have
this wide array of of tricks that could
be used profitably offensively and
defensively, and everyone's working with
the same materials or very close to it,
that can get awfully complicated.
>> Yeah. Some point, sometimes it's worth
simplifying. Said it a couple times
yesterday, just to simplify the problem.
>> Yeah.
>> Give everything but the ride, the wind
of the VI. Push it in. see what these
last two runes are all about.
Then you've got the anti- stubborn to
still go from there. Second rebuke you
don't have counterplay to.
>> Yeah,
>> that just is what it is.
Everything else can be covered by
pumping this VI
up. Now it has to be past 10. Actually,
that's where the puzzle starts to be a
little bit more difficult
is notably Darius is active. Two spells
have been played. This is 10 on the
point. You have to push this VI up to
11. Now, I guess there is the
possibility that there's not quite
enough in the bin if you don't use the
ride the wind in order to push over the
top of this. And maybe that's the
consideration for Zent
because it would be simple. You could
just spend everything but the right the
wind push in. If you get pushed back,
you grab the ride the wind out with the
Annie and you go from there.
>> That's just 10 currently not winning. So
that may have been what this tanking was
all about.
a situation that seemed a little bit
more simple.
Now going to have to go 10 into 10.
Dolly is going to let the trade happen.
And now you can still stubborn grab the
ride the wind, take Darius over to the
Warren
and wrap this thing up.
Zent is going to be able to grab game
number two here,
sending us to this double arena's
greatest to finish things out to decide
who the best Annie is here in Houston
and also determine our second finalist
who will be taking on the Master Y in
the final. finals
>> and I'm interested on the uh uh the call
here on the arena's greatest because it
seems to me like
this is so bad if you are the ongoing
second right it's a race to six now
effectively I wonder if Zent is supposed
to play in game number two to avoid this
scenario where you get to game three
you're going second and now we're only
playing to six.
>> And I imagine maybe Zent even kind of
pumpfaked himself by thinking, "Oh, I go
the Warren's game two cuz you'll expect
me to go arenas and you'll take out your
scrap peeps where I get to keep them
in." But then you end up in this spot.
This ends up coming around.
>> To me, the scrap peep warren thing is
just kind of it's six of one, half dozen
the other. Obviously, you'd rather pair
it with the Warren than not, but Dewali
might not be playing your game
regardless. He might just be saying,
"I'm cutting them for game two no matter
what." And now you're in the spot where
um you are the one going second in a uh
double arena's greatest game.
>> Yeah. And we'll see if Dewali does have
the sneaky deck hand for the full punish
as he pushes his merchant in. Going to
filter a little bit, but sneaky deck
hand up to four on the second turn of
the game. That is going to be a very
tough spot to come back from.
>> Not a lot of time to make your moves.
>> Yeah.
All
right, the wind dumped. There's the
draw.
Passive actions. The conquer comes
through now. The four runes. It is the
deck hand.
>> Yep.
>> Is there a void seeker? Anything to slow
this down? It looks like no. Four points
for Dewali out the gates.
Initially trade going to be offered.
Move trigger coming through.
Cleave pulled off of that discard and
draw. So at least the optionality now
for Zent to try and win that. But they
are just both going to pass. We will
have the trade accelerated Kai'Sa. I've
seen this somewhere before.
>> Yeah, at least
I mean this is
>> Seeker.
>> That is nightmare scenario for Zent.
Dewali will score up to five off the
hold.
>> Yeah, I mean it when you're playing a
game this short, you got to take some
risk, right? that every every exchange,
every point is amplified. But that was
worst case scenario for Zen.
>> Back to two runes. Dewali can push to
six on this turn if there's a way to
move over to the other arena's greatest.
And Annie at six is inevitable in most
matchups,
>> especially from I mean this spot here
where I mean Zen has nothing.
you know, how are you supposed to stop
just the deck hands, the vise, the ride
the winds? How are you supposed to keep
him off of two points here?
>> And we've already established that Zent
almost certainly doesn't have a void
seeker.
>> Yeah, likely would have been deployed to
stop the deck hand from pushing to four
>> or the merchant something something. You
would have done you would have done
something
>> somewhere on that turn.
Now the consideration. It looked like I
saw a flash and a ride the wind. Both
ways that this deck hand can get over
flash going to be deployed
to move the deck hand back. So now it
can be sent in to the other side. Poor
man's ganking.
Some assembly required,
but there's that critical six point.
So much work done already
for Dwalli.
Not much reason to overextend if he
doesn't need to. Not sure if he has that
many units left over, but he does have a
VI and he's just going to preset this
up. Neither player showing falling star.
falling out of favor in a lot of these
Annie decks.
>> Stack deck to start.
>> What even bails you out of this
situation is end
>> right
cuz you know these decks they don't play
a lot of pure removal. The a lot of the
movement stuff is supposed to be the
proxy for that. But uh when you fall
behind this far
uh not having access to removal means
that it it is just too tricky to kind of
assemble enough things in time.
Especially because the other side a lot
of those you know your quote unquote
proxies for removal will also be
effective in pushing your stuff back and
avoiding wins in combat.
>> Darius goes down. Rebuke is going to
stuff it.
Zent out of runes completely. The Darius
back to hand. Dewali only going to have
four runes for the next turn, but will
be going to seven points with a VI at
home. Only two runes for Zent available
from the Dark Child. And Dewali may just
be locking in that best of Annie and a
spot in the finals at the Houston
regional qualifier.
Just again, one last check to see what
could go wrong here. Yep. You want to
pump a little bit beforehand.
>> Yeah, play around the Void Seeker.
There's no reason not to. Up to five is
realistically. Oh, you can't even void
Seeker. It's two runes.
>> Play around the Gust. Pump it by one.
>> Gust is the one.
>> Up to four. Can't get gusted. Fight or
flight to stop it now.
Gust on the own deck hand.
>> Oh, play it to the other battlefield and
Dewali is making it to the finals. Very,
very nicely done. Uh, obviously a
matchup where going first is a huge huge
deal. But even that aside, there was a
ton of back and forth there. I think the
wall did a very nice job of prioritizing
the tricks, getting some of the the
fidgetier stuff, the stuff that's harder
to convert out of hand first, making
sure that the premium stuff was always
loved back. It's huge. We go from the
longest Annie match that we've probably
ever seen in an Annie mirror to maybe
the shortest in a double arena's
greatest finale. And that will set the
stage for our final as Shawn Dewali
picks up the win, becomes the best of
Annie, and will go on to face Blog on
Master Yi to round out the Houston
regional finals. We're going to go to a
quick break, but when we return, we will
have the finals right here. You don't
want to miss it. Let's
[Music]
go.
Oh,
[Applause]
[Music]
hey.
Heat. Heat.
Oh yeah.
[Music]
Oh,
heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
[Music]
it Oh,
you
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Oh,
[Applause]
[Music]
oh, Oh,
Oh,
[Music]
heat, heat.
Hallelujah.
[Music]
Oh,
[Applause]
[Music]
heat. Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Oh.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Welcome Back to the Houston Regional
Qualifier. I'm Kasanova joined by
Patrick Sullivan and we are on our way
to the finals of this event. Over a
thousand players descended upon Houston
to try and earn their spot as the first
ever RQ champion here for Riftbound. And
now we've got the last two who remain.
Let's take a look at that bracket. See
exactly who that is. is Dewali and BL
both having to make big runs through
this top eight and through this top 64
throughout the day. So, if you look at
that round of eight, that's our, you
know, of course, our top eight decks. We
have two copies of Kai'Sa. Uh, consensus
most popular deck going into the
tournament. I believe 33% roughly of the
field registered as the champion. None
of them were able to move on to the
round of four where we had three Annies,
an Annie Mirror match that we just
watched with Dewali coming out on top
against Zent and the one non Annie
player, Blur, playing Master Yi. We
watched them go over Primemore in the
top four and now another Annie versus Ye
match to finish the weekend.
>> Yeah, and Blark has been on a streak of
slaying Annies to get here. No veggies
in the top eight then primore in top
four and now just Dwali remains and that
is the matchup that he's been liking. We
saw the tech, the rune prisons in there.
We know that the defies exist. We know
that this is a matchup that in China was
what stopped Annie from finding any
success and we'll see if Blard can
continue that statement here in Houston
or if Dewali can push through as the
whole PCG invasion testing team playing
around this Annie deck have said they
feel quite favored into Ye.
We'll see. I mean, you know, you got
some
more long game elements in the San Die
and and Darius, I think, is a key part
of trying to break through. Uh, as you
see, a VI here on the first turn.
>> Yeah, can't miss the two drop. So, if
you don't have another one, Vi will have
to do. And we do have ramp for Blur. You
know, you mentioned all the different
versions having that first copy be the
best copy and going second. There's no
better than find your center going first
mobilize then on your obelisk game
catalyst of AON. So all the different
ways to get the ramp going
>> and I think part of the reason that that
Annie struggles in this matchup is what
are your ways to break up units that are
entering battlefields? You have a
variety of movement spells and the
varying levels of efficacy depending on
what's going on, but a lot of it has to
do with the removal that you find in
Fury. Void Seeker, Falling Star, those
are some, you know, best-in-class
removal spells. And if you look at a
deck like Kai'Sa, for example, a lot of
their units are right in the crosshairs
of that kind of stuff. You trade
profitably with their stuff quite
frequently. Once you're talking about
something like Master Gi that goes so
far over the top, those fury removal
spells are are so much less effective
against big units than they are against
the stuff in the middle that that Kai'Sa
for example presents.
>> Yeah. Now BL yet another turn of ramp,
another find your center going from six
runes to seven here. Will get up to that
magic number nine in the next turn.
Normally that number exciting for the
Aurora, but this is not an Aurora
version. This is just the ramp. Yei
trying to get up to start playing dead
blooms but having some action to follow
it and Blar is going to have that ready
for the third turn.
>> Although two copies of Find Your Center
to open here a little on the the slow
side, clunky side to Wall-ally holding
up to four here. Can't really advance
point total wise beyond this is as setup
as you can be. Uh but we've at least
entered a point where it's sort of
presenting a three-turn clock in some
respects and uh some amount of the
movement stuff pushing things away ride
the win into other battlefields could be
enough to to squeeze this one out before
BL starts deploying way too many large
threats.
>> And now just having to consider what
this turn can look like. If you retreat,
then you do open up the opportunity for
Blark to move in with something like the
Master Yihoned and try and get set up.
If you stay in, it's off to Dead Bloom.
The question is, can you bounce it
immediately? It looked like there may
have been a rebuke in hand, but it could
be a ride the wind. It's hard to tell
sometimes between those cards as we get
these quick glimpses, but the stack deck
to try and find your important tools to
deal with the matchup is going to be
what Dewali looks for.
Yeah, it's kind of interesting because I
to some extent I feel like you have to
try hold both or hold neither, right?
Like I it having one battlefield held at
the end of all of this. That's kind of
the lowest floor and lowest ceiling.
And it looks like DeWalt is going to go
withhold neither here.
sends everything home. Playing a pair of
two drops to add to this with the
merchant and the porro. Just building as
much might at home as possible. Ready to
run in and try and deal with the
mountain that can be a master Yehold.
Aspirin's climb to answer the Zon
Warren's game has been the MO for Plark
so far in this tournament knowing that
yes, Annie shows strength on this
battlefield, but I have aspirants to
respond to make this game go long enough
that I can make up for that acrudeed
value of the extra cycling.
It's mountain drakes also main deck for
Blard without Aurora being seen in this
deck at any point.
just valuing my total.
>> That is that's some honest work right
there.
>> 910
flavor text.
We've seen switchboard masteries before
where they take out all the twos and put
in the Auroras, but at least in the
games we've watched of BLG against these
Annies, that has not been the case,
which makes sense. Aurora not being a
strategy that's always profitable into
Annie with it being so fast.
And so there is maybe a world that
that's where these mountain drakes are
from, but if not, that is just that
vanilla 9 for 10 that BL is valuing
those stats.
>> That's just so much respect. You know,
talked a little bit about
uh going out working with Riot for the
first time, first play test, building
Aurora, and I very quickly got to the
point of it's mountain drake time. There
just not there was just not enough big
old boys to fill out an entire deck and
this was kind of the next best one. Uh
but I have so much respect for playing
it. Just do you are you doing anything
with the fact that it's a dragon? No. Uh
is for some reason 10 might a magic
number? No. Are you just playing with
Aurora and you ran out of stuff to play?
No. Do you have some way of searching
your deck where this has happens to be
the thing you want some amount of time?
No. What you see is what you get. And
this is in the finals.
>> Just a big old guy.
>> Just a just What do you mean? What's
your What do you mean what's my deal?
What's your deal,
>> man? I just like dragons. All right.
>> I'm pretty I'm I'm pretty
straightforward. I'm a 910. I tell a
little story there on the bottom. That's
all I got going on.
And the flavor text is apt. It says,
"After centuries of researchers trying
to understand dragons, the one thing
that they understand is to run. After
centuries of trying to understand why
you'd want a vanilla 10 nothing to say.
There's just nothing.
>> There's nothing to worry about. You
don't need, you know,
>> it's self-explanatory. You see the uh 10
in the upper right hand corner. You look
on the lefth hand side with the cost.
There's no power cost in it.
>> It's all you need to know.
>> All right, Darius Cleave.
That's 10.
>> That is also 10.
>> That's a number we like to talk about
sometimes is there's eight there for the
Tasty Fay folk. Looking like a tasty
snack for Darius. Maybe that's where the
bite came through. M
>> got a little hungry.
Two runes still up though for BL. So
there is action potentially available.
10 on eight discipline or on guard on
the table.
There's the discipline.
Trade offered.
Dewali's going to let it go.
More ramp for Blur.
Rune deck very thin. Going to be on the
full 12 going into the next turn.
But this opens up for Dewali to go to
six. He loses a Darius for his troubles,
but the VI still at home and the trash
getting full.
>> Remember again, you're coming in a
little late here. We are playing to nine
right now, not eight. That's a critical
number.
>> This a pivotal game in the match up in
the context of the finals. We saw Blar
take the victory on Aspirants in his
other win over Annie. Both his other
wins over Annie and needing to drop the
game on the arena's greatest with Annie
on the play and find the win later has
come up for Bl. It can be hard when
Annie gets to go that fast.
This is the opportunity for Dewali to
find the games over BL is to get the win
on Warren when aspirants is there for
this E deck.
>> Yeah, being able to get the aspirin game
is is a huge huge swing.
I have to imagine of the three games,
this is the one with with Dewali at the
greatest deficit just in terms of the
the quality of the the battlefields.
And Dead Bloom has been deployed. BL
having so many runes to work with. Dead
Bloom with four up for something like a
primal strength even if you try and go
as tall as possible.
Defy, discipline,
everything available to Blur. All the
tricks
up to seven on the hold. You don't have
to flinch yet. This can be a full
development turn for Dewali and look to
try and go for the double conquer to
follow. She'll still be playing into
that uphill battle of the Y deck with 12
runes.
Sneaky deck hand past the point of use.
Yeah, Dewalia has kind of freedom of
movement into the one battlefield and
the deck hands not doing anything about
the other one.
>> This merchant though getting a lot of
value. The Warren's helping to fill that
trash, but also this merchant fueling
the VI with this additional move.
But those answers for Blur have been
there in the past and the conquering of
Warren has let him filter as well.
Discipline has been able to dig. Rune
Prison we know is in the main. It's how
he answered one of his Annie opponents
earlier
and stopped their Vide.
Rebuke in hand. The one of tool that
goes up to three post board that helps
this deck with this Y matchup. the one
main
can find so much value. Just as that
rune prison main for Blar, the rebuke
main for Dewali can be the key piece to
unlocking the matchup.
But again, you don't you would you would
prefer to avoid using the rebuke until
it is actually lethal because it is kind
of the the trump card to almost any
defensive measure that bar can set up in
game number one. But the other side of
that is
remember that you still have Annie as
your champion here. And so there is some
incentive to play it just in a spot
that's good to open up the possibility
of Annie pick up the review. You can
play it again even if you don't end up
actually doing it. So there is sort of a
pushpull here with the incentives. It's
nice to hold it but there is also
something to be said for letting it go
and having the option to get it back
later.
>> Yeah. Is there a worry of sabotage main
board is maybe the other question.
>> Yes, there's a sabotage main. It's
better to play it on the dead bloom here
and then be able to grab it again from
the Annie stubborn on the next turn
since you're not populating the
battlefields anyway, right? Dead bloom
can't be played in immediately. But
double rebuke to respond into Bl's next
turn to go for the double conquer might
be what's on the table. And if there's
no main wind wall, there's no main way
to interact with the rebuke, then that
just all but guarantees the win into a
calm body deck that does not have direct
removal spells as these units on the
back row from Dewali push in.
>> So I'm to see here. I mean, this is the
the magic number of of runes needed is
10. 10 gets you to rebuke any rebuke.
It looks like that is
the exact
number of runes that we're sitting on
for Wall-E.
Turn starts. Five runes left unless
there is a wind wall main board
or a mystic reversal, but I doubt either
of those cards have made the main
considering how tight this list seems.
The rebuke's going to come out.
Lar going to have to recognize the
writing on the wall here. If he has an
answer, it has to come now.
>> So, you see three runes recycled here.
Two for the rebuke itself and one for
the deflect cost.
[Music]
One energy floated during that deflect.
Dead bloom's been bounced.
[Music]
Stubborn still in the champ zone. Can
reby this rebuke.
to deal with the master yhoned
don't even have to bother with combat
with recycling these cards for vi just
the rebuke back to hand score up to nine
and the aspirin game the big hill to
climb for Dewali
to set up an advantage in this series
would be his
and with it going through on the dead
bloom. I have to think that there's
likely not
something like the wind wall there.
Trying to think of the the use of
waiting
on casting an ability like that. I guess
I suppose
you do force Dewali to commit the
stubborn now in advance.
Yeah, I mean it it it's possible that
what you would want to do is pick up the
rebuke with the Annie and then make an
attack that goes over the top of the Yei
anyway. So it's it's putting the burden
on on Borg to have two things in a spot
where, you know, circumstantial evidence
suggests that's not the case or else we
would have probably seen a fight over
the first rebuke.
Blur just seeing the cards that are
currently being recycled for the VI
plus five up to eight. Eight would equal
the Y
on its own.
[Music]
curious. I I mean I would my starting
point would just be to at least present
plus one against the Ye.
>> Yeah.
>> To just at least say Yeah. Just
>> going to start with the merchant. Fill
the trash a little bit more.
No response from BL
at least on the move. Now we've got the
showdown. Conquer goes through.
Up to eight.
Little more fuel for the fire. More
options being put in hand, but I'm not
seeing an option that ends up better
than picking up Durbuke.
[Music]
two more potentially just going to vi
go up to 10 plays around exactly a
discipline.
[Music]
just solving the puzzle because at this
point
all these runes available feel like
there's a bunch of different ways that
you can get to the same result in this
game but a victory on aspirants it's
such a boon for the annulist into Yei
I mean, I have to assume that there's
just a, you know, DeWalt at this point
has the resources to kind of play around
every permutation of everything. So,
it's just a, you know, make sure that
you do not make a mistake here when you
have the ability to cover everything
most likely should you, you know, take
your time and map it out.
any stubborn being reached for now.
The one extra energy left up from the
rune that was recycled to the dead bloom
and it is going to be the rebuke. So, as
anticipated,
Rebuke Stubborn, grab Rebuke
now. Going to push
over the Ye,
spend a little bit more, make the VI a
little bit bigger, and as you said,
Yeah. Just covering all the options,
right?
>> Yep.
>> Do everything such that you get as much
stuff in your trash as possible, eat
whatever.
Now, present way over the top.
Discipline goes.
Push up to 10. This is currently 11
coming in from the VI
just takes it. That's the game.
Wall-ally up 1 Z over BL winning on
aspirants where the other Annies failed
against BL which does mean that there
will be an arena's greatest on the play
available for Dewali at some point in
this series that will be an advantageous
spot to be in but for this game too it
is Dreaming Tree and Vile Mos which I
would say a bit more hostile with the
Vile Mos existing but maybe similarly to
the aspirins when it comes to the total
value on these battlefields.
>> It's interesting. You know, I I think
that a lot of players would have the
intuition of, you know, why wouldn't
Wall-E want to try to get a more of an
edge going second? That's the harder
game to win. And when you're in a spot
where you just need to win one out of
two games and you know for sure one of
them you're going to be going second and
the other one should you get there
you're going first. you just want to
create the most leverage possible where
the game where you are the most
advantaged in the first place. So
willing to say look game two is going to
be a struggle no matter what. Even if I
do have arena's greatest it's still not
trivial but that card going first where
I already have a substantial advantage
that's going to be very hard for you to
beat. We are going to have a stack deck
in the showdown as the stalwart porro
moves into the dreaming tree.
Often times gust feels like something
you want to find early into these
porros. But with blur having four runes
up, it becomes a lot more difficult to
get that gust off because there can just
be so many different ways to counter it
out. Whether it's discipline, defy, so
many ways. But it is going to be the
gust anyway and say blur you must do
something and there will be a discipline
to try and counter it out. It looks like
that is going to be the draw for both
that will resolve fizzle gust.
It's an interesting play there too. Very
heads up from the wall-ally
when you're playing against a deck that
has a three cost ram spell, four cost
ram spell and you're talking about Gus,
not exactly the easiest card to convert
profitably in this kind of matchup. That
looks kind of bad, right? Well, he just
got blown out by this removal spell and
blur drew a card for his trouble and all
that. But if you look through the lens
of that's at the expense of playing a
ramp spell that turn if he wants to play
back at you with a pump spell
because you know the ramp spells they
fall off a cliff pretty fast. There
there's definitely a window turns one
and two where they're very very good. I
know that they have the out if you have
all of your your runes out. You draw a
card, but that's nowhere near as good as
jumping from four to six to eight. So
that that play on the service might have
looked bad from Dewali, but I think in
the context of the cards that Blur can
possibly have. It's one of those if he's
got it, it's actually not that bad.
There's actually a possibility he
wouldn't even play it anyway if he had
one of his ramp spells. He might just
say, "Okay, it's I, you know, my uh uh
these cards are timesensitive. I just
have to play it."
>> Yeah, just forcing the action. And we're
just going to see Zna's hourglass is
deployed for blar one on the last turn
one of this and that's going to keep the
porro around but generally wants to be
saved for the master yi the dead bloom
later on and this five at dreaming tree
is going to be annoying for Dewali to
push through but if he's got something
like a cleave or even just a gust this
can be nice once again saying would you
like to to play your pump and tell me
what you have simplify that game state
once more
>> and a really powerful way of playing
around the gear, too. It's a bit of a
slog to try to just, you know, just keep
attacking and things are getting
recalled, whatever. But something like a
bounce spell like Gus is is really
making those inefficient.
Now, Kai'Sa gets to conquer, gets
another draw
for Dewali. Nothing on the board for Bl,
but he does have the double zonas and he
is going into his master Y turn coming
up next. So certainly that will be a way
to deal with the wallally's board.
However, this is a lot of runes being
held up. I know for a fact this is a
three rebuke setup now after game one.
>> All right. Well, time to see what's up.
>> Yeah, the sabotage is going to find one.
Double flash means that Kai'Sa will be
safe and more cards will be drawn off
that dreaming tree. But that rebuke is
something that Dewali really wanted to
have to deal with this early on and be
able to recur with Annie Stubborn. Now
it's at the bottom of the deck.
Now with Blark knowing that the flash
can be played on the Kaiso, there's
consideration to just go to the Vile Mos
and clean up the traveling merchant
since that can't be flashed back, but
decides that the Dreaming Tree is more
valuable and will just commit.
>> Yeah, it's interesting. I I guess my
intuition would have just been to go to
FileM's layer anyway. Um because
bas has ganking and so you have freedom
of movement there
>> and but I guess in I don't know I guess
I guess Dewali has the same options
regardless. I don't know if it changes
very much.
>> Yeah. I think the thought here is if you
do that and then Dewali flashes back the
Kai'Sa draws a card and then reconquers
with the Kai'Sa on the next turn get an
additional card and I think that ends up
being the deciding factor for Blard.
You know, I mean, plenty of runes to
work with for Dewali, but a little bit
low on resources, right? Had to trade
out the flash for a new card. Sabotage
brought him down to two cards. He did
have the draw for the turn. So, we are
going to see a rebuke found and that is
gamechanging. That's why there's three
now in the deck. The additional two in
the board so important. And the big
reason that this team that Dewali told
me they feel favored in this matchup
were these rebukes.
>> Yeah. And and with between the dreaming
tree and the traveling merchant, you do
look at so many cards. Now, something to
keep in mind here, you might say, "Okay,
well, you just play Annie, pick it up,
and whatever." Remember that Blark has
access to sabotage. We saw that earlier.
Sabotage can't do anything about Annie
in the champion zone. Can't do anything
about the reuke and the trash. So Dewali
does not want to preemptively do
anything that could lead to exposure to
sabotage. Just say, "Okay, it's here.
It's a very powerful option that you
have to play around and you don't have
any sort of disruption that can break it
up."
>> Now Dewali at five and we knew there's
another flash. So this Kai'Sa can
continue to get brought back every time
that Blur replays Master Yi to try and
deal with this. And so while Dewali
isn't set up to win on the next turn
from going from six to eight, he is at
five now with a massive tempo advantage
and has developed enough might on the
board where now he can threaten from
multiple axes of both the might level
and the rebuke.
>> And it's interesting we talked about uh
you know vile moss through the context
of well once the Annie player puts
something there it's stuck. BL might be
having the same issue too. Like
obviously you want to break up this uh
traveling merchant that's sitting there
holding for a pointed turn, but anything
that you commit there that doesn't have
ganking is also stuck the same way and
you're so far behind the point race.
Yeah. And it is just going to be a dead
bloom. But that means Bl is completely
tapped out. So he's at the mercy of
whatever Dewali can piece together. Yes.
All right. The merchant gets to go
bye-bye. The flash is going to get cast
to just bring back the Kai'Sa. This is
just for those draws that we were
talking about earlier. You get the draw
from the dreaming tree now. And now when
you go in with the Kai'Sa to conquer,
you get another card to find all of the
answers you could need to a master Yi
opponent that has no runes available to
them.
The agency on this Annie deck can
provide so much when it comes to these
two skilled pilots. BL is now at the
mercy of Master Yi and playing the one
big guy per turn. Well, Dollywall is
looking for a million different options
for how to try and dismantle the hand of
the Master Yi. Two Proving Grounds
champions making it to the end of the
tables and they are trying to prove
which one is best. And Dark Child is
making a hell of a case.
>> And here we go.
>> Rebuke grabbed. It is going to be spent
immediately on the dead bloom as you
must to play around the sabotage
just to push to seven recognizing that
holding to eight is a very real
possibility in this spot as you've got
seven might on one end and you can put
seven on the other and there's only
going to be eight runes available and
Master Yi is horrible at dealing with
forks. Gotta say it has not been a great
game for the hourglass.
>> No,
>> it is not real bad.
>> There's been a lot a lot of units going
back to hand. Not a lot of them dying in
combat.
>> See if we can break out two. But this is
not a a spot that E plays well from.
Eight, nine cards in hand. So many
things just sent back.
[Music]
One side far too big for the dead bloom.
The other doesn't matter. Just a little
gumbo. A traveling merchant there
looking to hold the vile ma's layer
as Shawn Dollywal
starting the game only mere weeks ago
learning this Annie deck that his team
developed together
and taking it the distance. Not only the
best Annie, but the best in the
tournament here at the Houston Regional
Qualifier.
I
>> think BL's going to do one last survey
here and probably give this up. Yep.
>> And there it is. Your winner, your
champion, Dewali here in Houston, taking
down the first regional qualifier for
Riftbound in the West. I mean, so much
talk about this deck coming in as
something of a of a counter to Kaiso,
and I don't know if that's necessarily
the matchup you're looking for in the
finals, but the one copy of Rebuke in
the main and then two more in the
sideboard showed a lot of respect for
the matchup. The Rebuke was incredible.
I think Wally did a very nice job of of
managing sort of the am I trying to
double hold past the turn or am I
pulling everything back to prevent an
accelerate unit? a master ye from eating
something for free. We didn't even get
to the arena's greatest. We did not get
that far. That just a clean 2.
Congratulations.
>> Didn't even need it. As now we get to
celebrate with our winner. We're going
to send it to the floor with Barrett and
Shawn Dollywal.
>> I have the absolute honor of
congratulating the first ever English
regional qualifier champion, Dewali. I
present to you the prestige Buccaneer
Misfortune prize champion card. Wally, I
have one big question to start things
off. How do you feel in this exact
moment? There can only ever be one
first. It's It's actually insane. Like I
I can't believe it's happening. Like
this is the biggest tournament I've won
and I just feel so amazing. Um I love
the game. It's so good and just couldn't
be happier, man. To do it first is
awesome. Yeah. and you're incredibly
good at it as we've all just witnessed.
Take it down entirely. I I truly can't
believe a legend that nobody else has
been representing for a while. What did
you do and who can you thank? Anyone you
would like to shout out for this
achievement that you're taking right in
this moment. Um I'd like to shout out uh
Tar specifically. He uh worked a lot on
the Annie deck. Um I tested with a lot
of people. access with like NIA T, uh,
Michael Yazaker, like you know, a lot of
people that I played with to help me get
here. Um, I want to shout out my sponsor
like, uh, Invasion, TCG, and PCG. Um,
like they they, you know, I wouldn't be
here without them being able to support
me. Uh, my girlfriend and my parents
back home. It's just unbelievable. Like,
you know, it's a it's a collection of
friends and family that have got me
here. So, thanks to them. That's exactly
what makes Riftbound great. the
community, the family, the people, and
you are the first to take home this
trophy for the regional qualifier
champion.
Congratulations to Dewali one more time.
[Music]
[Applause]